I WAS UP HERE LAST TIME.
THAT IS RIGHT HERE.
I'M ABOUT TO MAKE SOME.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY --
MA'AM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY.
BARUCH HAND HERE DEEP
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
QUORUM IS PRESENT -- THIS IS THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDARS ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB THREE TWO TWO
LACKEY PEACE OFFICERS TRAINING.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB FIVE FIVE ONE
BRO FATAL VEHICULAR ACCIDENTS
CHEMICAL TEST RESULTS.
I DON'T NUMBER EIGHT AB SIX TO
NINE SMITH ARE CRIME VICTIMS TO
CALIFORNIA VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB SIX SIX
TWO CUNNINGHAM CRIMES AGAINST
MINORS.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB SIX
SEVEN FIVE RODRIGUEZ PRISONS
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB SIX
EIGHT OH PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS MENTAL HEALTH
TRAINING -- ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB EIGHT OH THREE
GIPSON PEER SUPPORT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB NINE
FOUR ONE CUNNINGHAM CRIMES
PUBLIC RECORDS DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB TEN
FIFTY TWO PEACE OFFICER TRAINING
HATE CRIMES.
IS THERE A MOTION.
SO MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CALL THE ROLL.
JONES SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I A CASSETTE
CALENDARS APPROVED -- WILL GO TO
THE FIRST ITEM -- EVAN LOW AB
[inaudible]
NINE NINE SEVEN I REMEMBER.
ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
A BEING.
NINE NINE SEVEN WITH RESPECT TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND FIRE ARMS OVER
50% OF SUICIDES ARE COMMITTED
WITH A FIREARM THIS THE BILL AS
A FOLLOW UP.
TO A PREVIOUS BILL THAT WE
PASSED I'M STILL ALL LAST YEAR --
THAT WOULD PROHIBIT INDIVIDUALS
FROM POSSESSING FIREARMS IF THEY
WERE.
PUT UNDER FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLDS
TWICE -- WITHIN A CALENDAR YEAR --
THIS CLOSES A LOOPHOLE -- BY
RESTRICTING THE PURCHASE A
FIREARM WIDE THAT INDIVIDUAL IS
WAITING FOR A COURT HEARING A
WITH ME AT TODAY IS HALEY
RENTALS DEPUTY COUNSEL WITH THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA AS WELL AS
DOCTOR FOR HE ONE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION.
IN ORDER TO THE UNIVERSE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US -- I'M HERE
BECAUSE I'M A PSYCHOLOGIST IN A
FEW YEARS BACK I WAS ACTUALLY
WORKING IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
WITH A TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER FEMALE
WHO'S ACTUALLY SENT TO ME FOR
TREATMENT FOR FAMILY
REUNIFICATION.
AS A RESULT OF PUTTING HER CHILD
IN DANGEROUS ENOUGH TO THE
LOCATIONS -- THAT SHE ACTUALLY
SEPARATE THESE TYPE OF BEHAVIOR
BESIDES HER PSYCHOTIC BREAK WAS
DRIVING BACKWARDS IN A CAR IN A
PARKING LOT A HIGH RATE OF SPEED
WITH A CHILD IN THE BACK.
AS WELL AS THE SOLUTION WAS SHE
WAS BEATING HER SON.
DURING TREATMENT SHOWS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE MEDICATION
AND TREATMENT AND AS WE PREPARE
TO THE FINAL COURT CASE --
HEARING A WEIGHT -- TOLL RIGHT
WAS GOING TO BE DETERMINED WHEN
SURE THAT SHE UNDERSTOOD THAT
HER SON WAS GOING TO BE ADOPTED
BY HER MATERNAL GRANDMOTHER.
WHICH WAS BASICALLY IT --
CLIENTS MOTHER AT THE DATA
SHESHA RECEIVED A FINAL COURT --
DECISION TO TERMINATE HER
PARENTAL RACIAL SO DISTRAUGHT
AND FORTUNE THREE DAYS LATER SHE
WAS FOUND DEAD FROM A SELF
INFLICTED GUNSHOT WOUND.
THIS OBVIOUSLY HAS ACTUALLY A
HUGE IMPACT ON ME AS A
PSYCHOLOGIST AND THIS IS THE
REASON WHY I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
SB [inaudible]
NINE NINE SEVEN OKAY YES.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS HALEY
REYNOLDS I'M A DEPUTY COUNTY
COUNSEL WITH THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA.
I'M JOINED THIS MORNING BY THE
DEPUTY COUNTY COUNSEL COULD BE
THE NARAYAN.
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINE NINE SEVEN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A MAN IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WAS TAKEN INTO CUSTODY ON
A FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLD AFTER HE
THREATENED TO COMMIT SUICIDE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT CONFISCATED HIS
WEAPONS UPON TAKING HIM INTO
CUSTODY THE MAN WAS NOT
ULTIMATELY ADMITTED FOR A CUTE.
ENTRY INPATIENT TREATMENT.
AND THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE FILED A
PETITION TO PREVENT THE RETURN
OF HIS WEAPONS THE MAN RESPONDED
TO THE PETITION AND REQUESTED A
HEARING.
AND DURING THE PREPARATION FOR
HIS HEARING HE COMMUNICATED
COUNTY COUNCIL THAT HE WAS STILL
SUFFERING FROM DEPRESSION AND
HAD SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
AT THE HEARING THE COURT FOUND
BY A PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE
THAT RETURNING THE WEAPONS TO
THE MAN WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN A
DANGER TO HIMSELF AND ORDERED
THAT THE WEAPONS BE DESTROYED.
AFTER THE HEARING THE MAN
COMMUNICATED TO COUNTY COUNCIL
THAT IT DIDN'T MATTER BECAUSE HE
COULD JUST GO BUY ANOTHER GOTTEN.
UNDER EXISTING LAW DESPITE A
COURT ORDER THAT A PERSON WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS SHOULD NOT HAVE
HIS GUNS RETURNED HE CAN BUY
WEAPONS THAT SAME DAY.
AB NINE NINE SEVEN SEEKS TO
CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE.
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO PROCESS IN
THE WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS
CODE TO PROHIBIT GUN OWNERSHIP.
FOR A PERSON THAT WAS TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY ON A FIFTY ONE FIFTY
HOLD BUT NOT ADMITTED FOR
TREATMENT.
HAD HIS WEAPONS CONFISCATED AND
HAD A COURT ORDER ENTERED TO
HAVE THOSE WEAPONS DESTROYED.
AB NINE NINE SEVEN PROVIDES A
LOGICAL AND STREAMLINED SOLUTION
TO MODIFY AN EXISTING PROCESS TO
KEEP GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
PERSONS WHO MAY USE THOSE
WEAPONS TO HARM THEMSELVES OR
OTHERS.
THANK YOU ANY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
AMANDA LEVY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION YOU
HEARD THE COMMENTS OF DOCTOR
LONG WE ALSO WANTED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS COREY
CELLS ALONE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING MARK -- GEORGE IN
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB -- NINE NINE SEVEN
THIS OF LAW PROPOSE LAW IS
UNNECESSARY GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS ALREADY
COVERED THIS AREA AND THEY DO IT
BETTER.
ON THE EMERGENCY GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER ALLOWS FOR AN
EX PARTE ORDER THEN THAT
INDIVIDUAL RELINQUISH THEIR FIRE
ARMS IMMEDIATELY.
AND IN THE CASE OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO THE
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL ON A FIFTY
ONE FIFTY HOLD.%
ON AND THE OFFICERS HAVE
CONFISCATED THEIR WEAPONS THEY
COULD FILE IMMEDIATELY FOR THE
FIFTY ONE FIFTY THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE TO WAIT THE THIRTY DAYS--
PROPOSED UNDER AB -- NINE NINE
SEVEN AB -- NINE NINE SEVEN DOES
NOT PROVIDE FOR DUE PROCESS OR
NOTICE ALL OF WHICH OF THE GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER DOES
BECAUSE INDIVIDUAL IS SERVED
WITH THE ORDER.
THEY GET A HEARING IN FRONT OF A
JUDGE AND THERE IF THERE IS NOT
AN EMERGENCY THERE'S A THIRTY
DAY PERIOD THE FILE A GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER THE
SAME AS PROPOSED.
IN THIS BILL.
ADDITIONALLY EIGHTY NINE ON NINE
SEVEN IS IN CONFLICT WITH
EXISTING LAW -- THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION WHICH
THEY SURE I'M SORRY.
AB NINE NINE SEVEN IS IN
CONFLICT WITH THE ADDITION WITH
EXISTING LAW WHICH SAYS IF
SOMEONE.
IS NOT HOSPITALIZE THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO GET THEIR WEAPONS BACK
AND I UNDERSTAND THE SITUATION
ON IN URBAN AREAS WHERE THEY ARE
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE VYING FOR
BEDS IN PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS.
AND THEY OFTEN -- INDIVIDUALS
WHO MIGHT BE HOSPITALIZED
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
ON ARE NOT HOSPITALIZED PERHAPS
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY OR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
OR ON SOME OF THE URBAN AREA LOS
ANGELES.
BUT THE GUN BY EMERGENCY GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER DOES
ALL OF THIS AND IT DOES IT AND
THAT'S IN THE PENAL CODE.
AND IT DOES -- FASTER AND WITH
THE CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS
OF NOTICE AND DUE PROCESS.
SO -- AB EIGHT NINE NINE SEVEN
IS UNNECESSARY AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER QUIRK.
SO WE HEAR ON THE ORDER OF
THIRTY BILLS EVERY WEEK MOST OF
WHICH GET OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AND THE CASE BEING MADE BY THE
OPPOSITION IS GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS DO THIS
ALREADY WHICH IS WHAT I BELIEVE
AS WELL.
PRESSING YOUR CLOTHES YOU COULD
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
BUT MY CONCERN IS AND IT'S THE
SAME THE GOVERNMENT LAST
GOVERNOR HADN'T WHO KNOWS ABOUT
THIS GOVERNOR.
IS THAT -- THE AMOUNT OF LOS WE
HAVE ON THE BOOKS SORT OF LIKE
DOUBLES EVERY FEW YEARS.
IT'S HARDER AND HARDER TO KNOWS
WHAT LEGAL AND ILLEGAL SO I JUST
AS SOON IF IT DOES THE JOB HAVE
THE GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER -- TAKE CARE OF IT.
OKAY A QUESTIONS CAN YOU ADDRESS
THAT.
THANKS.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS THAT --
PULL THE MIKE A LITTLE CLOSER.
TO THANK YOU.
I'M.
THE GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER.
SPEAK INTO THE MIKE AND VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
WE BELIEVE DID NOT ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THIS POPULATION AND IT'S
NOT ONLY THAT IT'S NOT ADEQUATE
IT'S SIMPLY NOT THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY TO YOUR POINT OF
HAVING TOO MANY LAWS ON THE
BOOKS.
THE GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER IS ASKING FOR PUZZLE
PIECES TO BE DIG SIDE TOGETHER
RATHER THAN STREAMLINING AND ARE
USING AN EXISTING PROCESS.
IF WE WERE TO SAY THAT OFFICERS
LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD RELY ON
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
THAT WOULD REQUIRE A COMPLETELY
SEPARATE PROCESS TO BE PURSUED
IN A COMPLETELY SEPARATE COURT --
THE EIGHTY ONE TO PETITION THAT
IS FILED IS HEARD IN CIVIL COURT
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
ARE HEARD IN FAMILY COURT AND
THE AB.
PETITION PROCESS UNDER EIGHTY
ONE OH TWO WOULD STILL HAVE TO
HAPPEN.
AND ON TOP OF THE GT R. O.
BECAUSE OF THE CONFISCATION OF
WEAPONS THAT OCCURS IN THE FIRST
INSTANCE WHEN SOMEONE IS TAKEN
INTO CUSTODY.
ON A FIFTY ONE FIFTY SO WHAT WE
ARE PROPOSING IS SIMPLY USING
THAT EXISTING PROCESS TO ADDRESS
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION THAT
HAS BEEN TAKEN INTO CUSTODY.
ON A FIFTY ONE FIFTY HAD THEIR
GUNS CONFISCATED THERE'S THIS
LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
THEM PURCHASE NEW GUIDANCE
RATHER THAN ASKING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND AND DRAINING
THOSE PRECIOUS RESOURCES.
THAT COULD BE PURSUING GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS THAT
ARE MORE NEEDED.
THIS ALLOWS THEM TO PROVE TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT THIS WHAT THE
EXISTING LIGHTING ONE OH TWO
INTENDS WHICH IS TO KEEP GUNS
OUT OF THE HANDS OF SOMEONE.
WHO'S BEEN FIFTY ONE FIFTIES AND
HAVE THEIR GUNS CONFISCATED.
SO.
HAS THERE BEEN A YOU KNOW. TO
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S POINT
THERE LAST TO PROCESS RIGHTS IN
YOUR PROPOSE EACH.
MECHANISM FOR EXAMPLE NOTICE
RATE SO WHY DON'T HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED PUTTING THE SAME DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS INTO THIS PROCESS
ARE USING THAT.
EIGHTY ONE YES OUR OF OUR CAMP
THANK YOU FOR RAISING THAT WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
CONSIDERING SEVERAL AMENDMENTS
AND THAT IS HIGH ON OUR LIST WE
HAVE DRAFTED SOME LANGUAGE
ALREADY TO INCLUDE A NOTICE
THERE IS CURRENTLY A NOTICE.
THAT IS MAILED ALREADY FOR THE
CONFISCATION PIECE BECAUSE A
PETITION IS FILED THAT TRIGGERS
A NOTICE TO BE MAILED TO THE
PERSON IN ORDER TO RECEIVE.
AN OPPORTUNITY REQUEST A HEARING
ON THOSE GUNS THAT ERE
CONFISCATED SO THIS WOULD SIMPLY
BE AMENDING THAT NOTICE TO ALLOW
THEM TO ALSO RECEIVE NOTICE THAT
THERE ADD THIS PETITION PROCESS
IS ALSO REQUESTING A BAN ON
OWNERSHIP FORGOTTEN. FOR GUNS
FOR THIS PERSON FOR FIVE YEARS.
AND IS THE STANDARD THE SAME IF
SEEKING IT THROUGH THE OTHER
PROCESSES THIS PROCESS.
THIS STANDARD IN EIGHTY ONE OH
TWO IS PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE
AND I BELIEVE AND CLEAR AND
CONVINCING FOR THE GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER -- SO THERE IS
THERE IS A DIFFERENT STANDARD
BUT THAT IS ANOTHER AMENDMENT WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO CONSIDER OKAY
YEAH BECAUSE I THINK THAT THIS
BODY HAS SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THE GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER.
BALANCE IS THE NEEDS OF THE GUN
OWNER ANNE'S. TO BE SAFE AND THE
GONNA BE SAFE IN THIS CASE BUT
SO I THINK NEARING THOSE RATES
WHILE USING A MORE EFFICIENT
PROCESS WOULD MAKE MORE SENSE TO
ME.
I AGREE THOSE ARE CERTAINLY
AMENDMENTS WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
CONSIDER.
DID YOU.
AND IN I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
CONCERNS AB YOU KNOW GENERALLY
WHEN I HEAR THE WORD LOOPHOLE.
I HEAR THAT IS AN END RUN AROUND
DUE PROCESS AND WE HAVE DVR ROSE
CURRENTLY ON THE BOOKS -- AND
THEY DO COVER ALL POPULATIONS
IT'S JUST A MATTER REALLY OF YOU
KNOW.
THE PROSECUTION FIGURING OUT A
WAY TO CIRCUMVENT -- YOU KNOW
STANDARDS THAT ARE VERY CLEAR
THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS AND HAVING
SOMEONE HAVE THE FENCE. TO SHARE
COMPELLING EVIDENCE YOU KNOW
AGAINST WHATEVER -- MAY BE
PRESENTED IN COURT AND SO I YOU
CAN KEEP COMMUNITIES SAFE
WITHOUT COMPROMISING CIVIL
RIGHTS AND CIVIL LIBERTIES AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND WAYS
TO KIND OF STAY IN THAT LANE --
BECAUSE YOU START ENCROACHING --
DOWN A DANGEROUS ROAD OF YOU
KNOW BIAS AND PREJUDICE THING --
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES AND SO I
WOULD HOPE I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THOSE AMENDMENTS.
YEAH WE WOULD CERTAINLY BE YOU
KNOW ARE WE ARE INTERESTED OF
COURSE IN PRESERVING THOSE DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS AND I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT.
REQUIRING TWO SEPARATE PROCESSES
IN TWO SEPARATE COURTS IS ALSO A
HINDRANCE ON DUE PROCESS RIGHTS
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES THE PERSON
RESPONDING TO ALSO BE.
APPEARING IN TWO DIFFERENT
COURTS ON TWO DIFFERENT
PROCESSES IN EIGHTY ONE OH TWO
AND THE GT R. O..
I WOULD ALSO JUST I'M POINT OUT
THAT THE GT R. O. IS A GREAT AND
USEFUL TOOL AND WE'RE EXCITED TO
USE IT IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
IT WAS I'VE LOOKED AT SOME OF
THE LEGISLATIVE HISTORY AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT A G. B. R.
O. IS REALLY INTENDED TO COVER
THE POPULATION THAT IS NOT
ALREADY COVERED BY.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY I'M IS
SPECIFICALLY WAS INTRODUCED IN
RESPONSE TO THE ISLA VISTA
SHOOTING IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
THE YOUNG MAN HIS FAMILY HAD
CALLED TO HAVE POLICE COME.
POLICE EVALUATED HIM A
DETERMINED HE DID NOT MEET THE
CRITERIA FOR FIFTY ONE FIFTY AND
AT THAT POINT BOTH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE FAMILY
MEMBERS HANDS WERE TIED.
INTO THE GT R. O. WAS INTRODUCED
TO COVER IT I NEED AND A
POPULATION THAT IS BEYOND THAT
IS BEYOND THE SCOPE OF MENTAL
ILLNESS.
AND IT WAS AN UNDERSTANDING OF
THE LAWMAKERS THAT FIFTY ONE
FIFTY WAS ALREADY COVERING THOSE
PERSONS WHO MAY BE DANGEROUS AND
MENTALLY ILL.
AND SO IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
FIFTY ONE FIFTY IS DOING WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND IT TO DO WE JUST SEE
THIS AS A NECESSARY -- CLOSURE
AND AND OF COURSE WENT TO INSURE
DUE PROCESS RIGHT STAY INTACT SO
WHERE THE POLICE OFFICE.
NINE WHERE THE POLICE OFFICERS
NOT TRAINED TO ADEQUATELY
DETERMINE.
HIS STATE OF MIND OR DID THEY
JUST NOT PRESENT EVIDENCE THAT
WAS COMPELLING ENOUGH.
I CERTAINLY CAN'T SPEAK TO HAVE
WHAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES WERE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN ON WET WHEN
WHETHER THE POLICE OFFICERS WERE
PROPERLY TRAINED BUT I DO KNOW
THAT THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SKINNER.
AT AND PRESENTED THE BILL AND
RESPONSE TO THAT SITUATION.
MR COURT YEAH I HAVE ONE OTHER
PROBLEM WITH THE BILL.
AND THAT IS -- PERSON'S GONNA
HAVE A FELONY SO YOU'VE SAID
THIS PERSON IS.
MENTALLY UNSTABLE.
IF THEY GO OUT AND BUY A GUN
THEY NOW HAVE A FELONY ON THE
RECORD.
SINCE MENTALLY UNSTABLE BUT
NEVER POSSESS TO GUIDE.
THEY CAN GO OUT AND BUY A GUN.
AND THEY'VE COMMITTED NO CRIME I
JUST FIND PARTICULARLY THE
FELONY ASPECT OF THIS.
ARE TO BE -- SOMETHING I CAN'T
SUPPORT.
AT THIS TO ADDRESS THAT CONCERN
IF I MAY I'M.
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE INCLUDED
IN AB ONE OH TWO MIRRORS THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S INCLUDED IN
EIGHTY ONE OF THREE WHICH IS AB
MECHANISM THAT PUTS A BAN ON
OWNERSHIP FOR PERSONS WHO ARE
COMMITTED -- EXCUSE ME ADMITTED
FOR INPATIENT ACUTE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT AND THAT IS WHY
WE'VE INCLUDED THAT LANGUAGE
IT'S A MAKES IT A WAFFLER.
AND WE ARE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
AMENDMENTS TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT IS A CONCERN AND TO THE
EXTENT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PERSONS THAT ARE MENTALLY ILL
AND HAPPEN WHETHER THEY'RE
COVERED AND WHETHER THEY CAN
HAVE GUN OWNERSHIP.
I'M IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT IT'S NOT JUST A QUESTION OF
PROBABLE CAUSE OUT IN THE FIELD
WHERE SOMEONE IS.
ASSESSED TO BE MENTALLY ILL THIS
IS REQUIRES A PSYCHIC.
PSYCHIATRIST REVIEW BUT THEN
ALSO A COURT RUBIO AND THAT'S
THE IMPORTANT.
THEIR THAT REALLY SEPARATES
THOSE POPULATIONS IS THAT A
COURT HAS REVIEWED AND FOUND BY
A PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE THAT
THIS PERSON.
SHOULD NOT HAVE WEAPONS BECAUSE
OF THE DANGER THAT WOULD PUT.
POSE TO THEMSELVES AND OTHERS.
OKAY THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
AND DID YOU WANT.
HIM TO THAT'S PARTY OR CLOSED
DID YOU WANT.
HE RAISING YOUR YOUR WITNESS
WILL RAISE YOUR HAND LIKE A JACK
IN THE BOX OR HAS -- THANK YOU --
I AM NOT AN ATTORNEY SO NOW HERE
ARE YOU LAW I'M A PSYCHOLOGIST I
DEAL WITH PEOPLE'S PAIN AND ALSO
THE PAIN FOR THE STATE FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THOSE WERE
DECEASED -- I ALSO MADE
EDUCATORS TO DOCTOR LEVEL
STUDENTS AS WAS MASTER LEVEL
STUDENTS I SUPERVISE AND ALSO
OVERSEE A LARGE NO HEALTH.
CURRENTLY SO CISCO.
I WAS ALWAYS UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THE LAW DID
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS OR HAVE
THEIR GUNS TAKEN AWAY OR FARMS
IF YOU WISH IT WERE TO BE.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY AND IT REMEMBER
IT IS A DANGEROUS SELF OTHERS
AND CLEARLY DISABLED AS A RESULT
OF A MENTAL ILLNESS -- THE
PERSON THAT I SHARED THE STORY
WITH I WAS ALWAYS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT SHE WOULD NEVER
BE ABLE TO ACCESS A FIREARM.
AND IF SHE IF THE LAWS WERE
ACTUALLY IN PLACE AND THINGS
WERE WORKING.
ACCORDINGLY I HOPE I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN HERE SPEAKING WITH YOU
TODAY SO PLEASE TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU AND MISTER LOW YOU
MAKE CLOTHES THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
THAT MADE BY A COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND LOOK FOR TO OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON ADDRESSING SOME
OF THESE OUTSTANDING ISSUES
SHOULD THIS BILL BEFORE.
I HAVE A QUESTION OF THE CHAIR.
WHICH IS WE'VE HEARD DISCUSSIONS
OF AMENDMENTS.
WILL YOU TAKE A PERSONAL WELL I
SHOULD SAY PROFESSIONAL INTEREST
IN THIS [inaudible]
OUR TO SURE THAT WE GET THE
RIGHT SET OF AMENDMENTS.
WELL YOU CAN ANSWER THAT IN HERE --
SO OF THE WAY WE'VE BEEN IN WELL
ONE BECAUSE OF OUR OUR CALENDAR
AND AMOUNT OF BILLS WE HAVE --
IT KEEPS REAL DIFFICULT TO LIKE
PUSH THINGS OFF. TO THE NEXT
WEEK AND AT THAT ALMOST AND
BEGINNING TO POWER IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT SAYING THAT -- WON THE WAYS
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH SOME OF
THESE -- IS WE'VE UP EITHER ALL
NON VOTED ALREADY VOTED DOWN A
BILL TO GIVE.
AND THEN AFTER RECONSIDER AUTHOR
THAT'S A RECONSIDERATION SO WE
CAN WORK ON IT.
DO A VERY LONG PERIOD OF TIME
AND SO -- IF IF THAT IS THE CASE --
BECAUSE FOR ME I I HAVE SOME
SOME CONCERNS -- TO OBVIOUSLY IT
BOTHERS ME -- WHEN WHEN I WHEN
YOU STIGMATIZE A WHOLE
POPULATION?
OF INDIVIDUALS NUMB NO MATTER
WHAT -- AND AND I AND I LIKE TO
SAY -- I'VE ALSO HEARD PEOPLE
SAY HEY LOOK THERE A LOT OF
WHITE MALES WHO COMMIT SOME
HEINOUS THINGS.
AS FAR AS MASS SHOOTINGS AND IS
IF YOU LOOK AT MOST A MASS
SHOOTING BUT I WOULDN'T TRY TO
TAKE STIGMATIZE THAT GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
AND TRY TO TAKE AWAY ALL OF
THEIR GUNS THE ADS WOULD NOT.
BE SOMETHING I WOULD WANT TO TO
HAVE A QUE PROPOSED OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT AND I'M FEELING THAT
WITH PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS BUT ON THE OTHER HAND --
NO ONE WANTS TO BE THERE WHEN
THEY RELIEF SOMEONE AND THAT
PERSON KIND OF BEEN CONSIDERED A
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEM AND THEN
THEY DO SOMETHING REALLY HEINOUS
OUT THERE.
AND THEN THE THIRD THING WHICH I
THINK IS THE ROOT OF WHERE WE
NEED TO GET TO WHICH IS BEEN
SOME IT JUST BOTHERS ME TO IT
DRIVES ME CRAZY TO KNOW WHEN --
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT COMES IN?
IT TRIES TO MAKE THEIR JOB
EASIER BY SHORTENING TO DUE
PROCESS.
LAWS SO THEY CAN GET.
THEY CAN GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET FASTER OR QUICKER OR GO
AROUND SOME THINGS AND SO IF YOU
COULD.
YOU KNOW.
I'M I'M DOING NANTES SO.
ONE BECAUSE FOR ME NOT MUSIC
KEEPS UP KEEP THE DISCUSSION
GOING.
BUT WE ALSO DO KIND OF DISMISS
THIS SO THAT WE CAN MOVE ON WITH
OUR OTHER BUSINESS BUT ALSO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
ON TAKING CARE OF THE ISSUE THAT
I BROUGHT UP MR QUIRK BROUGHT UP.
REBEKAH BAUER CAM BROUGHT UP
MISS COME LOADED UP BROUGHT UP
AND I KEPT SEEMS TO LACKEY SHAKE
HIS HEAD A LOT SO I'M NOT SURE
WHERE HE IS -- BUT AS MISTER
PURPOSE ST AT LEAST THE DOOR
OPEN -- BUT IT DIDN'T GET SUS
OFF OF OUR OUR OUR DOCKET SO WE
CAN GET TO OUR OTHER BUSINESS --
SO ODD TO CHAIRS RECOMMEND NON.
IN -- IN E..
WRECKED NONE.
SO CAPTION ONE IS OUR MOTION.
WILL MOVE THE BELL.
HELLO ON A. B. NINE NINE SEVEN
THE MOST XIN IS TO PASSAGE
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NOT VOTING LACKEY.
NO LACKEY NOPE BAUER-KAHAN HI
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT VOTING QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WICKS.
WICKS NOT VOTING.
I'M SORRY THAT MEASURE FAILS.
ARE YOU AN ASKED RECONSIDERATION
NO I'M NOT GO NOT OKAY
.
I DON'T SEEM MISTER GLORIA I'M
JUST MAKING SURE HE'S NOT IN A
ROW.
SO MISTER GRAYSON TIM GRAYSON
EUROPE AB -- NINE OH SEVEN I AM
.
TWENTY ONE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR TIME
AND ATTENTION ON THIS BILL AND
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
WITH A SCHOOL OR A PLACE OF
WORSHIP IS THREATENED IT CAN
DIRECTLY BECAUSE A REASONABLE
AND IMMEDIATE FEAR FOR ANYONE
WHO SPENDS THEIR TIME THERE.
AND FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND LOVED
ONES.
AB NINE ZERO SEVEN WILL MAKE IT
A CRIME TO THREATEN TO COMMIT AN
ACT THAT WILL KILL OR SERIOUSLY
HARM ANYONE ON THE GROUNDS OF A
SCHOOL OR RELIGIOUS INSTITUTION.
UNDER CURRENT LAW IN ORDER TO BE
PROSECUTED A THREAT MUST BE
SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED TOWARDS
ONE OR MANY INDIVIDUALS HOWEVER
IN OUR CURRENT CLIMATE THREATS
AREN'T JUST BEING MADE TOWARD.
INDIVIDUALS BUT INSTEAD AGAINST
ENTIRE SCHOOLS SYNAGOGUES
MOSQUES AND CHURCHES OUR
NEWSPAPERS AND NEWS FEEDS ARE
FILLED WITH TERRIBLE HEADLINES
OF CRIMES BEING COMMITTED
AGAINST TARGETED GROUPS OF
PEOPLE.
OVER FIFTY MUSLIMS MURDERED IN A
MOSQUE IN NEW ZEALAND ELEVEN
JEWISH WORSHIPPERS MURDERED IN A
SYNAGOGUE IN PITTSBURGH
PENNSYLVANIA.
A PREDOMINANTLY BLACK CHURCH IN
KENTUCKY TARGETED BY A GUNMAN
SCHOOL CHILDREN MURDERED AT
SANDY HOOK AND AT PARKLAND.
WHEN A STUDENT SEES A POST ON
SOCIAL MEDIA THAT ANOTHER
STUDENT WANTS TO KILL AT LEAST
THIRTY STUDENTS ON THE LAST DAY
OF SCHOOL?
THE FEAR THEY FEEL IS REAL.
THAT EXAMPLE IS A REAL ONE THAT
HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT IN
PLEASANT HILL.
DESPITE THAT COMMUNICATED
THREATS INTERVENTION BY THE FBI
AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
MULTIPLE GUNS BEING SEIZED FROM
THE STUDENTS HOME AND MULTIPLE
INDIVIDUALS AFRAID FOR THEIR
SAFETY.
PROSECUTORS WERE UNABLE TO
PURSUE A CRIMINAL THREAT CHARGE
BECAUSE OF HOW THE LAW IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN AB NINE ZERO
SEVEN WILL UPDATE OUR PENAL CODE
TO REFLECT THE INTENT OF THE LAW.
AND TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
THEY ARE TREATING THREATS
AGAINST OUR SCHOOLS AND PLACES
OF WORSHIP WITH GRAVITY THAT
THEY DEMAND.
MY WITNESS TIFFANY MATTHEWS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT OF THESE
ASSOCIATION IS WHAT THIS TODAY.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE THE SPONSOR OF AB NINE OH
SEVEN AND AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON POINTS OUT.
THERE HAS BEEN AN ALARMING
INCREASE IN GUN VIOLENCE
INCIDENT THAT SCHOOLS.
THESE INCIDENCES BECAUSE FEAR.
IN ARE DETRIMENTAL TO PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION THAT SCHOOLS PROVIDE.
WE'D LIKE TO STOP THESE
INCIDENTS BEFORE THEY HAPPEN BUT
IT IS DIFFICULT TO PROSECUTE
THESE CRIMINAL THREATS BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT DIRECTED AGAINST A
SPECIFIED INDIVIDUAL.
AS IS REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW PROSECUTORS
TO HOLD THESE INDIVIDUALS
ACCOUNTABLE.
THEREBY PROVIDING A MECHANISM TO
ENSURE THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES
FOR MAKING THE SERIOUS THAT.
YOUR QUESTION I VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION
.
MARGOT GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ANDERS ASSOCIATION OF WE
RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR YOUR NO
VOTE.
ALL WE LIVE IN REALLY PAINFUL
TIMES ANA.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
SPOKEN.
ABOUT WITH WHITE SUPREMACIST
TACKING CHURCHES SYNAGOGUES AND
MOSQUES.
WE ALL WANT TO DO SOMETHING TO
STOP THE ATTACKS.
ON HIM AS A MEMBER OF A TARGETED
GROUP -- I CERTAINLY FEEL
VULNERABLE IS PROBABLY MOST OF
THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM.
TO BAD AB NINE OH SEVEN IS NOT
THE SOLUTION.
AB NINE OH SEVEN WOULD EXPAND
THE CURRENT DEFINITION OF
CRIMINAL THREATS AND CREATE A
NEW CRIME OF CRIMINAL THREATS IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE SCHOOL OR
PLACE OF RELIGIOUS WORSHIP.
UP THE CURRENT STATUTE PENAL
CODE FOR TWENTY TWO IS VERY
PROBLEMATIC. FOR PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND THEIR CLIENTS THIS --
EXPANSION WOULD NOT STOP -- WORE
A WHITE SUPREMACIST OR OTHER --
PEOPLE WHO ARE INTENT UPON.
CREATING FEAR AND MADE HIM.
THE PEOPLE THIS HONEST PROPOSED
STATUTE WOULD CAPTURE ARE MY
CLIENTS THE MENTALLY ILL -- AND
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES.
UNDER THE CURRENT STATUTE WITH
THIS WOULD BE A FURTHER
EXTENSION OF WE HAD A CLIENT ON
A ROGER WHO WAS A MARINE CORPS
OF FAT.
HE SUFFERED FROM PTSD.
HE CAME ON TO CALIFORNIA FROM
ANOTHER STATE.
ANA WITHOUT SUFFICIENT MEDS FOR
A CONVENTION HE WAS ATTENDING
FOR VETERANS.
HE DIDN'T BRING ENOUGH MEDS AND
AS A RESULT TO HAVE THE EPISODE
OF HEARING VOICES.
AND SMELLING DEAD BODIES WHICH
REQUIRED HIM TO ACTUALLY BE.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY THE DOCTOR AT
THE HOSPITAL SAID WELL YOUR
SYMPTOMS DON'T MEET THE CRITERIA
AND YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ADMITTED AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
EVEN GIVE YOU MESS -- THE VET
SAID WELL WHAT DO I HAVE TO DO.
TO GET SOME HELP.
AND THE DISCHARGE PLANNER JUST
TOLD THEM WHAT THE CRITERIA WAS
AGAIN SO.
HE SHE SAID DANGER TO HIMSELF OR
OTHERS.
SO THE ROGER SAID WELL I'LL GET
A GUN.
AND I'LL SHOOT MYSELF FOR THE
STAFF HOUSE THAT.
SO THEY CALLED THE POLICE AND
ARRESTED HIM FOR A FELONY.
FOR TWENTY TWO OF TERRORIST
THREATS FOR TWENTY TWO IS A
FELONY AND IT'S A STRIKE -- THIS
EXPERIENCE OF BEING OFF YOUR
MEDS AND THEN JUST SAYING THINGS.
ON FOR SOME PEOPLE IS NOT
UNCOMMON WE HAD ANOTHER CLIENT
WHO WAS IN HIS LATE FIFTIES.
AND HE'S TOLD HIS FRIEND HE WAS
GONNA BLOW THE BUILDING UP.
HIS FRIEND CALLD THE DEPARTMENT
OF MENTAL HELP ASKING FOR HELP.
ANY THEY WERE TOO HE WAS
TRANSFERRED TO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
THE POLICE PROMPTLY ARRIVED AND
ARRESTED HIM. FOR FOR FOR TWENTY
TWO THE PROBLEM IS FOR TWENTY
TWO DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY ACTION
IT JUST REQUIRES WORDS.
AND IT APPLIES EVEN IF THE
PERSON WHO WAS SAYING THE WORDS
HAS NO.
ACTUAL INTENT OF CARRYING OUT
THE THREAT.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT EXPANDING
THE SCHOOL IN SNEER MORE PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS.
INTO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND CERTAINLY A SYMPATHETIC TO
THE INTENT BEHIND THE BILL.
BUT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA --
AND I WANT TO JOIN IN THIS
GEORGE'S COMMENTS BUT I ALSO
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT -- FIRST
FIRST THAT THIS IS.
NOT A BILL ABOUT WHERE THERE IS
AN ACTUAL ACT TO CARRY OUT THE
THREAT.
ON THE IT IS ONLY ABOUT THREATS
AND NOT EVEN KNOW IT NECESSARILY
THREATS WHERE THERE IS ANY
INTENT TO CARRY OUT THE THREAT --
BUT ALSO THAT THIS BILL IS IT'S
NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING TO
LESSEN THE NUMBER OF THREATS TO
SCHOOLS AND PLACES OF WORSHIP --
AND PLACES OF WORSHIP SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE THREATS COVERED
UNDER THE BILL CAN ALREADY BE
PROSECUTED UNDER EXISTING LAW.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SO OVERCOME
BY ANGER NOW THAT THEY MAKE
THESE THREATS WITHOUT REGARD TO
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE NOT GOING
TO STOP BECAUSE THIS BILL HAS
BEEN PASSED.
IT'S NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING TO
CHANGE THOSE CON THOSE POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES. EIGHTY NINE OH
SEVEN IS SIMPLY UNNECESSARY AND
WE URGE AND HOPEFUL.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MR QUIRK.
SILVA ARM YOU PROBABLY GET HERE
WE HAVE WE'RE SIR TO DOUBLING
THE SIZE OF THE CRIMINAL CODE
EVERY FEW YEARS FOR THAT REASON
I HAVE CONCERNS BECAUSE AGAIN
IT'S ALREADY CRIME.
THE D. A.'S REPRESENTATIVE SAID
THAT THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO
PROSECUTE THE CASE GIVEN HOW
TOUGH THE CURRENT LAW IS THAT
WAS PROBABLY GOOD REASON FOR IT
IN PARTICULAR.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS IDENTIFIED
CASES WHERE FOR EXAMPLE OF A
TALK HERE IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT
SOMEONE POSTING ON FACEBOOK AND
THE SUPREME COURT DECIDED THAT
THAT WASN'T.
BOB.
A THREAT THAT IT WAS -- EXERCISE
OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT SO YOU
ALSOHAVE THE DIFFICULTY THIS
LAW MAY WERE INTO FIRST
AMENDMENT PROBLEMS.
SO I JUST DON'T THINK I CAN VOTE
FOR THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
SO I TO WANT TO ECHO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUE -- WE HAVE CLOSE TO
SIX THOUSAND LAWS IN THE PENAL
CODE -- AND SO I GET THAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS I DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW THAT ALL OF THE
SOLUTIONS ARE COMING FROM OR
THROUGH PUBLIC SAFETY SOME OF
THE SOLUTIONS ARE FAR MORE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
AND NEBULOUS AND NUANCED.
AROUND.
MAYBE THIS COUNTRY BEING.
IN THE MIDST OF A MENTAL HEALTH
EPIDEMIC AND NONE OF US REALLY
ADEQUATELY KNOWING HOW TO DEAL
WITH TRAUMA -- THERE IS A COLD
PENAL CODE FOR TWO TWO IS
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS THIS IS
REALLY DUPLICATIVE LANGUAGE.
THE LAW THAT'S CURRENTLY ON THE
BOOKS SAYS YOU CANNOT DO ANY OF
THESE AGAINST A PERSON.
THIS WOULD ACTUALLY SAY YOU
CAN'T DO THIS -- STATE A KIND OF
THREAT AGAINST A PLACE.
YOU KNOW WE ARE SORT OF MOVING
THE NEEDLE.
FARTHER AND FARTHER AWAY -- AND
REALLY.
THE BAR FOR PROSECUTION IS SO
LOW AND I JUST GET CONCERNED
THAT WE'RE FIGURING OUT WAYS TO
CHIP AWAY AT THAT ALREADY LOW
THRESHOLD -- AND AND WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO END UP I DON'T KNOW.
I I QUESTION KIND OF IF YOU HEAR
SOMETHING SOME KIND OF THREAT
BEING SAID.
YOU KNOW YOU ALSO HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT WHO WAS THE RECIPIENT WHO
WAS THE PERSON HEARING THAT AND
HOW ARE THEY HEARING IT AND HOW
ARE THE INTERPRETING IT.
SO NOW ARE WE BASING LAWS BASED
ON HOW SOMEONE INTERPRETS WHAT
THEY HEAR.
WE'RE ALSO NOT TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION -- WHAT HAPPENS
[inaudible]
SO.
EIGHTY YOU CAN I BRING FIREARMS
TO A SCHOOL YOU CANNOT BRING
DRUGS YOU CAN I BRING MAYES YOU
CANNOT BRING KNIVES WE MAY GET
TO A POINT WHERE PEOPLE AREN'T
EVEN BRINGING BOOKS -- BUT THOSE
THINGS ARE ALREADY ILLEGAL.
AND THEN WE HAVE TO HAVE REAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW STUDENTS
ARE ACTUALLY BEING TREATED.
AT SCHOOLS IF BULLYING IS
HAPPENING IF THEY'RE BEING
HARASSED BY MAYBE EVEN PEOPLE
WHO WORK AT THE SCHOOLS.
AND IF THEY'RE SAYING THESE
KINDS OF THINGS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANOTHER WAY TO
COMMUNICATE AND THEY'RE ANGRY
AND THEY'RE SCARED AND WE'RE NOT
REALLY TALKING ABOUT BULLYING.
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT WAYS TO
ONCE AGAIN A RACE THE LIGHT THAT
IS DUE PROCESS.
AND FIGURING OUT WAYS TO
INCARCERATE SO MANY PEOPLE AND
WE HAVE BEEN PUTTING PEOPLE IN
BOXES FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS AND
IT'S NOT WORKING THIS IS NOT
ANSWERING THE QUESTION.
ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE.
WE CAN USE.
FOR TWO TO PEOPLE GET LOCKED UP
MANY A TIME MANY A DAY BECAUSE
OF THAT CODE.
I THINK WE HAVE THE TOOLS ON THE
BOOKS ALREADY.
AND I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE JUST
TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO USE THE
TOOLS THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN
THE CODE RATHER THAN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO PUT EVERY
PERSON IN JAIL THAT WERE AFRAID
UP.
AND WE'RE TOO UNCOMFORTABLE TO
HELP.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS WOULD LOOK LIKE BUT
I'M ACTUALLY INTERESTED IN BILLS
THAT TALK ABOUT THOSE ISSUES.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT I AM NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SORT PART
THIS BILL [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
BUT NO [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I THINK YOU KNOW YOU REYES
SORT OF A MUCH LARGER POINT THAN
JUST THIS BILL ABOUT PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS BEING TAKEN IN
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
INSTEAD OF INTO THE CARE THAT
THEY DESERVE AND NEED AND SHOULD
BE TREATED.
TO AND I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING IS
THAT.
THERE SHOULD BE A SEPARATE
AVENUE FOR THOSE THAT ARE
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL ILLNESS
RATHER THAN WE LACK THAT
TREATMENT RIGHT NOW AND SO.
THEY ARE BEING.
PICKED UP BY THE POLICE THEIR
BEEN PUT INTO JAILS AND SEVEN TO
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITIES AND I
THINK THAT IS A LARGER QUESTION.
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS THROUGH
HEALTHCARE AND THROUGH MENTAL
HEALTH CARE IN MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO BE TREATED AND NOT.
CRIMINALIZED FOR MENTAL ILLNESS
THAT BEING SAID YOU KNOW I SEE
EVERY DAY THE RISE IN THESE KIND
OF THREATS.
TO YOU KNOW MY OWN SYNAGOGUE AND
WE HEAR THAT OUR LOCAL SCHOOLS
AND YOU KNOW WE DO.
I AM OF THE OPINION THAT WE NEED
TO BE GIVING LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
TOOLS TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE SAFE
AND OUR PLACES OF WORSHIP.
IN OUR SCHOOLS BECAUSE WHEN I
DROP MY KIDS OFF TO SUNDAY
SCHOOL.
OR TO SCHOOL IN THE MORNING.
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
SAFEST PLACE FOR ME TO TAKE THEM.
AND CURRENTLY IT ISN'T.
THANK YOU.
AND YOU MAKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I DO
WANT TO REITERATE THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THAT YOU HAVE GIVEN TO THIS AND
THE HARD WORK THAT YOU OF PUT IN
TO WITH MY STAFF AND I DO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS HAS PROPOSED AS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE -- IT
IS UNFORTUNATE OF THE GROSS
GENERALIZATION OF THIS SUBJECT
BY A COLLEAGUE ON THE COMMITTEE --
BECAUSE IT'S NOT -- THE SAME AS
THE LAW THAT EXIST IT DOES
EXPAND IT TO SCHOOLS AND TO
PLACES OF WORSHIP.
THE DIFFERENCE IS IS THAT IF I
MAKE A THREAT TO JOHNNY.
THAT IS PROSECUTABLE BUT IF I
MAKE A THREAT. TO TO A JEWISH
SYNAGOGUE.
THEN I AM NOT PROSECUTED NIGHT
DO HAVE A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE OF
HOW THAT TOOK PLACE AND MY
DISTRICT.
AND IS FAR AS MENTAL HEALTH IS
CONCERNED -- AND THE ARGUMENT --
BY THE OPPOSITION AND I
APPRECIATE AND RESPECTFULLY --
WANT TO ADDRESS THAT AS FAR AS
IF THE ARGUMENT IS THIS BILL
DOESN'T STOP THREATS. TO SCHOOLS
INTO PLACES OF WORSHIP WELL THE
BILL ALREADY EXIST IN THE FORM
OF LAW IN THIS SENSE OF
INDIVIDUALS.
THEN I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THE
SAME ARGUE WOULD BE WITH THE
OPPOSITION THAT THE CURRENT BILL
DOESN'T STOP THREATS AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR APPS TO
WRITE IT DOESN'T STOP IT.
BUT IT DOES ALLOW US TO TAKE
ACTION AGAINST IT AND MAKE IT --
CONSEQUENTIAL AND WHAT THIS BILL
WILL DO THOUGH IT MAY NOT STOP A
THREAT WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO IS
MAKE A CONSEQUENTIAL.
AND YOU CAN'T JUST STAND UP IN
AN AIRPORT AND OUT OF ANGER SAY
ON A BLOW THIS PLACE UP.
AND EXPECT TO WALK OUT FREE AND
THE SAME THING I BELIEVE IS THAT
EVEN IN YOUR MIDST OF ANGER.
AND AND FOR SOMEONE AS A
CHAPLAIN OF THE CONCORD POLICE
DEPARTMENT SITTING IN THE FRONT
SEAT OF THAT CAR LISTENING THE
FIRST RESPONDERS.
ACTUALLY GOING AND AND HOPING
AND WORKING WITH VICTIMS OF
SCHOOLS THAT HAD TO GO TO SCHOOL
UNDER A THREAT.
THAT -- I SEE THE CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT THREAT AND SO ALL I'M
ASKING FOR IS THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT IF SOMEONE DOES NEED THE
HELP THAT WE HAVE THIS TOOL IF
IT'S A MENTAL ISSUE -- AND
MENTAL HEALTH -- PRESCRIPTIONS
REQUIRED THEN THIS PROCESS COULD
VERY WELL HOPE SOME FOLKS THAT
WOULD HAVE NEVER RECEIVED HELP.
FIND THEMSELVES IN A PLACE THAT
ELENA RHETORIC HOPE IS BEING
RECEIVED.
SO ALL I ASK FOR IS THAT WE LOOK
AT WHAT CURRENTLY EXIST.
AND EXPAND THAT TO BE ABLE TO
SAY THAT IF YOU DON'T NAME THE
PERSON BUT YOU ACTUALLY NAME THE
PLACE.
THEN THAT COUNTS AS WELL.
WAS BY WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND THANK YOU AND I THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE AT THE AMENDMENTS --
I WAS TO COMMITTEE.
ON CHAIRS ARE WORKING REAL HARD
WITH YOU SO WE COULD.
WORK OUT A LOT OF THE ISSUES OF
I JUST.
WOULD LIKE TO JUST MAKE ONE
RECOMMENDATION THERE'S THERE'S A
TERM OF ART OR IS A TERM THAT'S
USED.
AMONG PEOPLE HERE -- WHICH IS --
THROUGH THE CHAIR AND THE REASON
FOR THAT IS NONE OF THESE
COMMENTS ARE PERSONALLY TOWARD
YOU EARN.
FOR ANOTHER COMMITTEE IS NOT
TOWARD ANOTHER WITNESS -- AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAY TO THE CHAIR
SO HOPEFULLY -- AT WHICH I
PROBABLY SHOULD SOME OTHER
WITNESSES WHO REALLY GET.
I UNDERSTAND GETTING PASSIONATE
WELL TO IT.
MAKE SURE IT'S MISTER CHAIR WHAT
ARE THE AMENDMENTS IT'S NOT
CLEAR FROM THE ANALYSIS.
WHAT ARE THE AMENDMENTS AND
BECAUSE?
ARE ARE THEY ALREADY IN THE BILL.
DURING THE ANALYSIS.
THE HARD COPIES.
IN HARD COPY
ALL RIGHT MAYBE I DON'T HAVE THE
MOST RECENT COPY.
THE ONLY THING THAT PUTS TO THE
SYSTEM ARE THE ACTUAL AMOUNT YOU
CAN MEMBERS ARE AN ATTACHMENT
THAT DON'T COME WITH.
THE IN JUNE.
THEY'RE ALL IN THE RIGHT I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO READ THIS
BEFORE WE'VE HAD.
COULD YOU JUST STATE WHAT THEY
ARE.
GO AHEAD SANTA.
THROUGH THE CHAIR -- THE
AMENDMENTS DEAL -- ESSENTIALLY --
DELETE THAT -- THERE HAS TO BE A
DISRUPTION AT THE SCHOOL -- THE
AMEND TO BE WHAT THEIR HAT THE
THE BILL AS AS ORIGINALLY
DRAFTED REQUIRED THAT THERE BE A
JUST AN ACTUAL DESTRUCTION AT
THE SCHOOL OR PLACE OF WORSHIP
THAT WAS DELETED BECAUSE THE THE
THREAT IS WHAT HAPPENS -- THE
AMENDMENTS -- CLARIFY THAT IT'S
ESSENTIALLY THE THEY NOW MAY
MAKE THE CURRENT STATUTE BUT
CLARIFY THAT -- A PERSON CAN BE
AND REASONABLY SUSTAINED FEAR
FOR THEMSELVES OR ANY OTHER
MEMBER OF THE CONGREGATION OR
THE SCHOOL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR.
MOST OF A SHARED NOW DEPENDED
UPON THESE AND USUALLY.
THE AMENDED BILL FOLLOWS THE
ANALYSIS IN THIS CASE DIDN'T.
MEDICAID IS FOR THE YOUR NOT
GONNA MANAGES YET.
OKAY HE ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS
NOW OKAY THAT ONE PART OF THE
WHOLE PACKAGE.
ALL RIGHT MY MISTAKE.
THANK YOU.
SO CHURCH RECKON ODD WITH THE
AMENDMENTS.
IS THERE A MOTION.
I GUESS WE'LL START WITH THAT.
ALL MOVE THE BILL [inaudible]
CALDERON.
ON A. B. NINE OH SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
BARRICADE HAND BAUER-KAHAN I
DEEP.
I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT VOTING QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I LET MEASURES ON
CALL NEED ONE MORE.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
MEDICAL.
OKAY NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER NINE
MISTER FRAZIER.
A. B.
.
SIX FORTY ME MAYBE SHE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB SIX FORTY EXPANDS EXISTING
TRAINING COURSES FOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S.
THROUGH GRANTS OFFERED BY THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES BY
REQUIRING.
TRAINING OF INVEST OF
INVESTIGATION PROSECUTION OF
SEXUAL ABUSES CASE HE'S IN CASES.
INVOLVING VICTIMS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
ACCORDING TO DATA FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
NATIONAL STATISTICS SHOW THAT
ONE OUT OF FIVE NON DISABLED
WOMEN WILL BE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES ARE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AT A RATE SEVEN TIMES
HIGHER.
THEN THOSE WITHOUT DISABILITIES.
DATA FURTHER SHOWS THAT THE
CRIMES AGAINST INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES GO
MOSTLY I'M PROSECUTED AND ON
PUNISHED.
BECAUSE THESE CASES ARE
DIFFICULT TO WIN IN COURT.
THE RATE OF SEXUAL ABUSE AMONG A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS DIFFICULTIES
CONVEYING THEIR PAIN AND
SUFFERING.
AND ARE SPECIFICALLY TARGETING
OR TERRIFYINGLY HIGH.
AB SIX FORTY INSURERS DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ARE ADEQUATELY TRAINED
TO INVESTIGATE.
AND PROSECUTE CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
TODAY I HAVE DEBBIE MARINO.
HERE WAS STRICT WITH STRATEGIES
TO THE STATE'S USING STRATEGIES
TO EMPOWER PEOPLE.
AND THE ARK TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
NOT
.
I WILL START THE YEAH.
WE'LL WAIT. SIX AMERICANS
THROUGH THE LASER EYE
TECHNOLOGIES -- TAKES HER -- TO
TO LOOK AT IT FOR IT TO BE AND
PROGRAMS TAKE THEIR TIME -- NOT
TO HURRY
.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS DEBBIE
AND I WANT TO TELL YOU GUYS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY SEXUAL
HARASSMENT STORY.
BEGIN MY STORE SOME OF YOU MIGHT
WANT A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT INCLUDES AND
WELCOME SEXUAL ADVANCES REQUESTS
FOR SEXUAL FAVORS AND OTHER
VERBAL OR PHYSICAL HARASSMENT OF
A SEXUAL NATURE IN THE WORKPLACE
OR LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT DOES NOT
ALWAYS HAVE TO BE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT SEXUAL BEHAVIOR OR
DIRECTED AT A SPECIFIC PERSON
FOR EXAMPLE NEGATIVE COMMENTS
ABOUT WOMEN OR MEN AS A GROUP.
IS A FORM OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
WHAT DOES SEXUAL HARASSMENT LOOK
LIKE?
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CAN OCCUR IN A
VARIETY OF CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE HARASSER CAN IDENTIFY AS ANY
GENDER AND HAVE ANY RELATIONSHIP
TO THE VICTIM SOME EXAMPLES
BEING A DIRECT MANAGER INTERNET.
PROVIDER CO WORKER TEACHER HERE
OR COLLEAGUE.
SOME FORM OF HARASSMENT INCLUDE
MAKING CONDITIONS OF EMPLOYMENT
FOR ADVANCEMENT DEPENDENT ON
SEXUAL FAVORS EITHER EXPLICITLY.
OR IMPLICITLY.
PHYSICAL ACTS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
REQUESTS FOR SEXUAL FACTORS.
VERBAL HARASSMENT OF A SEXUAL
NATURE INCLUDING JOKES REFERRING
TO SEXUAL ACTS OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
UNLIMITED TOUCHING OF PHYSICAL
CONTACT.
AND WELCOME SEXUAL ADVANCES.
DISCUSSING SEXUAL RELATIONS%
STORIES FANTASIES AT WORK SCHOOL
OR ANOTHER INAPPROPRIATE PLACES.
FEELING THE PRESSURE TO ENGAGE
WITH SOMEONE SEXUALLY.
EXPOSING ONESELF OR PERFORMING
SEXUAL ACTS ON ONE'S SELF.
ALSO UNWANTED SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
PHOTOS EMAILS OR TEXT MESSAGES.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS A BROAD
TERM INCLUDING MANY TYPES OF
UNWELCOME VERBAL AND PHYSICAL
SEXUAL ATTENTION.
SEXUAL ASSAULT REFERS TO SEXUAL
CONTACT OR BEHAVIOR OFTEN
PHYSICAL THAT OCCURS WITHOUT THE
CONSENT OF THE VICTIM.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT GENERALLY
VIOLATE CIVIL LAWS.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO WORK ON A
LEARN WITHOUT BEING HER ****.
IN MANY CASES IS NOT A CRIMINAL
ACT.
ALL SEXUAL ASSAULT USUALLY
REFERS TO ACT THAT OUR CRIMINAL.
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT IS A NON LEGAL
TERM USED INFORMALLY TO DESCRIBE
A BROAD RANGE OF SEXUAL
BEHAVIORS I THINK THIS IS ONE OF
THEM TRAININGS THAT SHE'S DONE
SO I THINK WE HAVE.
OTHER SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY A
MAN HE CAME INTO MY ROOM TO GIVE
ME A SHOWER HE TOOK OFF MY
CLOTHES AND THEN HE TOOK ME TO
THE SHOWER ROOM AND TOOK OFF MY
TOWEL.
I WAS WATCHING HIM AS HE
SHOWERED ME AND SOMETHING SEEMED
A LITTLE OFF.
HE STARTED WATCHING ME AND THEN
HE STARTED TOUCHING MY **** AND
HE ASKED WHAT ARE YOU DOING.
HE SAID WASHINGTON HE PUT HIS
FINGER OF MY BOAT.
I SCREAMED AND SOMEONE CAME TO
SEE WHAT WAS GOING ON I WAS
REALLY SHAKEN UP ABOUT THE WHOLE
THING.
WAS REALLY HARD FOR ME TO TRUST
ANYONE AFTER THAT.
I PRESSED CHARGES AGAINST HIM.
WHAT HAPPENED TO ME COULD HAPPEN
TO ANYONE DON'T BE AFRAID TO
SPEAK OUT AND STAND UP FOR
YOURSELF THANK YOU EVERYONE?
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS DEBBIE
AND I WANT TO TELL YOU GUYS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY SEXUAL
HARASSMENT STORY.
BEFORE I BEGIN MY STORY SOME OF
YOU MIGHT WANT A CLEARER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT INCLUDES AND
WELCOME SEXUAL ADVANCES REQUESTS
FOR SEXUAL FAVORS AND OTHER
VERBAL OR PHYSICAL HARASSMENT OF
A SEXUAL NATURE IN THE WORKPLACE
OR LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THE YEAH SO
WE'RE WE'RE FINE WITH GIVING THE
WITNESS A MIXTURE TIME.
EXPERT WITNESS YOU WANNA TAKE A
TWO MINUTE SPAN.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
GIVING THEM EXTRA TIME I AM.
I DO WANT TO SAY DEBBIE AND I
PARTICIPATED IN THE TRAINING --
AND SHE WAS REALLY INSTRUMENTAL
IN CREATING A VIDEO TRAINING
VIDEO FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
INVESTIGATORS.
WE ALSO HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS
THAT WAS GOING TO BE HERE TODAY
AND TALK ABOUT HIS STORY BUT
THINGS GOT A LITTLE TURNED
AROUND FOR YOU HE DIDN'T MAKE IT.
THIS BILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE YOU COULD SEE -- TO BE
ABLE TO REALLY INVESTIGATE.
N. IN HERE WHAT DEBBIE WENT
THROUGH YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO COMMUNICATE SO
BIG PIECE OF THE TRAINING.
REVOLVES AROUND COMMUNICATING
WITH PEOPLE THAT HAVE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF COMMUNICATION STYLES SO --
WE WE APPRECIATE THE TIME TODAY
AND REALLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON
THE BILL TRAINING -- FOR SEXUAL
SO INVESTIGATORS PROSECUTORS
DA'S ANYONE INVOLVED IN THE
SYSTEM -- TO TO INCREASE
KNOWLEDGE AND ABILITY TO
SEXUAL PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED THAT HAVE INTELLECTUAL
OR DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WHEN MISTER RYAN CHIN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
MORNING MR MEMBERS ACROSS YOUR
HERNANDEZ A BE HAVE THE COVER
TURN CALIFORNIA TURNS REMOTE
JUSTICE WE HAVE AN OPPOSE LESS
AMENDED.
OPPOSITION I'VE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION THE OTHER STAFF WE
JUST HAVE A SMALL AMENDMENT TO
THE BILL I WANT TO THANK ON THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING ON THIS ISSUE.
I WAS WANT SOME CLARIFICATION
THAT BOTH THE VISOR E. OF
COMMITTING TRAIN -- ALL IS ALSO
INCLUSIVE OF THE CANNELLA FENCE
ATTORNEY SAYS WE HAVE
PROSECUTORS INVOLVED WITH
EVERYTHING AND BE BACK GOOD
BALANCED APPROACH AND CAN BE
HELPFUL HAVE ALL SIDES THERE. TO
MAKE SURE WE GET IT RIGHT TO THE
SMALL ISSUE WE'RE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE -- LOOK FORWARD TO
RESOLVING THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ARE IN OUT.
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SCENE NO ONE OUR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAN LUMBER DOVE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD -- YOU KNOW THIS
ISSUE IS IMPORTANT TO ME -- I
ACTUALLY -- KNOW OF AN INSTANCE
WHERE A YOUNG MAN WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES --
WAS SEXUALLY ABUSED.
AND ASSAULTED -- AND AS A RESULT
HER IN SPITE OR BECAUSE OF THOSE
THINGS WAS ALSO ACTING OUT.
BUT BECAUSE THERE'S A LACK OF
AWARENESS ABOUT THIS COMMUNITY
AND THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
WAS PROSECUTED.
AND IN FACT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE SAID.
WE KNOW HE HAS DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
ANDWE KNOW HE NEEDS MENTAL HELP
SUPPORT.
BUT THAT'S PROSECUTOR. FOR THE
WIN.
AND GET JAIL TIME.
AND THEN ASKED THE JUDGE TO GET
HIM HELP.
AND THAT'S REALLY NOT HOW WE
SHOULD BE TREATING INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND THAT'S NOT HOW WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT THEM.
SO I APPLAUD THIS BILL.
I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS.
AND WITH DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
OFFICES BECAUSE IN FACT ALSO IN
THIS CASE THE REGIONAL CENTER
VIOLATED THIS YOUNG MAN'S HIPPA.
RIGHT. TO HELP GET HIM PUT AWAY.
I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE THAT YOU
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS BECAUSE I
THINK THAT -- ANYONE WHO PLAYS A
ROLE IN -- THE PROTECTION OF
RIGHTS AND DUE PROCESS.
AND IS A PART OF THIS
ENVIRONMENT SHOULD ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN GETTING THESE
TRAININGS AND THAT INCLUDES
PUBLIC DEFENDERS -- AS WELL SO I
HOPE YOU LOOK INTO THOSE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MR FRAZIER YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS OF AND I I
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFULNESS OF
THE THE POSCO THE COKE CRIMINAL --
DEFENDING ATTORNEYS -- THIS IS
ALREADY AN EXISTING PROGRAM IN
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
THE DA'S PARTICIPATING.
THIS JUST ADDS ADDITIONAL
CURRICULUM IF WE WERE TO ADD ALL
OF THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND
CRIMINAL.
JUSTICE ATTORNEYS IN CALIFORNIA
THIS WOULD NEVER GET OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS -- SO ONE OF THE
THINGS A GOOD REASON AND SO THIS
IS A STEP.
THAT'S ALREADY AN EXISTING
PROGRAM THAT WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO AUGMENT.
AND THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
SO AND I THINK THAT ANY
INTERESTED PARTY AT IN THE NEXT
COMING SESSION WHO'D LIKE TO
TEAM WITH ME.
I THINK THAT IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
METHOD IF WE CAN FIND THE
REVENUE SOURCE TO MOVE FORWARD
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE THE IN
OTHER INDIVIDUALS HAS EVERY
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE THE THE THE
TRAINING ALSO.
YEAH WELL WE ALL KNOW THE TRAP.
IT'S CALLED APPROPRIATIONS AND
GIVEN THAT I'M I'M GOING TO VOTE
YES AS WELL -- I DO HOPE THAT WE
CAN DO SOMETHING FURTHER DOWN
THE LINE.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR EVERYONE TO BE TRAINED IN
THE SENSITIVITY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS -- WE DO HAVE THE
CASE OF SOMEONE WHO WAS ACTUALLY
PROSECUTED AND THAT.
CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE BEEN
HELPFUL IF THAT TED DEFENDING
ATTORNEY HAD HAD SOME TRAINING --
SO.
I'M HI THE CHAIR IS URGING AN
AYE VOTE -- MADAM SECRETARY --
WE HAVE TOGETHER MOTION A MOVE
THE BILL MASTERMAN.
SECOND THANK YOU.
SO MOTION BY MISTER DO YEP --
AND THE SECOND BY POWER CON.
ON A BASIC.
GIVE ME ON EIGHTY SIX FORTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY BARRICADE HANAE BARRICADE
HAND I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I JACKIE
WAS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LACKEY I BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION WAS CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
OKAY -- TO THE NEXT PERSON IS
MISTER GLORIA A. B. -- THREE
NINETY THREE ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN OR IS IT I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
EIGHT NINETY THREE YEAH
.
WELCOME ONE IS TO QUIRK IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB --
EIGHT NINETY THREE THIS MORNING
THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL A BILL
THAT IS IN RESPONSE TO THE
OVERWHELMING CALL FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS.
A BIT FOR OUR DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION THE
TWENTY SECOND AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICT TO STOP SELLING GUNS
AND AMMUNITION ON STATE PROPERTY.
AS MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE
NO DOUBT AWARE THE PLAGUE OF GUN
VIOLENCE IS PRESENT IN NEARLY
EVERY CORNER OF OUR STATE.
JUST LAST YEAR NEARLY FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE DIE FROM GUNS IN
UNITED STATES THE HIGHEST IN THE
LAST IN FIFTY YEARS.
REGRETTABLY RARELY A WEEK GOES
BY WE'RE NOT ANOTHER SENSELESS
TRAGEDY OCCURS INVOLVING GUNS.
TO OBVIOUSLY.
ALL OF US ARE THINKING ABOUT
THOSE AFFECTED BY THE TRAGEDY
NEW ZEALAND.
WE SEEN TOO MANY OF THESE TERROR
OF ANTS HAPPEN IN OUR SCHOOLS
ARE PLACES OF WORSHIP.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. FORTY FOR
THOSE OF US WHO BELIEVE WE WERE
SENT HERE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS PROBLEM WE NOW HAVE ENGAGED
IN ACTIVE CITIZENRY.
AS THE WIND ON OUR BACKS I HAVE
OVER A DOZEN OF MY CONSTITUENTS
HERE TODAY TO OFFER MORE THAN
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS.
MEMBERS WE ARE HERE FOR ACTION.
ACCORDING TO A STUDY OF THE SAN
DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS
JUST CRIMINAL JUSTICE CLEARING
HOUSE NEARLY THREE QUARTERS 73%
OF ALL HOMICIDES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN INVOLVED A FIREARM.
IN THE SANDY REGION JUST OVER
HALF 53% OF ALL HOMICIDES
INVOLVED A GUN.
AS WITH ALL OF MOVE MANY OF YOUR
DISTRICTS MY CONSTITUENTS DIDN'T
WAIT FOR STATE OR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO RESPOND.
LAST YEAR CITIZENS FROM THE FROM
DELMAR ENCINITAS SOLANA BEACH
AND ALL ACROSS THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO PETITION THE DEL MAR FAIR
BOARD THE STATE ENTITY THAT
GOVERNS THE ACTIVITIES AT THE
DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS. TO STOP ITS
COMPLICITY AND PROFITING OFF OF
GUN SALES THAT END UP IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND THEY HEARD US LOUD AND CLEAR
IN RESPONSE THE FAIR BOARD
AGREED WITH THE COMMUNITY AND
VOTED TO INSTRUCT STAFF TO
EXPLORE POLICIES TO PHASE OUT
STATE SANCTIONED GUN SHOWS.
THE BOARD INSTRUCTED THE STAFF
TO EXPLORE GUN SAFETY -- AND
EDUCATIONAL EVENTS FOR GUNS AND
AMMUNITION WERE NOT SOLD BUT
UNLIKE OTHER AGRICULTURE
DISTRICT BOARDS ARE BORED
LISTENED AND HEEDED THE CALL TO
EXPLORE THE PROHIBITION OF GUNS
AND AMMO FOR SALE.
AS YOUR ANALYSIS NOTES -- THE
GUN THE WORK TO BAN GUN SHOWS IS
CURRENTLY ON HOLD AS THE BOARD
AWAITS THE DISPOSITION OF A
LEGAL CHALLENGE BY THE GUN SHOW
VENDOR.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THAT GUN SHOW
VENDOR CROSSROADS OF THE WEST
HAS FILED SUIT AGAINST THE BOARD
ACTION DESPITE BEING UNDER
INVESTIGATION BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THE DOJ IS CURRENTLY REVIEWING
THE CERTIFICATE OF ELIGIBILITY
OF ONE OF THE PROMOTERS OF THE
SHOW GIVEN AN APPARENT FELONY
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND.
MEMBERS AB EIGHT NINETY THREE IS
A DISTRICT BILL THIS LEGISLATION
ONLY IMPACTS OUR ARMS THAT ARE
SOLD AT THE SEVEN EIGHT IN THE
SEVENTY TO ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND
DOES NOT THE IMPACT THE ABILITY
FOR OTHER AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS TO SELL WEAPONS ON
THEIR PROPERTY.
I HAVE A DOZENS OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE FLOWN UP
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF OUR SHARED COMMUNITY.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU'LL HEAT OUR
CALL TO IN THE SHOW'S ONCE AND
FOR ALL.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN WITH
ME THIS MORNING YEAH I HAVE ROSE
AND SHARP CO FOUNDER OF NEVER
AGAIN CALIFORNIA AND NOW IN HARD
AND HARDENS.
POSITION FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO.
WAS IN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS ROSEANNE SHARP AND I
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT NINETY THREE AUTHORED BY
TODD GLORIA.
AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE I RESIDE
IN THE SEVENTY EIGHTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT I AM THE FOUNDER OF
NEVER AGAIN CA OUR NAME AND OUR
MISSION.
COME FROM THE STUDENTS AT
PARKLAND WE BELIEVE THIS
LEGISLATION RESPECTS AND
PROTECTS THE LIVES AND RIGHTS OF
ALL THE CITIZENS WITH SEVENTY
THREE GUNS STORES IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
A GUN SHOW ON A STATE OWNED
PROPERTY IS OVERKILL LITERALLY.
THE PRESENCE OF GUN SHOWS AT THE
FAIRGROUNDS NORMALIZES THEIR USE
IT SAYS GUNS ARE OKAY HERE.
LAST SUMMER A TWENTY TWO YEAR
OLD MAN FIRED HIS GUN INTO A
CROWD WHEN HE COULD NOT BUY A
TICKET FOR SOLD OUT DEL MAR
CONCERT.
GUNS DO NOT JUST KILL IN MAINE
GUNS DO GREAT PSYCHOLOGICAL
DAMAGE THIS WEEKEND WE LEARNED
THAT A SECOND STUDENTS SURVIVOR
OF THE PARKLAND SHOOTING.
SURVIVED PHYS PHYSICALLY BUT NOT
PSYCHOLOGICALLY.
BECOMING THE SECOND TO PARKLAND
STUDENT AND A SINGLE WEEK TO
COMMIT SUICIDE.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
WROTE TO THE DEL MAR FAIRPORT.
QUOTE IF CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
PERMIT THE SALE OF FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION ON STATE OWNED
PROPERTY WE ARE SENDING A SIGNAL
THAT WE VALUE THE SALE OF
FIREARMS ABOVE THE LIVES OF
AMERICANS.
WE HAVE LETTERS OF SUPPORT FOR
THIS LEGISLATION FROM THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS OF THE
NEIGHBORING CITIES DEL MAR
SELANNE BEACH IN ENCINITAS.
WHO REPRESENT OVER SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND VOTERS?
THE NRA AFFILIATED PROMOTERS OF
THE DEL MAR GUN SHOWS SAID THE
GUN SHOWS ARE SAFE.
NEVER AGAIN PROVED OTHERWISE WE
UNCOVERED CRIMES FROM THE POLICE
REPORTS WE UNCOVERED THAT TO
FELON CONVICTED.
FROM FEDERAL FIREARMS VIOLATIONS
HAD BEEN THE PROMOTER OF THE GUN
SHOW.
MEMBERS OF THE DEL MAR VERY
BORED AND COVERED MORE IN THEIR
OWN INSPECTION OF THE GUN SHOWS
THEY VOTED TO SUSPEND THESE GUN
SHOWS.
THE STATE DOES NOT BELONG IN THE
BUSINESS OF PROMOTING.
AMPLE IF THE PROLIFERATION OF
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION AND
PROFITING FROM THE SALES ON
STATE OWNED PROPERTY.
THE STATE DOES BELONG IN THE
BUSINESS OF INSURING PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THAT IS WHY WE APPEAR
AN APPEAL TODAY TO YOU FOR YOUR
VOTE I URGE A YES VOTE THANK YOU --
THE VICE CHAIR IS NOW HERE SO
I'M GOING TO HAND THE GAVEL OVER
TO THE VICE CHAIR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
I AM HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB BILL. EIGHT NINETY THREE
TO HELP REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
GUNS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AS A RESIDENT OF THE SEVENTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND DEL
MAR FAIR ATTENDEE OVER SEVERAL
DECADES AS WELL AS A PROFESSOR
OF ORTHOPEDIC SURGERY.
AT UC SAN DIEGO.
I STRONGLY RECOMMEND.
THE TO STOP RENTING.
THIS STATE OWNED PROPERTY
FORGOTTEN SHOWS.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS I
HAVE BECOME VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
STATE OWNED PROPERTY IS.
TAKING MONEY FROM GUN SHOWS.
AND THE ADVERSE AFFECTS.
OF GUN SHOWS HAN OUR COMMUNITY.
GUN SHOWS ARE NOT SAFE.
FAMILY ENTERTAINMENT GUN SHOWS
LEAD TO THE PROLIFERATION OF
GUNS AND GUN VIOLENCE.
I JOINED THE FACULTY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF ORTHOPAEDIC
SURGERY IN. NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
TO HELP DIAGNOSE AND TREAT
COMPARTMENT SYNDROMES IN TRAUMA
PATIENTS. ONE BECAUSE OF
COMPARTMENT SYNDROME.
IS A GUNSHOT WOUND.
AND THESE ARE VERY DAMAGING. TO
MUSCLES AND BONES.
AND WITH DEVASTATING AND DEADLY
COMPLICATIONS [inaudible]
THIS CONDITION.
HAS VERY SERIOUS EFFECTS ON
VICTIMS AS WELL AS THEIR
FAMILIES.
MORE OVER.
LEGAL GUNS WHICH ARE ILLEGALLY
MODIFIED WITH KITS SOLD AT GUN
SHOWS.
ARE EVEN MORE DAMAGING.
WE ARE PROUD THAT OUR RESEARCH
AT UC SAN DIEGO.
HAS HELPED DECREASE THE
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY.
CAUSED BY GUNSHOT WOUNDS.
HOWEVER.
IN THE SAME WAY AS OUR
COMPARTMENT SYNDROME RESEARCH.
HAS HELPED.
SURGEONS AND PATIENTS.
WE NEED MORE RESEARCH ON GUN
VIOLENCE.
FROM THIS STANDPOINT STATE OWNED
FAIRGROUNDS WOULD SERVE
CALIFORNIA BETTER THROUGH GUN
SAFETY EDUCATION.
IT HAS BEEN MY PRIVILEGE.
AND DUTY TO ATTEND.
SEVERAL OF DEL MAR FAIR BOARD
MEETINGS AND SEVERAL PROTESTS
LINES.
OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS TO
PROMOTE GUN SAFETY.
WITH THE ABOVE CONSIDERATIONS IN
MIND I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT AB
EIGHT NINETY THREE TO PROHIBIT
GUN SHOWS.
AT OUR STATE OWNED FAIR GROUNDS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY.
OKAY ANY OTHER -- WHEN THIS IS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE?
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS IRA
SHARP I RESIDE IN THE SEVENTY
EIGHTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND I
SUPPORT AB EIGHT NINETY THREE
AND URGE YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF
IT THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS JENNIFER
LAWN BOMB AND I RESIDE IN THE
SAME DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I'M I'M A MOTHER I'M A RETIRED
CPA I'M A MEMBER OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND I WOULD LIKE
SOME -- ACTION AND RESPONSE TO
THE OVERWHELMING CRY FROM OUR
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND FOR ALL OTHERS
JUST NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
HI I'M ROBBIE AND FIFTEEN YEARS
OLD AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS SAN
DIEGO.
AND I'M HERE TO REPRESENT MY
FELLOW CLASSMATES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELLEN MONTON ARI I
LIVE IN ENCINITAS CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS IN THE DISTRICT AND I
AM HERE REPRESENTING INDIVISIBLE
FORTY NINE AND SUPPORT OUR
REPRESENTATIVE OR ASSEMBLYMAN --
GLORIOUS BILL.
MY NAME'S KELLY HARLESS I AM A
COUNCIL MEMBER IN THE CITY OF
SOLANO BEACH WHICH IS IN THE
SEVENTY EIGHTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB.
EIGHT NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M SURE THE TO ROY
AND I'M A DAD AND A VICE
PRESIDENT OF ENGINEERING I WOULD
RATHER SEE CELL PHONES --
ROBARTS IN OUR BEAUTIFUL CITY SO
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS SIMONE MCCLELLAN I'M
FROM -- CARLSBAD AND I SUPPORT --
REPRESENTATIVE TODD GLORIA.
TODAY IN -- IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
NINETY THREE I'M A CONCERNED
CITIZEN AND INTERIOR DESIGNER.
AND I FEEL THAT WE LIVE IN A
BEAUTIFUL COMMUNITY THAT --
DOESN'T NEED ANYMORE
PROLIFERATION OF THE EPIDEMIC OF
GUN VIOLENCE.
MY NAME IS KATHY MURPHY I LIVE
IN SOLANA BEACH CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION I THINK IT'S BEEN.
OF SUPPORTED BY.
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND BY
MANY MANY PEOPLE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY THANK YOU.
OKAY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING I'M MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAPPING
LYNCH REPRESENTING -- THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION SAFARI CLUB
INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR SPORTS
SINCE COALITION CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY ALL ON
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK THE THE
COMMITTEE OF FOR THAT VERY
THOROUGH ANALYSIS IS ISSUE HAS A
RICH HISTORY -- IN THE
LEGISLATIVE ARENA.
AND I CAN SAY I WAS ONE OF THE
PARTICIPANTS WHEN WE DEVELOP TO
THE GUN SHOW ALL LOSS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH HAVE BEEN SORT OF A
LANDMARK REALLY IN THE COUNTRY
AND EVEN ON THE UC DAVIS A
RESEARCHER WHO WOULD PORTRAY
HIMSELF AS ANTI GUN.
HAS -- INDICATED THAT THE GUN
SHOWS IN CALIFORNIA ARE A MODEL
FOR THE NATION -- WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE SOMETHING
THAT GETS MISSED A LOT OF THE
TIMES IN THAT WHEN THERE ARE GUN
SHOWS THEY OCCURRED DURING THE
DAYTIME ON THE WEEKENDS.
BUT ALL THE APPLICABLE LAWS IN
THE PENAL CODE ON ALL STATE LAWS
ARE COMPLIED WITH BY ALL THE
VENDORS IT'S NOT THAT YOU CAN GO
TO A GUN SHOW.
AND WALK OUT WITH A FIREARM YOU
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE WAITING
PERIODS AND ALL THOSE -- SAME
PROCESSES THAT EXIST -- FOR
EVERYONE ELSE.
THAT MIGHT DO A TRANSACTION AT A
STORE FRONT -- ONE OF THE
CONCERNS OVER THE YEARS -- AND
CONTINUES TO BE A CONCERN IF YOU
DON'T PROVIDE A VENUE FOR A
PRIVATE PARTY TRANSFERS I'VE
THERE'S AN ESTATE SALE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THE GUN SHOW BECOMES A
PRETTY USEFUL VENUE FOR THE OUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE PAST IT'S
BEEN CONCERNED.
ABOUT THE BANNING OF GUN SHOWS
WHICH WOULD DRIVE THE
UNDERGROUND -- SELL SELLING OF
FIREARMS AND THAT ALSO WAS
POINTED OUT IN THE UC DAVIS
STUDY.
IN ADDITION -- I NOTE THAT THIS
IS STATE PROPERTY AND THAT MEANS
THAT THE TAXPAYERS HAVE ACCESS
TO IT THERE ARE FIRST AND SECOND
AMENDMENT ISSUES WITH THIS.
AND I NOTICED THE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT TALKED ABOUT CONCERTS
YES OUR CONCERTS AT THOSE BEEN
USE THOSE OCCUR AT NIGHT AND I
THINK IF YOU CHECK THE RECORD
YOU'LL SEE.
THERE ARE MANY MORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CALLS ON THINGS THAT
GO WRONG IT CONCERTS. FOR
EXAMPLE -- THE ANALYSIS ALSO
DOES POINT OUT -- THAT THERE
THERE IS A LAWSUIT PENDING IN
THE FEDERAL COURT ON
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THIS AND
THE BOARD DOES HAVE THIS UNDER
REVIEWS SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
THINK THAT THAT -- THE CURRENT
STATUTES ARE ARE PERFECTLY FINE
AND THAT -- WE SHOULD ALLOW ALL
THE THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
TO ACCESS OUR STATE FACILITIES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECORD DâN RE WITH NATIONAL
RIGHT TO ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE.
FOR GUN OWNERS THE CALIFORNIA
MISTER PRENTICE HAD AN EMERGENCY
WASN'T ABLE TO MAKE IT -- MY
COLLEAGUE MISS WHEN SHE COVERED
EVERYTHING I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT -- ALL STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS APPLY AT A GUN SHOW
IT'S JUST LIKE PURCHASING A
FIREARM AT A BRICK AND MORTAR
NOTHING CHANGES YOU STILL NEED A
FIRE SAFETY CERTIFICATE THERE
STILL A TEN DAY WAITING PERIOD
THERE STILL IS ALL THE
APPLICABLE.
PAPERWORK AND BACKGROUND CHECKS
SIX CETERA SOME STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT FARMS ACQUIRED A GUN
SHOWS ARE NOT MORE LIKELY TO BE
USED IN A CRIME.
THIS IS JUST -- AN EFFORT TO TO
BE BàN OF THE CULTURE OF
FIREARMS YOU'VE HEARD THAT FROM
SOME OF THE WITNESSES TODAY --
THEY WANT TO GET RID OF THEM.
THIS ISN'T ROOTED IN PUBLIC
SAFETY WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT HERE COMING SAYING
WE NEED TO BAN GUN SHOWS.
AND I ALSO WANT TO REITERATE THE
THE FACT THAT THERE IS A PENDING
LEGAL CHALLENGE ON FIRST AND
SECOND AMENDMENT GROUNDS --
INCLUDING PRIOR RESTRAINT EQUAL
PROTECTION WITH THAT WERE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE WERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL IN THE ATTIC THE
HIGHLIGHT IS TO PREVIOUS
GOVERNORS HAVE BEAT OF THIS
EXACT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
SO LET'S NOT MAKE THAT SAME
MISTAKE THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HERE.
OR YOU MAY CLOSE.
I THINK I JUST NINETY THREE
SOUTH MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN AS
STRICTLY ASPEN.
MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL.
GET A FIRST AND SECOND RICK OFF
THE QUESTION COURSE.
ON AB EIGHT NINETY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAND
AYE BARRICADE HAND I DEEP.
NO.
NO KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I'VE KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS HI WEEKS I
MEASURES ON CALL NEEDS ONE VOTE.
THINK OF A STRUCTURE.
MONDAY THE NINETEENTH.
GIVEN THIS MELINDA'S
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELINDA'S -- AB.
NINE FIFTY NINE I AM.
TWENTY FOUR GOOD MORNING MR VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR HEARING MY BILL
THIS MORNING WHICH IS AB.
NINE FIVE NINE THIS BILL
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VERTICAL
PROSECUTION PROGRAMS IN UP TO
ELEVEN COUNTIES HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS A FORM OF MODERN
DAY SLAVERY THAT MANIPULATE SOME
FORCES VICTIMS.
INTO SEXUAL EXPLOITATION AND
PHYSICAL LABOR VICTIMS ARE
TRAFFICKED NOT ONLY FROM STATE
TO STATE BUT FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES.
VERTICAL PROSECUTION UNITS
INVOLVED ONE OR MORE STAFF TURN
ANY EXCUSE ME ATTORNEYS WHO HAVE
SPECIALIZED TRAINING TO HANDLE
CASES JUST LIKE THIS FROM
ARRAIGNMENT TO CONVICTION.
THIS PROSECUTION MODEL BENEFITS
VICTIMS WHO ARE ALREADY UNDER A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TRAUMA IT
WOULD NO LONGER.
NEED TO CONTACT MULTIPLE
ATTORNEYS TO DEVELOP A
RELATIONSHIP WITH EACH ONE OF
THEM.
AB NINE FIVE NINE WOULD REQUIRE
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
TO ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR VERTICAL
PROSECUTION PROGRAMS AGAINST
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CRIMES FOR UP
TO ELEVEN COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OFFICES.
IN ADDITION CALLOW YES WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE
OUTLINING THE NUMBER OF
PROSECUTIONS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES THE NUMBER OF
CONVICTIONS IN THE SENTENCES
IMPOSED.
ATTORNEYS PERFORMING VERTICAL
PROSECUTION PROVIDE THE
CONSISTENCY AND EXPERTISE
NECESSARY TO CONDUCT SEPARATE
SUCCESSFUL PROSECUTION OF THESE
CALMS COMPLEX CASES.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY MIKE KESTER IN AND IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
AND THE CATHOLIC CONFERENCE HERE
TO TESTIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS GARY PAUL Q. IS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY.
REPRESENTS HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS IN RIVERSIDE COUNTIES
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THANK
YOU MISTER MISTER VICE CHAIR.
GIVE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
IT'S AN HONOR FOR ME TO SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY BECAUSE I COME AT THIS
ISSUE FROM A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
FRONTS.
I COME AS A FATHER WHO WANTS TO
PROTECT HIS CHILDREN FROM THE
DANGERS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AS A COMMUNITY MEMBER THAT SEEKS
TO CREATE A SAFER COMMUNITY
WHERE EVERY MEMBERS VALUED AND
PROTECTED.
BUT I ALSO COME AT THIS FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF BEING ANTI A WHO
AND DEALS WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CASES ON A REGULAR BASIS.
AS SOMEONE WHO SEES THE NEED AND
VALUE FOR VERTICAL PROSECUTION
UNIT.
LAST YEAR I DON'T WHAT THE KEYS
WERE SIXTEEN ALL GIRL FROM
MODESTO WHICH TRAFFICKED.
OUR DRAFTERS TOOK HER FROM A
GROUP HOME IN MODESTO TO SANTA
CLARA DOWN TO BAKERSFIELD TO LOS
ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY SAMBAR
LATINO.
LAS VEGAS RIVERSIDE AND SHE WAS
TAKEN OUT OF THE STATE ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS AS FAR AS
LOUISIANA.
FINALLY BEING RECOVERED IN
MONTEREY COUNTY.
I TELL YOU ABOUT THAT CASE
BECAUSE OF THE MANY LESSONS I
THINK THAT CAN BE LEARNED FROM
IT.
HER CASE IS NOT AN ANOMALY.
BUT RATHER CALM WE OFTEN SHARED
WAR WE OFTEN SEE THE MOVEMENT OF
VICTIMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SECOND IT TOOK A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT I RELIED ON ASSISTANCE
FROM MY COLLEAGUES IN SIX
DIFFERENT COUNTIES TO ASSIST ME
TO LOCATE HER AND BRING HER
TRAFFICKER TO JUSTICE.
BUT THE BIGGEST TAKEAWAY I TOOK
FROM MY CASE WAS THE DIFFERENT
DYNAMICS THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES AND THE
SKILLS SENATE APPROACH NEEDED
WOULD DEALING WITH OUR VICTIMS.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND OUR
VICTIMS AND UNDERSTAND THE
UNDERLYING ISSUES THAT THEY MAY
BE DOING WORK.
AND WE MUST CONTINUE TO LEARN
THE TECHNIQUES OF TRAFFICKERS.
ALSO BEST PRACTICES TO BE USED
IN FIGHTING AGAINST THIS
TERRIBLE CRIME.
OR VERTICAL PROSECUTION UNIT
WOULD ALLOW PROSECUTORS TO
COMBAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING THEY'RE
NOT ONLY CONVICTIONS BUT ALSO
PREVENTION BY WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL NGOS SCHOOLS AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
WERE ALSO EIGHT IN PROVIDING A
TRAUMA CENTERED APPROACH WHEN
DEALING WITH OUR VICTIMS AND
BENEFIT THOSE SEEKING VACATION
RELIEF UNDER PENAL CODE SECTION
TWO THIRTY SIX POINT.
ONE FOUR THIS BILL WOULD RESULT
IN A POSITIVE CHANGE FOR
COMMUNITIES AND STATE.
THIS BILL IS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IT'S SOMETHING
THAT MUST HAPPEN AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATHIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
MARIA JOSE FERNANDEZ FLOORS
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT.
RANGER WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
DON CAP KEY ON BEHALF OF CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SOME.
KATIE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I MAKE A MOTION OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
THIS.
YEAH SO I YOU KNOW I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT I I DON'T KNOW THAT
I THINK THAT THIS IS A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BILL I FEEL LIKE
THIS IS A FUNDING BILL -- AND
IT'S A BUDGET BILL MASKING AS A
POLICY BILL AND I WOULD WONDER
WHY THIS HASN'T GONE THROUGH --
BUDGET SUBDIALECTS T. YOU KNOW
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE LAWS ON THE
BOOKS AS IT RELATES TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING -- AND ALSO SEX
TRAFFICKING -- AND JUST ALSO
QUESTION WHY.
IT'S ALL FUNDING FOR A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES BUT ALSO NO
FUNDING -- FOR PUBLIC DEFENDERS
AND I KNOW THAT WAS IN THE
ANALYSIS I DON'T KNOW IF MEANT
THAT WAS ADDRESSED OR IF THERE'S
SOME AMENDMENTS OR IF THAT'S
BEEN ADDRESS.
SO THE REASON THAT THIS BILL IS --
HERE FIRST AND NINE AND BUDGETS
OF FIVE IS BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
THE THE BILL WAS CUTE ON THAT
WASN'T UP TO ME IF I HAD MY
DECISION AS TO WHERE THE BILL
WOULD GO WOULD GO STRAIGHT TO
THE FLOOR.
BUT THIS BILL IS IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE -- AS FAR AS
THE FINDING THIS IS HOW WE THIS
IS HOW THIS THIS BILL WAS
STRUCTURE IN THE PAST -- THIS
BILL IS COME TO THIS COMMITTEE
TWICE -- AND WHILE YOU ARE
CORRECT THAT THERE IS SOME
FUNDING ATTACHED TO THIS THIS
HAS BEEN THE CASE ALL ALONG
WHICH HAS BEEN APPROPRIATED MY
MIND INTERNAL SAYS MIND HE WAS
VOTED FOR IT -- WE COULD
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WE COULD TRY
TO PUT SOMETHING IN THE BUDGET
BUT I THINK THIS IS A POLICY
MATTER AS WELL WITH RESPECT TO
HOW THESE CASES ARE PROSECUTED --
AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS AS AS
YOU ARE WELL AWARE I'M SURE IS.
IS THE CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR
THESE VICTIMS WHICH IS A POLICY
ISSUE WHICH IS WHY.
I THINK IT IS IN THIS COMMITTEE
THEY'LL WASN'T MY DECISION BUT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONCERNS.
KIM'S LETTERS RIVERS NO OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
CLOTHES WILL BE SHORT I WILL
JUST -- TELL YOU THAT.
IF IF YOU'VE LISTENED TO THE
STORIES OF VICTIMS.
WHO -- MANY OF THEM VERY YOUNG --
MANY OF THEM.
WERE FORCED INTO THIS SOME OF
THEM.
WERE WILLING PARTICIPANTS IN TO
WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS A
RELATIONSHIP AND NOT A
TRAFFICKING ISSUE AND THEN FIND
THEMSELVES IN A SITUATION WHERE
THEY CAN'T GET OUT.
SO TO TELL YOUR STORY TO SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PEOPLE ALONG THE WAY
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IS VERY
TRAUMATIC.
IT'S HARD ENOUGH TO TELL ONE
PERSON AND REMEMBER YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN WHO.
IF YOU DON'T COME FROM A FAMILY
UNIT WHERE THEY FELT SAFE AND
COMFORTABLE -- IN DISCUSSING
WHAT WAS GOING ON THAT THAT'S
PART OF THE REASON WHY THEY
LAUGHED.
SO TO PUT THEM THROUGH THE ADDED
TRAUMA OF TELLING. ONE PERSON
AND ANOTHER PERSON AND ANOTHER
PERSON WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM HE
END UP IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY
DON'T WANT TO TELL ANYONE -- OR
THEY JUST WALK AWAY FROM THE
PROSECUTION ALTOGETHER NO LONGER
PARTICIPATING WITNESS WHICH IS
NOT WHAT WE WANT TO SEE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN VERY GOOD.
ABOUT BRINGING FORWARD BILLS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WHICH
IS GROWING -- AND TRY TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT SO WITH THAT --
I WILL JUST TELL YOU THAT.
I'M I CERTAINLY RESPECT YOUR
CONCERNS ALTHOUGH I THINK WE'RE
PROBABLY ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
HOW WE DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE --
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
OKAY I GUESS YOU WOULD CALL FOR
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE A
FIRST AND SECOND.
ON EIGHTY NINE FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY HI LACKEY AYE BARRICADE
HAND AYE BARRICADE HAND I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT VOTING QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU.
WE'RE ALMOST CERTAIN GAMES OR
ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST YOU
MAY PROCEED.
AB.
FOR THIRTY THREE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR I'VE MOVED THE BILL
MESSAGER.
EVERY OF LOTION.
AND SECOND YOU MAY PROCEED SIR
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
FIRST I WANT TO START OFF.
BY STATING THAT I WILL ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
IN AB FOR THREE THREE INSURERS
THAT VICTIMS OF CRIME CAN RETAIN
THEIR PEACE OF MIND.
AND PURSUE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO RESTITUTION.
THIS BILL REQUIRES CRIME VICTIMS
WERE PROSECUTING ATTORNEYS TO BE
MADE AWARE OF EARLY TERMINATION
OF PROBATION.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT TO NOTIFY CRIME
VICTIMS WHEN A PROBATION TERM IS
TERMINATED EARLY BY THE COURT'S
ORDER.
THIS CAN LEAD TO SITUATIONS
WHERE VICTIMS ARE UNAWARE OF THE
TERMINATION OF PROBATION IN
THEIR CASES.
THIS NOTIFICATION WILL ENSURE
THAT VICTIMS OF CRIME ESPECIALLY
VICTIMS OF INTERPERSONAL OR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE AWARE OF
THESE CHANGES IN PROBATION TERMS.
WHICH MAY INCLUDE BANDS ON
CONTACTING SPECIFIC PEOPLE.
MARCY'S LAW CONSTITUTIVELY
MANDATES PROPER RESTITUTION FOR
VICTIMS OF CRIME.
THIS MANDATE FOR HEALING A
HEARING WILL ENSURE THAT OF
VICTIMS CONSCIOUS CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO RESTITUTION IS
CONSIDERED BEFORE THE EARLY
TERMINATION OF PROBATION.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THE VICTIM
OF CRIME CAN BE MADE WHOLE TO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PER SERVER PURSUE
PROPER RESTITUTION.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS DONE KEPT
KEY REPRESENTING THE CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
I THINK YEAR OLD JOHN CAP KEY
MCCUE CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF CRIME VICTIMS UNITED
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US ON
SOME AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL --
IMPORTANTLY FROM CONVICTIONS
UNITED SIDE FEEDBACK I'M VICTIMS
ARE REQUIRED TO BE PROVIDED
RESTITUTION TO COVER ECONOMIC
LOSSES ASSOCIATE WITH THEIR
VICTIMIZATION.
BUT THERE ARE SOME OCCASIONS
THAT ARISE WHERE THE VICTIMS
LOSSES MAY NOT BE ABLE TO BE
FULLY QUANTIFIED AND DETERMINE
PRIOR TO SENTENCING -- CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS FOR RESTITUTION TO BE
REVISITED BUT THAT MUST OCCUR
PRIOR TO THE END OF TERM AT THE
END OF PROBATION.
WHEN THE COURT ULTIMATELY LOSES
JURISDICTION OVER THE DEFENDANT
THE CHALLENGES THE VICTIMS MAY
NOT HAVE A WAY OF KNOWING THAT
THEY NEED -- TO PERHAPS PETITION
FOR RECONSIDERATION OF
ADDITIONAL RESTITUTION IN CASES
WHERE -- PERHAPS ADDITIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELLING -- WAS --
EXCEEDED THE AMOUNT OF
RESTITUTION ORIGINALLY PROVIDED
A PERHAPS ADDITIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH A RELOCATION FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS WHAT
HAVE YOU.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THIRTY THREE
SIX TO PROVIDE VICTIMS THAT
NOTICE -- TO TO ENSURE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE VICTIM HAS REQUESTED TO BE
NOTIFIED OF THESE TYPES OF
OCCASIONS I TO GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THE CASE FOR
ADDITIONAL RESTITUTION -- BASED
ON COSTS INCURRED.
RELATED TO THEIR VICTIMIZATION
ABOVE WHAT WAS PROVIDED AT THAT
A SENTENCING PERIOD.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
WITH US ON STRONGLY URGE RIGHT
VOTE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATH IS A MAP OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
RANGER WITH RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT THE
PROBATION OFFICERS AND THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY INVESTIGATORS
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE'RE NOT IN
SUPPORT BUT I DID WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE WOULD HAVE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION BASED ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TAKING.
OKAY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
QUESTIONS REQUIREMENTS FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
CATION AROMA SHE MAY CLOSE.
ALL I'M SORRY I MISSED SOMEBODY.
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FOR A DAY --
I DON'T KNOW MAYBE I WOKE UP IN
SOME KIND OF MOOD TODAY -- YEAH
I HAVE I DO HAVE -- SOME
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL I
APPRECIATE THE A SO YOU --
STEPPING FORWARD BUT I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL
ENCROACHING UPON DOUBLE JEOPARDY --
VICTIMS ALREADY.
ARE INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS AND
CAN BE NOTIFIED I HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS RE INSERTING THE
PROSECUTION RE INSERTING -- THE
DA'S OFFICE IS -- BACK INTO A
PROCESS WHERE THEY NO LONGER
HAVE A ROLE -- WHAT YOU END UP
HAVING IS SORT OF A NEVER ENDING
PROSECUTORIAL INVOLVEMENT -- IN
CASES THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ADJUDICATED.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE ALWAYS WANT
TO REAWAKEN.
THE DA'S OFFICES IN THESE ISSUES
AND WHEN.
CASES DO COME BEFORE JUDGES --
THERE IS SOMETHING CALLED A
VICTIM'S IMPACT STATEMENT
[inaudible]
THAT IS.
PRODUCED.
THAT IS HEARD -- AND THAT IS
PLACED INTO THE RECORD -- AND
JUDGES MONITOR THESE CASES AND I
HAVE TO TELL YOU IF THERE ANY
SHENANIGANS OR ANY KIND OF YOU
KNOW.
A MAN AGAINST HAPPENING -- THAT
ALSO IS IN VIOLATION AND WILL BE
BROUGHT BEFORE THE JUDGE USUALLY
ON FOLKS ARE ASKING FOR EARLY
TERMINATION IT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET A JOB THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET A LOAN THEY'RE
TRYING TO MOVE ON WITH THEIR
LIFE.
AND THIS SORT OF KEEPS THEM ON
THIS NEVER ENDING FERRIS WHEEL
OF INCARCERATION -- VICTIMS
ALREADY ARE [inaudible]
SQUARELY PLACED IN THE MIDST OF
THIS PROCESS -- SO I JUST HAVE.
TO JUST SORT OF STATE THAT I
HAVE THOSE -- KINDS OF CONCERNS
WITH THESE -- WITH THESE KINDS
OF CASES -- LAWS -- THAT ARE
BROUGHT BEFORE US AND AND WHY WE
NEED TO INVOLVE A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TO KIND OF JUST JUMP
BACK INTO THE MIX AND FIGURE OUT
A WAY -- TO DENY FOLKS THE
ABILITY TO KIND OF REHABILITATE.
AND MOVE ON WITH THEIR LIVES IS
CONCERNING I JUST WANTED TO
REGISTER THAT CONCERN.
OKAY NOW YOU MAY CLOSE WILL
THINK IT AND IN RESPONSE TO THAT --
IN PART OF OF THIS MOVING
FORWARD AND ACTUALLY ENSURES
THAT THE VICTIM WILL BE NOTIFIED
RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT SENATE STONE THAT THEY ARE
NOTIFIED DURING THIS TIME.
THEY HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO
THAT.
I THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
JUST KNOW -- TO UNDER CURRENT A
STATUTE TODAY THE PROSECUTING
ATTORNEY IS GIVEN A NOTICE ARE
READY AND THESE CASES -- WE ARE
JUST SEEKING FOR KIND OF A VERY
SMALL SUBSET OF CASES WHERE A
VICTIM WHAT ARE BE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIM AS SOMEONE THAT
PERHAPS IS VICTIMIZED HAS
ADDITIONAL COUNSELING ABOVE THE
RESTITUTION ORDERED AGAIN SOME
OF SOMETIMES SOME OF THOSE --
COSTS ARE HARD TO DETERMINE AT
THE TIME OF SENTENCING -- WE
DON'T NECESSARILY BELIEVE THAT
THERE WILL BE A YOU KNOW AN
INORDINATE TO NUMBER OF CASES
WHERE A VICTIM YOU KNOW WHAT
ACTUALLY PURSUE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEEK OUT ADDITIONAL
RESTITUTION.
BUT IN THOSE CASES WHERE KIND OF
TO DAY ARE PROVIDED NOTICE AT
LEAST THEY HAVE THAT ABILITY TO
BE NOTIFIED AND AND AND SEEK
THAT OUT BUT THE PROSECUTORS
ALREADY GIVEN NOT NOTICE UNDER
CURRENT LAW AT THIS TIME.
PRIDE IN THE LANGUAGE ARE A I'M
IS.
VIOLENCE OR RIGHT [inaudible]
YOU'RE NOT.
THIS BILL AND WE'RE NOT SPECIFIC --
AND CASES ARE GOING TO PRICE TAG
RIGHT -- CHARACTERS IN YOUR RANK
NO SO IT IT'S VICTIMS WHO AND
CURVE ACOSTA SENSITIVE THEIR
VICTIMIZATION DAY AGAIN WOULD
HAVE.
TO YOU KNOW MAKE THAT CASE TO
THE COURT FOR WHY YOU KNOW THE
COURT SHOULD EVEN CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL RESTITUTION ABOVE
WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY I PROVIDED --
SO IT'S NOT AN AUTOMATIC WHERE
THE VICTIM WOULD BE
AUTOMATICALLY GIVEN THE UP THAT
ADDITIONAL YOU KNOW --
RESTITUTION AMOUNTED DATES THEY
WOULD HAVE TO DAM BEING COMING
UPON THEM TO MAKE THE CASE FOR
THAT WHETHER IT'S DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIM -- WHETHER TO
SEXUAL SOLD THAT -- A STOCKING
OUT WHAT HAVE YOU SO IT'S I MEAN
THE THE BURDEN WOULD BE ON THE
VICTIM THEMSELVES TO WORK WITH
THE PROSECUTOR -- IN YOU KNOW TO
SEEK ARE KIND OF THAT
OPPORTUNITY BUT IT WOULD BE IN
EVERY CASE IT WOULDN'T BE A
WHOLE SLEW OF CASES WE WOULD
EXPECT.
ALL DUE RESPECT IT'S TIME FOR
THE CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND AYE AYE AGAIN REITERATING
THAT WE DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE THERE.
ELECTRIC RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S PROBABLY MOVED AND SECONDED
SO WILL NOW CALL FOR THE
QUESTION.
ON EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
HI LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAN HI
BARRICADE HAND I DEEP
[inaudible]
I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NO QUIRK.
I SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS HI WICKS I
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I ALL RIGHT.
MEASURE PASSES GARAGE RELATIONS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SHE HAS.
WE HAVE MISSED IRWIN UP NEXT SHE
HAS [inaudible] THREE ITEMS --
AB. TWELVE A. B..
THREE FORTY IS THAT FOUR FIVE
FIVE I CAN'T READ OR SIX FOUR
BUT I CAN'T READ YOU'RE
HANDWRITING.
WELL LET ME TELL YOU WHICH ONE
SHE'S GOING FIRST [inaudible]
JUST. FOR FIVE AB TWELVE FIRST.
YES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR JONES SAWYER
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWELVE
TO THIS MORNING AND WITH THAT
WILL -- MAKE A CHANGE AND TWO
CLARIFICATIONS RELATING TO GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS LAID OUT
IN THE MOCK UP ATTACHED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
AB TWELVE IS ONE OF A PACKAGE OF
BILLS THAT I'M OFFERING THIS
SESSION IN RESPONSE TO THE
BORDERLINE SHOOTINGS IN MY
DISTRICT THAT TOOK THE LIVES OF
TWELVE OF MY CONSTITUENTS LAST
FALL.
YOU DID VOTE ON THE FIRST BILL
WHICH ESTABLISHED A G. V. R. O.
POLICY A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
I SPENT THE LAST FEW MONTHS
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS INCLUDING
INDIVISIBLE TO DEVELOP
LEGISLATION THAT COULD WORK TO
AVOID ANOTHER TRAGEDY LIKE THE
ONE INFLICTED UPON MY COMMUNITY.
WE ARE OWES AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
OUR NEW TOOL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CREATED TO PRO
ACTIVELY INTERVENE IN DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHILE MOST TV ARE OWES BEGAN AS
ORDERS THAT LAST TWENTY ONE DAYS
THE COURT MAY ORDER YOUR LONG
PRO -- PROHIBITION AFTER NOTICE
TO THE INDIVIDUAL AND THE
HEARING.
AB TWELVE PROVIDES PROVIDES
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO SET THE
TIME PERIOD FOR A JEEP YARO.
AFTER NOTICING HEARING --
BETWEEN ONE TO FIVE YEARS TO
ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN TO THE
COURTS FAMILIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO EXTEND THE GDR
ROSE ON A YEARLY BASIS.
IF THE G. V. R. O. [inaudible]
OF ORDER FROM WAS LONGER THAN
ONE YEAR THE INDIVIDUAL WOULD
RETAIN A YEARLY ABILITY TO
PETITION THE COURT FOR MOBILE OF
THE ORDER ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS
WITH.
WHO NO LONGER POSE A DANGER TO
RECOVER THEIR FIREARMS BUT THE
COURT WOULD NOT NEED TO REVIEW
ORDERS EVERY YEAR -- SO -- IF
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY THAT IS A
STRONG LIKELIHOOD OF CONTINUING
DANGER LIKES THOSE BASED ON A A
DIAGNOSIS OF ALZHEIMER'S OR
DEMENTIA.
THE BILL ALSO CLARIFIES THAT THE
ALLOWANCE AN EXISTING LAW FOR
TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO STORE OR
SELL FIREARMS TO REGISTER DEALER
ONLY APPLIES WHEN AN EX PARTE OR
NOTICE AND HEARING TV ARE ALWAYS
SERVE BY CIVIL PROCESS SERVER.
NOT WHEN A TV ARE -- IS SERVED
BY A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
THIS AVOIDS THE NONSENSICAL
INTERPRETATION THAT A PERSON WHO
IS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND A JUDGE
BELIEVE IS DANGEROUS IS ALLOWED
TO HAVE AN ENTIRE DAY TO DO AS
THEY PLEASE WITH A FIREARM.
HERE TODAY WITH ME IS VENTURA
COUNTY SHERIFF BILL A YUBA
SPONSOR OF THE BILL SURE FOR YOU.
A GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
JONES SAWYER -- MEMBERS --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR ONE MENTION I
BELIEVE THEY ARE FOR VENTURA
COUNTY.
AND I'M I'M PLEASE COME HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE WHICH MAKES CHANGES TO
THE EXISTING GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
HAS ASSEMBLY WOMAN -- WHEN
MENTIONED AN ACT OF GUN VIOLENCE
OCCURRED IN OUR COMMUNITY LAST
YEAR AND TOOK THE LIVES OF
TWELVE PEOPLE AT THE BORDERLINE
BAR AND GRILL -- ONE OF MY
DEPUTIES SO ONE OF OUR DEPUTY
SERGEANT RON HILL IS.
A LIGHT LOSSES LIFE THAT EVENING
PROTECTING RESIDENTS.
BOTH YOUNG AND OLD OUT TO ENJOY
A NIGHT OF DANCING.
OUR COMMUNITY HAS COME TOGETHER
SINCE THAT NIGHT NOVEMBER IN
MEANINGFUL WAYS. TO BOTH
REMEMBER THOSE WE LOST AND TO
WORK TOWARDS PREVENTING ANOTHER.
TRAGEDY FROM OCCURRING AGAIN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AB TWELVE IS ONE OF A HANDFUL OF
BILLS THAT HAVE COME OUT OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
AND I BELIEVE BUILDS UPON
CALIFORNIA'S NATION LEADING LAWS
RELATING TO GUN VIOLENCE.
AS LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL HAVE
SWORN TO PROTECT AND SERVE MY
COMMUNITY.
AND IT IS TRUE LEGAL TOOLS THE
LEGISLATURE GIVES US THAT WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH THAT DUTY.
AB TWELVE WILL BUILD UPON THOSE
TOOLS AND I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB [inaudible]
TWELVE THANK YOU.
UNDER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA --
THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WANTS
EFFORTS ALSO WANT TO SPEAK UP ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
EXCUSE ME THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURES WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY MATH IS ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
SHOT SHOWING YOUR MIKE OKAY
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN.
I'M ACTUALLY HERE TO SAY THAT WE
HAVE WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH US ON OUR
CONCERNS AND WE ARE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION.
I WORRY PASSED ENOUGH TO GET
HERE BEFORE YOU SAID OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THIS IS JAMIE WANTED TO THE
SHORE MIKE AS WELL JUST TO A
BRIEF YES -- MISTER GENERIC
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD DâN
READ WITHOUT HER I FOR SO
STATION ALSO HERE FOR GUN OWNERS
A CALIFORNIA MISTER PRESS COULD
MAKE IT TODAY BECAUSE OF A
FAMILY EMERGENCY.
WE ARE TAKING A LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS AND EVALUATING THOSE
BUT WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
UNDERLYING G. R. O. PROCESS.
AND EXPANDING THAT AN EXTENDING
THE DURATION -- KEEP IN MIND
THESE ARE PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME OR JUDICATA
MENTALLY ILL AND COULD PUT HIM.
IN A STATE WHERE THEY'RE AT DO
NOT HAVE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS FOR UP TO FIVE YEARS IN
THE BURDEN IS ON THEM FOR
INCREASED COSTS WITH APPEALING
THOSE DECISIONS IN THOSE ORDERS
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN REGRET THAT ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL ASSOCIATION WE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF KEEPING.
FARMS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
CRIMINALS AND THOSE FOLKS THAT
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN WE ALSO FEEL
THAT THE SYSTEM IN PLACE
CURRENTLY COULD WORK IF IT'S
UTILIZED AND WE'RE AGAINST THE
EXTENSION OF TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
DID YOU.
WHICH SIDE ARE YOU ON I'M
CONFUSED NOW FIGURE THAT OUT.
GOOD MORNING MR KERRY NOT YOUR
HERNANDEZ SOME HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND I THINK THE AUTHORS
OFFICE FOR HAVING EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH US.
LOOKING FORWARD TO SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS -- OUR ISSUE IS AGAIN
JUST INCLUDING -- IF THERE'S
GOING TO BE ANY FUNDING FOR
FEDERAL PROSECUTION OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE DEFENSE IS ALSO -- FULLY
FULLY FUNDED AS WELL -- AND WE
DO NOT KNOW THAT THOUGHT IT
SHOWS THAT THERE ARE SOME
PROBLEMS WITH THE DATABASE
UNDERLYING DATABASE.
SO WE'RE JUST GONNA TRY TO SEE
IF WE CAN MAKE THE BILL OF A
STRONGER LEVEL THERE I WANT TO
THANK THE OTHERS OFFICE FOR THE
CONVERSATION.
A MARYLAND BILL.
OKAY SAY THAT TESTIMONY.
SO YOU SHOULD MOVE SAID ABOUT
WITH A FIFTY NOT ON THE SAME
TIME.
MANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
IT.
NO OKAY YOU MAY CLOSE MISSOURI
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I THE THE
CHURCH RECOMMENDING AND I CALL
THE ROLL UP.
FIRST REMOVED OKAY.
ON A. B. TWELVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED JONES SAWYER HI
JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT BOATING BARRICADE
HAND I BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
HI.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE BUT NOT VOTING
QUIRK HI.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS HI WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES. TO YOUR NEXT --
ONE I WILL NOW BE PRESENTING AB --
THREE FORTY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SIX THE DOJ HAS MAINTAINED THE
ARMED AND PROHIBITED PERSON
SYSTEM PROGRAM AN AUTOMATIC DATE
OF AN AUTOMATED DATABASE THAT
CROSS REFERENCES GUN
REGISTRATION DATA.
WITH LISTS OF PROHIBITED PERSONS
A PERSISTENT BACKLOG OF OVER TEN
THOUSAND POTENTIALLY ARMED
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THE APP
SYSTEM UNDERLINES THE NEED.
FOR A NEW APPROACH DESPITE
RECEIVING OVER TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN TWENTY FOURTEEN HIGH
RATES OF VACANCIES AND TURN OVER.
AMONG SPECIAL AGENTS LAND AB
THREE FORTY CREATES A PILOT
PROGRAM TO FIND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCES THAT
WOULD DISARM PROHIBITED PERSONS
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION.
I'M ALSO LEADING A BUDGET ASK
WITH OTHER MEMBERS THAT WOULD
FUND THIS PILOT PROGRAM
DIVERTING A SMALL PORTION OF THE
ADDITIONAL FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOME PROPOSED IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET FOR THE APPS PROGRAM.
WITH NO SOLUTION TO STAFFING
IMPEDIMENTS THAT THE DOJ TO
ALLOW THE APPS PROGRAM TO BE
FULLY STAFFED AND LAST YEAR'S
NUMBERS SHOWING IT IS MORE
LIKELY THAT A PROHIBITED PERSON
WILL DIRE HAVE THEIR PROHIBITION
EXPIRE RATHER THAN THE DOJ --
AGENT INVESTIGATING THEM IT'S
TIME TO EXPLORE A NEW APPROACH
THAT AUGMENTS THE WORK OF THE
DOJ.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS VENTURA
COUNTY SHERIFF DELAY YOU.
SPONSOR AGAIN OF THE GOOD
MORNING AGAIN MORNING MEMBERS --
FOR THE RECORD BILLION SHERIFF
OF ENTER CANDY I AM PLEASED TO
COME HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE FORTY WHICH CREATES A
PILOT PROGRAM FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HELP REDUCE
BACKLOGS.
IN ASSURING THE COMPLIANCE OF
THOSE PROHIBITED FROM POSSESSING
FIREARMS.
AB THREE FORTY IS ONE MORE OF A
HANDFUL OF BILLS THAT STEM FROM
THE CONVERSATIONS.
THAT WERE SPURRED AS A RESULT OF
THE VIOLENCE AT THE BORDERLINE
BAR AND GRILL IN NOVEMBER.
AND I BELIEVE BUILDS UPON
CALIFORNIA'S.
LEADING GUN LAWS RELATED TO GUN
VIOLENCE.
MY DEPARTMENT MANY OTHERS CROSS
STRAIT THE STATE OF A STRONG
INTEREST IN BEING A FORCE
MULTIPLIER FOR THE DOJ.
AND REDUCING THE APPS BACKLOG.
A RECENT SWEEPS INVOLVING LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF DEMONSTRATE
THE VALUE OF LEVERAGING LOCAL
OFFICERS IN THIS EFFORT.
THE SHERIFFS AND POLICE OFFICERS
ARE WELL EQUIPPED TO CONDUCT
APPS INVESTIGATIONS.
BECAUSE OF OUR FAMILIARITY WITH
OUR COMMUNITIES AND RESIDENTS.
WE SERVE AND ARE USUALLY
PROHIBITED DUE TO FELONIES AND
MISDEMEANORS ARE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS.
THAT WERE INVESTIGATED BY OUR
DEPARTMENTS -- JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE DURING.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE CAMERA
POLICE DEPARTMENT -- WHICH IS
STAFFED BY DEPUTY SHERIFFS SO
WITH THE VENTURA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
INVESTIGATED INCIDENTS THE
RESULT OF A SEIZURE OF OVER
EIGHTY FIVE FIREARMS AND
THOUSANDS OF ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITIONS.
DURING THE COURSE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT RELATED
INVESTIGATIONS.
WERE WERE VERY GOOD AT HANDLING
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE SORT OF
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IS READY
TO STEP UP AND PLAY A LARGER
ROLE.
IN RECOVERING FIREARMS IN THE
APPS PROGRAM.
AND I ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB.
TWELVE THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT AS WELL
AS THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
AND I'LL MAKE A MOTION WITH THE
BILL.
RT ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE VERY HARD FOR ME SO I JUST
REPEAT WHAT I WHAT I SAID BEFORE
WHAT I SAID BEFORE SO I I WANNA
THINK OTHERS OFFICE WORKING WITH
US WE HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON THE
BUDGET ITEM AS WELL SO I THINK
WE'LL PROBABLY BE FINE.
AND YES I DO -- REPEAT MY
ENQUIRING AS TO WHY SENATE
PUBLIC SPEAKING SIMPLY PUBLIC
SAFETY CONTINUE TO MEET AT THE
EXACT SAME TIME EVERY.
EVERY TUESDAY CELL I KNOW A LOT
OF US ARE THINKING.
THANK YOU I CONCUR WITH HIS
COMMENTS.
KATHY LENDS REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION OUTDOOR SPORTSMAN'S
COLLISION CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S
LOBBY AND SPARKLING
INTERNATIONAL APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S COMMENTS WE DON'T AGAIN
OPPOSE THE CONCEPT HERE WE HAVE.
THE APP PROGRAM HAS BEEN A
FESTERING PROBLEM AND I'M IN THE
CAPITAL FOR A LONG TIME WE ALL
SUPPORT.
RESOLVING THE ISSUES THERE WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING MECHANISM IS NOT THE
DEALER RECORD OF SALE -- FROM
LEGITIMATE FIREARMS PURCHASES
THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN.
SUPPORT OR TWEENER STORE.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YES THIS WORKS JUST ONE
QUESTION JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
SO FOR THIS PILOT PROGRAM --
THIS WOULD AUGMENT OR BE IN
ADDITION TO THE DOJ'S PROGRAM
DOJ'S PROGRAM CRACKED AND ENDS
AND NOT INSTEAD OF BUT IN
ADDITION.
TO A CONCLUSION.
THANK YOU DID YOU.
SO I HAVE A QUESTION.
WHY ARE WE NOT JUST HOLDING DOJ
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING THEIR JOB --
AS OPPOSED.
TO COMING UP WITH ANOTHER
PROGRAM THAT IN MY MIND KIND OF
IS AN END RUN AROUND -- SEARCH
WARRANTS AND GIVES --
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHERRY PICK HOW
THEY WANTED TO END RUNS AROUND
SEARCH WARRANTS.
OF I THINK THERE'S BEEN THERE
HAVE BEEN EFFORTS OVER THE YEAR
TO HOLD -- DOJ MORE ACCOUNTABLE
TO THEIR NUMBERS AND WE THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL JUST
AUGMENT WHAT THEY'RE DOING SO
THAT WE CAN REALLY START TO MAKE
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT TO ON
REDUCING THE INVENTORY SO.
AND AS FAR AS AND AND ROUND AND
ROUND SEARCH WARRANTS I'M I'M
NOT SURE -- WHAT YOU MEAN BY
THAT -- WELL OKAY SO WHAT I MEAN
IS -- THEY'RE SORT OF ALREADY
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN DOJ HAS A PROGRAM I HEAR
YOUR CONCERNS AND YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT IT NOT HAPPENING FAST
ENOUGH SO.
RATHER THAN SORT OF CREATE
SOMETHING ELSE.
THAT YOU ALSO HAVE TO MONITOR --
THAT ALSO COMES WITH
COMPLICATIONS -- WHY NOT HOLD
THE FOLKS THAT ARE ACCOUNTABLE --
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING
THIS JOB -- ACCOUNTABLE HAVE
THEM COME DOWN AND TALK ABOUT
WHY THEY'RE NOT MOVING AS
QUICKLY AS FOLKS WOULD LIKE YOU
KNOW ULTIMATELY YOU ARE
EMPOWERING AND FUNDING.
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE'RE DECIDING
WHICH ONES WILL BE SELECTED BUT
YOU'RE EMPOWERING THEM TO ALSO
GO IN AND AND DO THIS KIND OF
WORK WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING --
THERE IS WHEN WE GET IT RIGHT --
THAT SINCE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN YOU KNOW THERE
HAS BEEN IN PLACE A PROHIBITED
PERSONS FIREARMS RELINQUISHMENT
FORM THAT HAS TO GET FILLED OUT
AT THE END OF ANY CASE IF YOU
DON'T YOU'RE IN VIOLATION AND
THERE IS FOLLOW UP AND
MONITORING THEY READ TAKE FIRE
ARMS IMMEDIATELY -- UPON
CONCLUSION OF THESE CASES SO
THEN TO SAY HEY WHY DON'T WE
FUND AND EMPOWER CERTAIN
DEPARTMENTS WHO MAY BE OPERATING
WITH INTEGRITY OR NOT TO KIND OF
CHERRY PICK HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
GO BACK -- YOU KNOW IN CERTAIN
CASES OPEN THEM UP FOLLOW
CERTAIN PEOPLE -- TOO BAD YOU
KNOW DO WHATEVER THEY'RE GOING
TO DO JUST KIND OF CONCERNS ME
AND THE REASON WHY SHARED IS
BECAUSE THERE WAS AN INSTANCE
WHERE -- A GENTLE MAN -- IT WAS
LISTED ON THE POLICE REPORT THAT
HIS FIREARMS HAD BEEN TAKEN.
PROBATION THROUGH SOME PAPERWORK
ERROR.
HAD IT LISTED THAT THEY WEREN'T.
HIS RIGHTS ARE VIOLATED.
BUSTED DOWN HIS DOOR.
JACK HIM UP [inaudible]
CHARGED HIM.
AND ONCE ITWAS ALL REVEAL
BECAUSE OF DUE PROCESS THEY
REALIZE.
HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY GUNS AND IN
FACT THERE WAS A PAPERWORK ERROR.
SO.
WE'RE SORT OF EMPOWERING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE KINDS OF
INSTANCES TO CONTINUE TO OCCUR --
WITH POPULATIONS THAT ARE
ALREADY OVER POLICE DEALING WITH
OVER COMPLIANCE AND AN OVER
PUNISHMENT SO WHY DON'T WE JUST.
HOLD THE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE THAT
WE HAVE ALREADY FUNDED TO DO THE
JOB THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
[inaudible]
UGH.
TODAY YES THE FUNDING HAS THE
EVERY YEAR THERE HAS BEEN A
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
OF THE AYE.
PERHAPS SURE OF A YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THIS BUT FOR US WE
THINK IT CAN BE -- IT WOULD BE
MORE EFFICIENT.
OBVIOUSLY IF THERE'S A MISTAKE
WITH THE DATABASE THAT'S A WHOLE
NOTHER PROBLEM WE THINK THAT IT
COULD POSSIBLY BE MORE EFFICIENT
I HAVE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHO KNOWS THE LOCAL COMMUNITY BE
ABLE TO WORK ON THE LIST OF
THOSE PROHIBITED POSSESSORS AND
ON THAT LIST THERE I MEAN
THERE'S A THERE'S A STANDARD FOR
WHO IS ON THE LIST?
AND SO THIS GIVES LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO USE THE INTELLIGENCE THEY
ALREADY HAVE TO WORK ON ON THE
LIST IF THE LIST IS INCORRECT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO KNOW TO SO THESE
THE THIS WOULD BE A PILOT
PROGRAMS AND THREE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES -- WHERE THE SHERIFFS
HAVE ALREADY AGREED AND THAT
WOULD BE VERY CAREFUL DATA TAKEN
SAYS TO TO SEE IF THERE IS A
MODEL THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO
AUGMENT WHAT THE DOJ IS DOING?
AND THE IDEA THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HELPS THE DOJ IS NOT.
UNIQUE THIS TIME THE DOJ WAS
GIVEN FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
I THINK IT WAS THREE YEARS AGO --
TO HAVE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUGMENTS THE WORK THEY'RE DOING
AND THAT MEN MONEY ENDED UP
BEING ON SPENT AND CAME RIGHT
BACK INTO THE GENERAL FUND SO
SAID.
THIS WAY WE WILL GET GOOD
STATISTICS.
AND WE'LL SEE HOW ACCURATE THE
DATABASES THAT THE DOJ IS OF
MAINTAINING.
YOU KNOW.
I'M SORRY.
BUT THAT KILLER IN YOUR DISTRICT
WHO MURDERED THOSE PEOPLE.
HE WAS NOT ON THE LIST.
HE HAD FAMILY MEMBERS OR FRIENDS
WHO.
YOU KNOW MAYBE I DON'T KNOW HAD
SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT HIS MENTAL
HEALTH AND HIS BEHAVIOR.
BUT NOBODY WENT AND GOT AT G. B.
R. O. WHICH WAS ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS BECAUSE MAYBE HE DIDN'T
LOOK DANGEROUS ENOUGH FOR THEY
DON'T WANT US NATURE.
IT CAN HAPPEN IN MY FAMILY OR HE
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A DANGEROUS
PERSON HE DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THE
PERSON WHO WOULD BE CAPABLE OF
DOING THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
YOU KNOW THAT'S BIAS WHICH IS
INHERENT IN SO MANY OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE
HAPPENING THAT WE'RE HAVING
RIGHT NOW.
BUT THAT PERSON WOULDN'T EVEN BE
IN THIS LIST FOR SOMEONE -- TO
CHECK UP ON AND HE'S A VERY GUY
THAT DID THOSE ATROCIOUS ACTS.
THIS ISN'T GOING TO GET HIM.
WHY DON'T WANT TO GET INTO
WHETHER BILL SO WHAT YOUR
QUESTION WAS COME ALIVE AND
HAVING A MOMENT MY BUT MY
QUESTION WAS THE SAME ABOUT
FUNDING ABOUT HOW THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS ARE PACKED?
YOU KNOW THERE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS AND ARTICLES IN
THE NEWS ACROSS THE STATE ABOUT
CERTAIN SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE OPERATING WITH
INTEGRITY AND THAT ARE NOT.
IS THAT TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION WITH REGARD TO
THIS BILL.
SO YOU CAN ADDRESS THAT IN YOUR
CLOSER ANYONE ELSE WITH ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND YOU CAN ADDRESSED AS YOUR
CLOTHES [inaudible]
OF DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT WOULD LIKE.
TO HAVE ANY FINISHING CLOSING
STATEMENTS.
WELL JUST JUST TO COMMENT ON ON
THIS FAMILY MEMBERS -- REMARKS
REGARDING -- YOU SERVING THE
SEARCH FOR PROCESS THIS THIS
THIS DOES NOT IN ANY WAY CHANGE
THE RULES OF SEARCH AND SEIZURE
THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLACE.
IN THE STATE -- IS SIMPLY A
REDIRECT THE TASKING OF
FULFILLMENT OF THE APPS LIST TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IS PILOT
PROJECT IS. TO TO SEE IF IT'S
MORE EFFECTIVE THAN AND I WERE
ABLE TO KEEP GUNS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE THAT SHOULDN'T
HAVE THEM.
OKAY THANK YOU.
DID YOU WANNA ADD UP I I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DRIVE A
THANK YOU -- SO I'VE
[inaudible]
SO HERE'S HERE'S THE CHAIRS
DILEMMA -- I BELIEVE WE NEED TO
GIVE MORE.
RESOURCES TO LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT SO THAT THEY CAN AID
DOJ IN ELIMINATING PEOPLE ARE
PROHIBITED -- BLESSED
[inaudible]
OF WHICH DURING THE BUDGET
PROCESS I WILL BE TALKING SO I
DO SIT ON SUB FIVE SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THAT.
WITH WITH DOCTOR WEBER --
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO -- I ALSO
BELIEVE SOMEBODY NEEDS TO BE IN
CHARGE AND I THINK PART OF THE
CONCERN IS.
DOJ IS SUPPOSED TO BE IN CHARGE
WE WE NEED TO MAKE THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE HAVE A NEW COLLECTED THAT HE
WENT TO OUR COMMITTEE WE JUST
APPOINTED A JUST GOT REELECTED A
NEW -- ATTORNEY GENERAL SO HE'S
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
SO YOU CAN GET THE JOB DONE WE
NEED.
TO GET ON THEIR WITH.
HE NEEDS TO HE NEEDS TO DO IS ON
PLAN ON HOW TO GET THIS DONE --
SO FOR ME IT WAS A COORDINATED
EFFORT IF WE COULD WITH THE DOJ
AT THE HEALTH.
BECAUSE I NEED TO BLAME SOMEBODY
IF IT DOESN'T WORK I CAN'T.
I DON'T WANT TO COME BACK AND
I'M BLATANT ABOUT PUTTING YOU ON
GLASS BUT ONLY DOUBLE AFTER YOU
CHIEF AND THEN THERE'S TWO OTHER
PROGRAMS AND THEY FAIL.
FUNDS TO A GOOD ONE FAILS AND
NOBODY.
IS TAKING THE BLAME FOR IT WE'RE
STILL POINT BEING.
AT THE END OF THE DAY -- AND
I'VE SPOKEN TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THAT -- THIS IS AN ISSUE
HE HAS -- TO ULTIMATELY A FIX
AND ALSO DON'T AND THAT'S WHY
THIS IS IN POLICY COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW NOT MOSTLY IN.
IS WHETHER NOT WE WANT TO TAKE
SOME OF THIS.
RESPONSIBILITY AWAY FROM HIM AND
ALMOST GIVE IT TO THE LOCALS.
AND SO -- THAT'S WHY COULDN'T WE
WERE STILL KIND OF DEVELOPING IT.
AND I KNOW YOU AND I WAS ARE WE
JUST WE DISAGREE.
KINDA DISAGREE BUT WE HAD TWO
DIFFERENT CONCEPT OF HOW THIS
SHOULD BE DONE -- IF THIS YOU
FAIL I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU
REVISIT IT IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
AND WITH THE PROVISO THAT WE
MAKE.
D. O. J. D. ATTORNEY GENERAL --
RESPONSIBLE FOR BUT MOST
IMPORTANT WE HAVE SOMEBODY
THAT'S DOING IT LEAD. TO MAYBE
EVEN GIVE OUT THE GRANT.
SO THAT -- WE MAKE SURE THEY GET
DONE SO THE QUESTION IS THAT THE
CONSUMERS WERE ASKING CAN BE
RESOLVED IN THAT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T RESOLVE IT.
I DON'T THINK WE RESULT RIGHT
NOW.
SO.
IS THERE A SECOND TO THE MOTION
[inaudible]
A SECOND [inaudible]
CALDERON.
ON AB THREE FORTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NOT VOTING LACKEY.
LACKEY FIVE BARRICADE HAN HI
BARRICADE HAND I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT VOTING QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS [inaudible]
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
AND ONE LAST ITEM [inaudible]
I REMEMBER. TEN EIGHTY SIX AND
AS AB.
SIX FORTY FIVE AB SIX FOUR FIVE
REQUIRES POSTING OF THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE ON
EXISTING LABELS ON GUN PACKAGING
ON THE FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATION EXAM AND ON NEW
SIGNS AND GUN SHOPS.
THERE'S BEEN A STARTLING
INCREASE OF FIREARMS SUICIDES IN
CALIFORNIA AND CURRENTLY THERE'S
NO MANDATE IN MANDATED
INFORMATION ON SUICIDE
PREVENTION RESOURCES.
AT ANY POINT DURING THE PROCESS
OF OBTAINING A FIREARM.
THIS CAP WAS HIGHLIGHTED TO ME
BY A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN
VENTURA COUNTY WHO WAS A VETERAN.
WHO HAD LOST HIS OWN BROTHER A
VETERAN TO A FIREARM SUICIDE?
AND I'M PROUD TO BE OFFERING HIS
LEGISLATIVE IDEA IT IS MY HOPE
THAT AB SIX FOUR FIVE WILL
REDUCE FIREARM SUICIDE BY
PROVIDING GREATER ACCESS. TO
VALUABLE INFORMATION THAT CAN
ASSIST AN INDIVIDUAL IN TIME OF
CRISIS.
I MOVE THE BILL MR I GUESS.
ANY OF THE WITNESSES ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS BETSEY
ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WERE SICK AND SALAS ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANY OF THE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT CAPULETS REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION I'M HERE AND I'M NOT
REALLY OPPOSITION I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THE SPIRIT OF THE GOAL
BUT MAYBE TO OFFER -- ANOTHER
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO
APPROACH THIS THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
REPRESENTS THE FIREARMS
RETAILERS DISTRIBUTOR
MANUFACTURERS AND SPORTSMAN.
AND FIREARMS USERS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE -- BEEN AND EMBARKED
UPON A PROGRAM WHICH IS BEING
HANDED OUT TO YOU RIGHT NOW WITH
THE AMERICAN FOUNDATION FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION -- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THIS COMMITTEE
SPENT TALKING A LOT ABOUT ON I'M
A VARIETY OF TALK TOPICS IN.
A TRAINING AT PROVIDES ONLINE
VIDEOS IT PROVIDES POSTERS
FLYERS FOR CUSTOMERS COUNTER
TOPS -- DECALS AND WE WERE HERE
WHEN THE BAKER BILL THE ANALYSIS
IS VERY THOROUGH WITH THE
HISTORY -- AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FIVE WHICH BY THE WAY JUST WENT
INTO EFFECT IN JANUARY SO ALL
THE WARNING LABELS ALL THE
POSTINGS JUST WENT INTO EFFECT
THIS YEAR I THINK THE BAKER BILL
ADDED.
THE NUMBER.
NINE ON THE LIST OF THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED THIS.
CREATES NUMBER TEN AND I THINK
WE ALL KNOW WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS ON A NUMBER OF
SUBJECTS WHETHER IT'S PROP SIXTY
FIVE OR WHATEVER -- POSTING YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT YOU REACH A
POINT OF SATURATION WHERE IN NO
LONGER IS EFFECTIVE IN SUICIDES
JUST REALLY TO IMPORTANT PORT TO
GET BURIED IN A WARNING LABEL IN
A BOX.
THAT NOBODY IS GOING TO READ AND
YOU ALSO HAVE ALL THE BUSINESS
IMPACTS WITH THE YEAR JUST NOW
HAD ALL THAT CHANGED OUT THE
FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
AND NOW THIS WOULD GO INTO
EFFECT NEXT YEAR -- IN JUNE AND
SO YOU'RE REALLY DISRUPTING THE
STREAM OF COMMERCE AND IT REALLY
DOESN'T PRODUCE A GOOD RESULTS
SO WE CERTAINLY WANT TO SUPPORT
WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO
AND WE'D CERTAINLY LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR.
AND MAY BE IN BED AND EXPAND
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OUT THERE WORKING WITH NATIONAL
SUICIDE GROUPS AND THE INDUSTRY
SELF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MR QUIRK.
YES -- I SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT THE OPPOSITION HAS.
BOB WE'VE ALL GONE THROUGH
SIGNING OFF ON A MORTGAGE I'VE
NEVER BOUGHT A GUN SO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT'S LIKE BUT I CAN
HELP YOU WITH THAT [inaudible]
NO.
THEY'RE TOO DANGEROUS TO HAVE IN
THE HOUSEHOLD THAT I THINK IS
VERY TRUE THERE WILL BE NO
SUICIDE IN MY HOUSE.
BECAUSE I WILL NOT BUY A GUN.
SO.
I FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THAT
I THINK HOUSES IF YOU HAVE A GUN
IN THE HOUSE IT'S MUCH MORE
LIKELY.
THAT A FAMILY MEMBERS GOING TO
GET KILLED THE NEW USE IT FOR
DEFENSE.
SO I'M SORRY YOU WILL NOT BE
HELPING ME.
ON THE OTHER HAND.
HAVING GONE THROUGH A MORTGAGE
AND YOU KNOW.
A HUNDRED DIFFERENT PAGES I'M
JUST A LITTLE CONCERNED --
THEY'RE ALREADY WARNINGS WHY ARE
THEY ADEQUATE NOW.
AND WITH THAT I'M I'M NOT SURE
IF IT WAS IN THE ANALYSIS WE
TOOK AN AMENDMENT THAT WAS
SUGGESTED BY THE AMERICAN
FOUNDATION.
FOR SUICIDE PREVENTION TO THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE ITEM TEN ON A
LIST THIS IS GOING TO BE A
SEPARATE SIGN.
THAT GIVES THE THE NAME OF THAT
GIVES A NUMBER FOR THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION HOTLINE.
AND AGAIN IN THE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE VETERAN THAT I SPOKE TO
AND ALL ALL THE ALSO GIVE THE
STUDENTS NICK THAT.
THAT FOR VETERANS 69% OF THE
VETERAN SUICIDES ARE WITH A
FIREARM.
OF THE VETERAN THAT I SPOKE TO
SAID RIGHT IN THAT MOMENT OF
NEED WHEN THEY THAT WAS ALL HE
WANTED WAS A NUMBER.
OF SOMEBODY THAT WOULD BE ABLE
TO COUNSEL THEM THROUGH THAT
CRISIS SO WE THINK THAT.
LOOKING AT THOSE THREE DIFFERENT
POINTS A SIGN OF A SIGN ON THE
WALL.
A THE SIGN WHEN YOU TAKE THE THE
GUN EXAM AND OF THE THE SIGN ON
THE GUN PACKAGING THAT THOSE
JUST IT JUST.
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR SOMEBODY THAT IS
CONTEMPLATING.
SUICIDE TO HAVE A NUMBER THAT
THEY CAN REACH OUT TO YOU MADE A
GOOD CASE SOME OF THE BILL.
THE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
WE ASK FOR RIVAL.
OUT CHAIRS RECOMMEND AYE.
ON AB SIX FORTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER AYE.
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE AYE POWER
QUE HAN.
DEEP I DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
HI.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK HI QUIRK
SANTIAGO.
WICKS HI WICKS HI.
MOST MOTION PASSES THANK YOU --
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
I WOULD LIKE TO ROOM REMIND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO TESTIFY.
WE HAVE. SEVEN EIGHT MORE BILLS
AND IT'S NOW ELEVEN OO -- SEVEN
SO.
BREVITY IS WILL BE REALLY
APPRECIATED.
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE TABLE.
AND WHO'S UP.
I HAVE.
JUST MAKE SURE SHE'S NOT HERE
ELOISE RACES NECKS [inaudible]
ALL KALRA.
HE VIEWED NOT A ONE SEVEN HI
NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO YOUR TIMING IS
IMPECCABLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT WAS
THE INTENT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU AB NINE
SEVENTEEN WHICH WILL UPDATE THE
TIME LINE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND CERTIFICATION
ENTITIES TO PROVIDE THE PROPER
DOCUMENTATION. TO THE VICTIM OF
A CRIME OR THE REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE PURPOSES OF OBTAINING U.
VISAS OR TV'S A CERTIFICATION.
A U. VISA IS GRANTED IT TO
VICTIMS OF A CRIME OR THEIR
LOVED ONES WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
AND HAVE FULLY COOPERATED WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO ASSIST
IN THE PROSECUTION IN THE
CRIMINAL CASE.
SIMILAR THE T. VISA ALLOWS
ELIGIBLE VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TO TEMPORARILY
REMAIN IN THE AND WORK IN THE US.
IN RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
ENACTED LEGISLATION TO ENSURE
YOU VISA AND TV'S APPLICANTS
HAVE RECEIVED CERTIFICATION FROM
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN A
TIMELY MANNER FOR THOSE.
IN REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS.
AND FOR THOSE IN REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS IN AN EXPEDITED
MANNER.
NONETHELESS MANY IMMIGRATION
PRACTITIONERS AND DEPORTATION
DEFENSE HAVE EXPRESSED THE NEED
TO CREATE A CERTIFICATION
PROCESS THAT IS PARALLEL TO THAT
OF THE CURRENT IMMIGRATION COURT
SYSTEMS TO FURTHER PROTECT
VICTIMS.
THIS BILL.
SIMPLY REQUIRES A CERTIFYING END
ENTITY TO PROCESS VICTIM
CERTIFICATION FOR PURPOSES OF
OBTAINING A YOU THESE ARE TO
VISA. TO DO IT WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS OF THE REQUEST RATHER THAN.
NINETY UNLESS THE NON CITIZEN IS
IN REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS IN WHICH
CASE THE CERTIFICATION MUST BE
PROCESSED.
IN SEVEN DAYS RATHER THAN THE
CURRENT FOURTEEN HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
R. CHRISTOPHER SONGES POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH SHEILA AND SEEN PF
LOTUS STAFF ATTORNEY WITH CHIP
Là I WANT YOU BOTH TO KNOW YOU
HAVE A BI PARTISAN MOTION TO
MOVE IN A SECOND.
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN.
GOOD MORNING THE CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA FLOORS AND I'M A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH CHEAP Là OUR
LEGAL DEPARTMENT PROVIDES
REPRESENTATION TO IMMIGRANTS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND NATURALIZATION PROCESS SEES.
FAMILY BASED ADJUSTMENTS VICTIMS
OF CRIME AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS
FACING IMMINENT DEPORTATION I'M
HERE TO URGE YOU TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF AB NICE SEVENTEEN FOR
TWO REASONS. TO ENSURE THE DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS OF IMMIGRANTS
INTO AND POWER COUNCIL TO
PROVIDE THE BEST DEFENSE
POSSIBLE AN IMMINENT DEPORTATION.
IT IS NO SURPRISE THAT POLITICS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL HAVE CHANGE
THE CLIMATE UNDER WHICH
IMMIGRATION PRACTICE
PRACTITIONERS.
PRACTICE LAW WE FELT THIS CHANGE
MOST IN IMMIGRATION COURT.
IMMIGRATION JUDGES ARE UNDER
PRESSURE TO CLOSE AS MANY CASES
IN A SHORT OF A TIME AS POSSIBLE
THAT MEANS THAT IMMIGRATION
JUDGES ARE LESS LIKELY TO
PROVIDEUS WITH CONTINUANCES TO
PRESENT OUR CASES.
THIS HAS HAD AN ADVERSE EFFECT
ON YOU BE SENT TV SET APPLICANTS
WHO ARE BENEFICIARIES OF
COLLATERAL RELIEF.
IN IMMIGRATION COURT IN SHORT
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE WE CAN NO
LONGER DEPEND ON THE LUXURY OF
TIME TO HELP.
DEVISE ITS BEST READY TO DEFEND
IMMIGRANTS FROM DEPORTATION THAT
IS WHY WE ARE ASKING FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE VICTIMS OF
CRIME AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHICH WITH ACCESS TO POLICE
REPORTS AND CERTIFICATION FOR
ALL THESE REASONS.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A.
B..
NINE SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
BECAUSE RESPONSES WHICH OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS PRADA SPONSOR THE BILL
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KRISTIN M. THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TENDS MASTIC
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY ANGER AN ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PETER WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
A DRY RIVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
HAD A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MORE MATURE MEMBERS COURSE ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
VICTIM CORPORATION IS VALUABLE
IF NOT VITAL IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS THAT'S A
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES THE
CERTIFYING ENTITY IN THE CASE
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT SHARE
OF SMOTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT THESE.
TO SIGN THESE CERTIFICATIONS AND
REQUIRES THAT THERE'S A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT A
VICTIM IS COOPERATING.
UNTIL THEY'RE NOT COOPERATING --
IF THE NOTION OF THE VISA IS
DEPENDENT ON COOPERATION WITH
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AN ENTITY THAT'S BEING ASKED TO
CERTIFY COOPERATION.
SHOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
MAKE THAT DECISION NOT THAT'S
ALREADY EXISTING LAW BUT THIS
BILL ADDS ADDITIONAL PEOPLE WHO
CAN REQUEST.
THIS NOTION OF SIGNING THE
CERTIFICATION WHICH IS AN
INFECTED DEMAND UNLESS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIAL CAN SHOW
THAT THE PERSON IS NOT
COOPERATING IF THE NOTION IS
THAT THE ENTITY IS GIVEN THAT.
AUTHORITY TO DECIDE AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
DECIDE.
THE BILL FURTHER TAKES THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS OUT OF
THE HANDS OF THE CERTIFYING
ENTITIES CREATES TIME AND
RESOURCE ISSUES.
BY SHORTENING THE TIME FRAMES
ALLOWED AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WITH US ROBS ISSUE THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OKAY CHAIRS RECOMMEND I MAY CALL
THE ROLL.
ON EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY I A BARRICADE HAN
[inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK ALL RIGHT QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS I WICKS I THE BILL PASSES
THANK YOU.
NOW WE'RE MOVING [inaudible]
MR COOLEY.
OKAY MITHRAS WE WERE TRYING TO
MOVE THROUGH THESE.
AB SIX TWO ZERO ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN YEAH READY IS APPRECIATED
CINDY MR RULES CHAIR.
SO PROCEED WITH ALACRITY.
SB SIX TWENTY DEALS WAS SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD.
IT'S ACTUALLY A BILL IS
PREVIOUSLY PASSES COMMITTEE WAS
VETOED BY THE MOVE ABOUT HER.
YEAH.
IT DEALS WITH A CLASS OF CHILD
DEATH WITH YOUR BETWEEN TWELVE
AND EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE.
IT IS RECOGNIZE UNDER FEDERAL
STATUTES.
AN EARLY IN MY CAREER ACTUALLY
DO THE GUY IN THIS BUILDING.
WHO WITH HIS WIFE LOFTS AN
INFANT?
AND AT THAT TIME OF SIDS WAS
UNKNOWN.
IT WAS SEVERAL RECOGNIZE UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW AND MUCH LATER
ACTUALLY RECOGNIZED BY THE CDC
[inaudible]
SO.
THE FACT IS AS TIME GOES ON WE
IDENTIFY A PHENOMENON THAT WE
CAN PUT A LABEL ON THIS IS
ALREADY HAS A LABEL ON IT.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL I HAVE --
SONYA WINCHELL WHO LOST HER SON.
TO BRIEFLY TESTIFY BUT SHE'S
BEEN A PART OF THIS CONVERSATION
FOR SEVERAL YEARS -- SOON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU COMMITTEE.
I'M GONNA READ BECAUSE I HAVE
BEEN REALLY NOT BE FAST.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT MY FIRST
BORN SON NICO WINCHELL AND
SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD OTHERWISE KNOWN AS S.
UTC.
SUNDAY OCTOBER TWENTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE JUST ANOTHER DAY FOR ANY CO.
A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD SOPHOMORE
REAL AMERICANA HIGH SCHOOL AND
DEVOTED JAZZ GUITARIST WITH THE
NATIONALLY ACCLAIMED HIGH SCHOOL
JAZZ BAND.
HE SPENT THE NIGHT BEFORE AT ONE
OF THE MANY ON GOING FALL BAND
FUNDRAISING PARTIES.
AND SUNDAY MORNING HE WAS TO
VOLUNTEER AT AT A CAR WASH.
NICO NEVER MADE IT BECAUSE
SOMETIME BETWEEN FOUR AND FIVE
AM HE DIED IN HIS SLEEP.
INSTEAD OF A JOYOUS DAY HELPING
THIS BAND COMMUNITY OUR HOME
BECAME A CRIME SCENE.
WITH FIRST RESPONDERS
INVESTIGATING AND QUESTIONING
OUR FAMILY.
THE CHAPLAIN TO RIDE WITHOUT ANY
HELPFUL ADVICE EXCEPT TO DRINK
WATER.
THE CORNER REMOVED HIS COLD
PURPLE TINGE BODY WHILE HIS
FATHER.
HIS TWELVE YEAR OLD BROTHER.
AND MYSELF SAT SHOCKED IN
NUMBING SILENCE.
WE WERE LEFT WITH NOIDEA AS TO
HOW TO HOW HAPPY HEALTHY SIX
FOOT TALL TEENAGER JUST DIED IN
HIS SLEEP EIGHT DAYS BEFORE HIS
SIXTEENTH BIRTHDAY.
THIS ONLY HAPPENS TO INFANTS WE
ARE TOLD.
WE HAVE NO FAMILY HISTORY OF
BREAST YOU DC OR HAD EVEN HEARD
OF IT WE WERE COMPLETELY UNAWARE
OF HOW TO PROCEED.
THANKFULLY A FRIEND WAS A
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST CALLED AND
INFORMED US ABOUT S. UTC.
HE TOLD US AT THE CORNER DOES
NOT HARVEST DNA RICH TO ISSUE
AND THAT WE NEED IT FOR FURTHER
INVESTIGATION.
NONE OF THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FORMATION CAME FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS.
CALIFORNIA MOST FAMILIES WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF ISSUE DC ARE LEFT
WITHOUT ANY ABILITY TO FURTHER
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THEIR
BELOVED CHILD'S DEATH.
THERE IS AN INCREDIBLY SHORT
TIME PERIOD TO COLLECT IMPORTANT
DATA FOR S. UT RESEARCH.
BECAUSE OUR FRIEND INTERVENES WE
CONTACTED THE CORNER IN TIME FOR
TISSUE AND ORGAN RETENTION AND
WE'RE WE WERE ABLE TO SUPPLY S.
UT RESEARCHERS AT BOSTON
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL FOR RESEARCH.
MOST FAMILIES BERRIER CREMATE
THIS INFORMATION WITH YOUR CHILD
AND ARE LEFT TO LIVE THEIR LIVES
NEVER KNOWING HOW OR WHY THEY'RE
HEALTHY CHILD DIED.
WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE SOME
CLUES AS TO WHAT KILLED OUR SON
THE INVESTIGATION CONTINUES
THROUGH THE RESEARCH TEAM?
NEW.
HOLD UP THE PICTURE AND SHARE A
SURELY GO WITH THEM -- AND IF
YOU CAN SEE FROM HERE THIS IS
NICK -- EIGHT DAYS BEFORE HE
PASSED HE WAS DOWNTOWN AT
SEVENTEENTH AND I ST A SECOND
SATURDAY WITH HIS JAZZ BAND
PERFORMING -- WITH THIS COMBO
THANKS SO THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER.
WE HAVE A MOTION MEMBERS COOPER
FOOD JUST VERY BRIEFLY GARY
COOPER TWO THINGS ONE I AM A
NEIGHBOR OF THE WIND CHILLS AND
WE WERE THERE THE DAY THAT MAKE
UP PASSED AWAY IT WAS A VERY
TRAGIC SITUATION AND THAT'S WHY
I'VE WORKED WITH -- MISTER
COOLEY.
AND SONYA THE LAST FEW YEARS TO
TRY TO GET THIS PASSED SECONDLY
HOW I'VE BEEN AUTHORIZED TO SAY
FROM CHRISTINE K. ONE WHO WORKS
FOR THE JANET GENETIC COUNSELOR
FOR THE ROBERTS PROJECT FOR S.
UTC THE BOSTON CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL IN SUPPORT SO I
STRONGLY RECOMMEND.
PASSAGE OF A. B..
SIX TWENTY THANK YOU.
BUT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
JUST GOT.
IS A TURN MEMBERS COURSE ALSO ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE CORNERS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL I'M VERY SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS MA'AM -- UNFORTUNATELY --
DEATHS OCCUR IN CHILDHOOD DEATHS
ALWAYS RECEIVE CAREFUL SCRUTINY --
AND ARE OFTEN THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY OF A CORNER'S OFFICE --
THE SHARES ARE CONCERNED HERE
BECAUSE FORTY NINE OF THE FIFTY
COUNTY SHERIFF'S ALSO SERVICE
THE ELECTED COUNTY CORNER -- ANY
TIME THE CAUSE OF DEATH IS NOT
READILY APPARENT A SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION IS UNDERTAKEN AND
THAT HAPPENS IRRESPECTIVE OF THE
AGE OF THE DECEDENT -- S. U. DC.
IS CLASSIFICATION OF S. U. D. C.
LACKS HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE
WHAT WITHOUT ANY DISRESPECT ANY --
DECEIVING OR FAMILY -- BUT THERE
THERE THERE HAS NOT BEEN
SCIENTIFIC VETTING -- IS --
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE TO THIS
NOTION OF A SYNDROME OF S. U. DC --
SIDS HAS GAINED IN TIME BUT
THERE WERE QUESTIONS SIMILAR TO
SIDS AND AGAIN THIS IS A MUCH
BROADER CATEGORY OF DEATHS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
CHILD WHO DIES BETWEEN THE AGES
OF ONE EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE --
CHILDHOOD DEATHS WHEN THE CAUSES
UNDETERMINED ARE NOT HOMOGENEOUS
IN NATURE -- WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT CREATING THIS NOTION.
THAT THAT ANY DEATH OF AN
UNDETERMINED CAUSE -- OF A CHILD
BETWEEN THE AGES OF ONE EIGHTEEN
GET INAPPROPRIATELY GROUP
TOGETHER AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTION FROM MISTER QUIRK YES
JUST IN RESPONSE TO THE
SHERIFF'S.
I'VE GOT THE BILL IN FRONT OF ME
IT'S VERY SIMPLE IT SIMPLY SAYS.
OUR SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD IT'S NOT CAPITALIZED
IT'S NOT TO ME INDICATING THE
SYNDROME.
IT'S JUST SAYING IF THERE'S A
SUDDEN DEATH BETWEEN ONE AND
EIGHT EIGHTEEN YEARS -- YOU'LL
TAKE A TISSUE SAMPLE WHICH COULD
BE USEFUL AS HE SAID FOR DNA SO
I I THINK THIS IS TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE.
HAS BEEN MOVED.
YEAH I HAVE AS YOU MOVE TO WORK
THANK YOU RIVERSIDE MOTION THANK
YOU I HEARD IT IT'S GREAT BILL I
TAKE IT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OKAY YOU MAY CLOSE I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I DO WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE NATIONAL
CORNERS ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS
THIS CLASSIFICATION.
AND ADVISED PEOPLE OF THE TISSUE
SAMPLE SO I THINK FROM A
NATIONAL PERSPECTIVE.
IT IS UNDERSTOOD.
IT'S NOT CLASSIFIED AS A
SYNDROME.
AND I THINK THE POINT WAS SIDS
IS SAID WAS IDENTIFIED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED LAWS TO DEAL
WITH THE TOPIC.
BEFORE CDC ACTUALLY RECOGNIZE IT --
SO I THINK.
IT'S A VERY APPROPRIATE
SPOTLIGHT AND YOU'RE ONLY
DEALING WITH THOSE SITUATIONS
WERE IS FRANKLY A SOURCE OF
CONSTERNATION. TO THE DEATH
PROFESSIONALS THEY CANNOT FATHOM
WHY THIS CHILD DIED.
AND I THINK ENACT FACT PATTERN
TO OFFER FAMILIES A PATH. TO FOR
UNDERSTANDING AND SAFEGUARDING.
IT IS JUST SENSIBLE QUESTIONABLE.
THANK YOU MINUTE AT MIDNIGHT
TONIGHT THANK YOU FOR COMING IN
AND SHARING YOUR STORY AND BRING
IN A PICTURE OF YOUR OF YOUR SON --
AND I KNOW THAT WITH.
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO
DO THAT OF YOU KNOW I I AND ONE
OF THE AGED THAT REMEMBERS --
WHEN THEY COULD EXPLAIN -- EIGHT
IN RESEARCH AND AND WERE NOW.
HAVING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT IT
BEING CURED WITHIN OUR LIFETIME.
AND WE'RE GETTING CLOSER CLOSER
BUT I THINK THAT'S BECAUSE WE'RE
TAKING TISSUE SAMPLE BECAUSE WE
DO MORE RESEARCH BECAUSE WERE.
WE DOING MORE TO FIND OUT HOW WE
GET THERE AND SO.
THAT'S WHY THE CHURCH RECOMMEND
I BOTH SO THAT WE CAN.
WE CANNOT FIGURE OUT DISMISSED
REUS SO THANK YOU FOR BRING THE
SPORT IS GROWING SEPARATION
[inaudible]
CALDERON.
ON EIGHTY SIX TWENTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE BAUER-KAHAN.
DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I THE
MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
BERMAN.
A. B..
FIVE THREE EIGHT ITEM NUMBER
FIVE THE MOTION IS A SECOND
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO MOVE MISS WICKS SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THE QUICK
MOTION AND SECOND -- WILL BE
VERY BRIEF I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL.
SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT SIXTY
IMPROVE THE AVAILABILITY
EFFICIENCY AND QUALITY OF
MEDICAL EVIDENCE YOUR
EXAMINATIONS. FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS AFTER AND DURING
SEXUAL ASSAULT TIMELY ACCESS TO
TRAUMA INFORMED IN EVIDENCE
BASED CARE CAN PREVENT ADVERSE
HEALTH OUTCOMES.
AND ALLOW FOR THE PROPER
COLLECTION OF EVIDENCE
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THEIR
VALUE TO SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
ACCESS TO MEDICAL OF AN ENTRY
EXAMINATIONS IS LIMITED
CURRENTLY THERE ARE FORTY NINE
SEXUAL ASSAULT FORENSIC
EXAMINATION TEAM SERVING ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
EXAMINERS IS CHALLENGING -- AB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ADDRESSES
THESE I GOT MORE DETAILS BUT
I'LL SAVE IT AND IN CASE THERE
QUESTIONS BUT WANT -- TO GIVE
THE EXPERTS A CHANCE. TO TO TO
SPEAK WITH ME TODAY ARE KIM
WALKER AND HILLARY LARKIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SEXUAL
ASSAULT FORENSIC EXAMINER'S
ASSOCIATION THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL.
IT IS BILL WAS ON CONSENT TO IT.
WE RECEIVED SOME INFORMATION AT
THE LAST MINUTE TO REASON.
APPRECIATE THAT MR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME TELLER LARK
AND I'M A PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT
AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE THIRTEEN
AND ALAMEDA COUNTY -- I I JUST
WANNA REMIND YOU WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OUR SIR TEAMS AND
BY DEFINITION THAT'S A MEDICAL
EXAMINER AN ADVOCATE AND A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
HELP US KEEP UP WITH TECHNOLOGY
AND IMPROVE THAT -- QUALITY OF
THE EXAM THAT WE CAN DELIVER AS
MEDICAL EXAMINERS.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT -- WE'VE
CREATED ELECT AN ELECTRONIC
REPORTING FORM TO KEEP UP WITH
THE ELECTRONIC REPORTING FORMS
THAT ARE.
ARE SORRY THE ELECTRONIC MEDICAL
RECORDS THAT ARE USED IN
HOSPITALS EVERY DAY.
SO IT ALLOWS US -- TO MOSTLY
INTEGRATE INTO THE ELECTRONIC
COMMENT ELECTRONIC MEDICAL
RECORD THE FORM ALSO IMPROVES
PRIVACY AND SECURITY OF THIS
VERY SENSITIVE DOCUMENT WELL
CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE THE EXAM TECHNIQUES
MONITOR QUALITY INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CREATE MORE
TRANSPARENCY ACROSS MULTIPLE.
DISCIPLINES.
ACCESS TO START EXAMS -- ACROSS
THE STATE IS AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE AND WE NEED TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN MORE QUALIFIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO PERFORM THE
EXAMS.
THE BILL -- EXPANDS THE SCOPE OF
THIS YOU SEE FM TO SEE TO NOT
ONLY TRAIN AND SEXUAL ASSAULT
BUT ALSO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
STRANGULATION AN ELDER ABUSE --
JUST FOR AN EXAMPLE SEXUAL
ASSAULT DOES NOT HAPPEN IN
ISOLATION SO 17% OF THE VICTIMS
THAT WE SEE IN OUR PROGRAM AT
HIGHLAND OR HAVE ALSO BEEN
STRANGLED SO HAVING CROSS
TRAINING AND STRANGULATION.
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
IN THE PAST LEGISLATIVE YEAR
THERE BEEN INITIATIVES PROPOSED
AND PASSED THE FOCUS RESOURCES
ON THE TESTING OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE KID AND DNA ANALYSIS WE
CANNOT FORGET THAT THOSE KIDS
ARE BEING COLLECTED BY THE
MEDICAL EXAMINERS.
WHO ARE SEEN IN TREATING SEXUAL
ASSAULT VICTIMS AND THEIR QUEUE
CRISIS THE SOONER THE VICTIMS
CAN ACCESS TRAINED FORENSIC
EXAMINERS?
THE BETTER TRAINED EXPERIENCE IN
SUPPORT OF THOSE EXAMINERS ARE
THE BETTER THE QUALITY OF
EVIDENCE.
SO IF WE ARE GOING TO GET THE
BEST RETURN ON INVESTMENT WE
NEED TO SUPPORT BOTH THE MEDICAL
EXAMINER'S THAT COLLECT THAT
EVIDENCE AND THE CRIMINALIST WHO
ANALYZE IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS KEN
WALKER AND THE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR FOR THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT FORENSIC EXAM TEAM IN
CIVIC THAT SERVE SANTA CLARA SAN
BENITO AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTIES.
I'M ALSO IN THE LEADERSHIP BOARD
OF CAL SAFE REPRESENTING THE
FORTY NINE EXAM TEAMS.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY I'M A
PRACTICING FORENSIC NURSE
EXAMINER PROVIDING MEDICAL AND
FRIENDS A CARE TO SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SUCH AS UP FORENSIC EXAMINER'S
PRIMARILY PERFORM A STANDARD
MEDICAL FORENSIC EXAM FOR
PATIENTS TO PRESENT AFTER
REPORTING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS INCLUDES PROVISION OF
PATIENT RIGHTS MEDICAL CARE AND
TREATMENT EVIDENCE COLLECTION
AND SUPPORT.
UNDER THE VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN
ACT SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
HAVE THE RIGHT TO THE SAME
MEDICAL FORENSIC EXAM.
EVEN IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
PURSUE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THIS EXAM ALLOWS THE PATIENT
CRITICAL TIME TO PROCESS THE
AFTER EFFECTS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
BUT PRESERVES PERISHABLE
EVIDENCE THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
LOST.
EXAMS DONE UNDER BORROWER
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
ABBREVIATED EXAMS.
INITIALLY IT WAS BELIEVED THAT
THESE EXAMS WILL TAKE LESS TIME
AND COST LESS TO COMPLETE.
AFTER FOUR YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
IN THE FIELD IS BECOME APPARENT
THAT NOTHING ABOUT THE EXAM IS
ABBREVIATED.
AND THERE'S NO REDUCTION IN THE
COST OF PROVIDING THEM.
EXAM TEAMS OF ESSENTIALLY
ELIMINATED THE ABBREVIATED
EXAMINE PROVIDED A STANDARD EXAM
IS BEST PRACTICE.
SINCE THE EXAM IS THE EXAM THERE
SHOULD BE ONE RATE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT.
AND THAT SHOULD BE BASED ON
LOCALLY NEGOTIATED RATE FOR ALL
EXAMS.
THERE SHOULD BE NO NEGOTIATE NO
NEGOTIATION OF THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE BASED ON THE PATIENT'S
DECISION TO ENGAGE OR PORT TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ENTRANCE EXAM TEAMS IN
CALIFORNIA CANNOT SUSTAIN
PROVIDING FULLY RESOURCE
STANDARD EXAMS AT A LOWER RATE.
IT WOULD JEOPARDIZE AVAILABILITY
OF THE QUALIFIED HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS REDUCE PATIENT ACCESS
TO EXAMS.
AMONG ITS MANY GOALS AB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT SIX TO CLARIFY THE
LANGUAGE ON OFFSETTING THE COST
OF EXAMS TO FIND BY BALA.
WHICH IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
VIABILITY OF EXAM TEAMS IN
CALIFORNIA WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STRIVE
HARD AND I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
FORENSIC NURSES SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER.
ON THE INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF FRIENDS A NURSE YOUR NAME IN
ORGANIZATIONS ALL RIGHT THANKS
THANK YOU.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE SHORES
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BE HERE TODAY MY NAME IS JOHN
FINLEY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AS THE STATE COALITION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FOUR RAPE
CRISIS CENTER PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ON THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT OPPOSES SB THIRTY
AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT IN ITS
CURRENT FORM -- WE'RE TAKING A
RESPECTFUL OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDMENT POSITION IF ENACTED
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ULTIMATELY
HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON LOCAL
SEXUAL SOLD SERVICES PROGRAMS
RAPE CRISIS CENTERS AND THE
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
THAT THE SERVER.
CAL COSTS IS STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THE PROVISION OF AB FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT THAT ELIMINATES IN STATUTE
THE EXISTING THREE HUNDRED
DOLLAR REIMBURSEMENT CAP FOR AN
ABBREVIATED ADULT ADOLESCENT
SEXUAL ASSAULT AN EXAMINATION.
FOR MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
HOSPITALS THAT PROVIDE THOSE
EXAMS AND INSTEAD ALLOWS IT TO
BE SET BY THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
CALL CASA OPPOSES USING VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ACT SERVICES
TRAINING OFFICERS PROSECUTORS
KNOWN AS STOP GRANTS TO FUND ANY
INCREASED REIMBURSEMENT FOR
FORENSIC EXAMINATIONS WHICH
REMOVING THIS CAP AND STATUTE
WOULD ULTIMATELY ALLOW.
FOR IF THE REIMBURSEMENT CAP IS
REMOVED AND THE FUNDING FOR
REIMBURSING THESE EXAMS
CONTINUES TO COME FROM ABOUT WAS
STOP GRANTS THE RAPE CRISIS
CENTER PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WOULD STAND
TO LOSE VITAL FUNDING RESOURCES.
TELL COSTS AND OTHER ENTITIES
OPPOSE SIMILAR LEGISLATION IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT
SOUGHT TO RAISE THE
REIMBURSEMENT ABOUT AND OUR
POSITION ON THIS MATTER IS NOT
CHANGED.
THE BILL ANALYSIS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AT THAT TIME
PROVIDED A SIMILAR POINT OF VIEW
STATING CURRENTLY VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ACT FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE FULLY COMMITTED AND IF THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS EVER
INCREASED.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
WILL BE REIMBURSED AT THE
EXPENSE OF ANOTHER PROGRAM.
SOME AGENCIES CURRENTLY DO NOT
PURSUE THE OCCASIONAL THREE
HUNDRED DOLLAR REIMBURSEMENT
BECAUSE IT IS NOT COST EFFECTIVE
BUT THEY WOULD PURSUE A HIGHER
LEVEL OF REIMBURSEMENT.
CAL CASA BELIEVES THAT
ELIMINATING THE STATUTORY CAP ON
REIMBURSEMENTS EFFECTIVELY SERVE
THE SAME PURPOSE AS RAISING IT
AND AS A STRATEGY TO CALL CASA
POSES TO SOLVING THIS PROBLEM.
INSTEAD OF USING VAL WAS STOP
GRANTS AS REIMBURSEMENT DOLLARS
FOR THE ABBREVIATED SEXUAL
ASSAULT EXAMS THE REIMBURSEMENT
FUNDING SHOULD COME FROM THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD.
VICTIMS COMPENSATION CURRENTLY
REIMBURSES THE COSTA FORENSIC
EXAMS IN FORTY SIX OTHER STATES.
CALVI CB ALSO REIMBURSES CERTAIN
MEDICAL EXPENSES FOR VICTIMS OF
CRIME AND CAL CASA BELIEVES THE
CAL B. C. B. PROVIDES THE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING STREAM TO
REIMBURSE ABBREVIATED SEXUAL
ASSAULT EXAMS WHICH ARE BY
DEFINITION CRIME RELATED
EXPENSES.
WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR THAT A SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL
ABUSE SHOULD NEVER BE BILLED FOR
A FORENSIC RAPE EXAM AND
SIMILARLY A SURVIVOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO COMPLY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD NOT HAVE ANY
INFLUENCE OR WHETHER IF WHETHER
OR NOT A FORENSIC RAPE EXAM.
IS REIMBURSABLE ALL SURVIVORS
ARE ENTITLED BY LAW TO A
FORENSIC RAPE EXAM REGARDLESS OF
THE COMPLIANCE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHETHER DESIRE TO
REPORT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA RAPE CRISIS CENTERS
PROVIDED SERVICES 435-000-60070
EIGHT SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT WITH NUMBERS CONTINUING
TO INCREASE DUE TO EXPANDED
AWARENESS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
WE STAND UNITED WITH A MEMBER
PROGRAMS IN URGING THAT THIS
BILL BE REMAIN A BE AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE PROVISION THAT
ELIMINATES THE REIMBURSEMENT CAP
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO COMMIT
OURSELVES TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR.
THE LEGISLATURE SPONSORS AND ANY
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND A
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM THAT
DOES NOT TAKE AWAY FROM CRITICAL
FUNDING RESOURCES FOR RAPE
CRISIS CENTERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
YES GOOD MORNING I'M HERE TILL
MALLEY ON THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN.
ISSUES AROUND SEXUAL SALT FOR A
GOOD PART OF TWENTY YEARS.
INCLUDING THE LOCK -- SPONSORING
THE LAW THAT CREATED THE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLAR FUNDING IS A STOP
GAP MEASURE. FOR BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE EXAMS FIRST SURVIVORS
WHO DID NOT WANT TO ENGAGE WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THEREFORE LAW ENFORCEMENT
WOULD WERE NOT WAS NOT ON THE
HOOK TO PAY FOR THE EXAM.
I AGREE WITH CAL CLASSES
POSITION AND I WANT TO SAY THAT
I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR MY
COLLEAGUES I WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH MS LARKIN.
AT HALF THROUGH HIGHLAND
HOSPITAL WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
START ISSUE SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE AND HOW IT
HIGHLIGHTS HOSPITALS ONE OF THE
FIRST START CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO I SUPPORT THE THE A FACT THAT
FORENSIC EXAMS SHOULD BE FUNDED
AND PAID FOR NOT BY THE VICTIM
EVER.
BUT BY OF VICTIMS OF CRIME
FUNDING.
THE FIRST PART OF A FRIEND'S
EXAMS A MEDICAL EXAM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE VICTIM SURVIVOR IS
HEALTHY AND THAT THEIR DAUGHTER
ANY HEALTH ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED.
PART OF THE EXAM ALSO INCLUDES
STINGS LIKE STD SCREENING AND
MORNING AFTER PILLS ANOTHER
PROPHYLAXIS X. TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE HEALTHY FIRST.
AND THE SECOND PART OF THAT EXAM
IS A FORENSIC EXAM TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY FORENSIC EVIDENCE.
AND SO FOR THAT PURPOSE BECAUSE
THE PRIMARY EXAM.
IS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE SURVIVOR IS HEALTHY.
AND THAT -- AND THERE IT'S A
MEDICAL EXAM THAT IT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR VICTIMS OF CRIME
TO FUND THAT.
VICTIMS OF CRIME PAY FOR
PEOPLE'S MENTAL EXAMS.
IN OTHER TYPES OF CRIMES VICTIMS
OF CRIME FUNDING PAYS FOR
RELOCATION AND MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING FOR OTHER VICTIMS OF
CRIME AND THERE'S NO REASON WHY
VICTIMS OF CRIME SHOULD NOT ALSO
BE PAYING FOR THE MEDICAL
FORENSIC EXAMS.
THAT THE EXPERTS SUCH AS THE TWO
SPEAKERS HERE A PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL ARE ENGAGING IN.
SO FOR THAT REASON I VERY VERY
REGRETFULLY OPPOSE IT AND URGE
THAT WE USE WE CHANGE OUR AMEND
TO MAKE THE FUNDING COME FROM
VICTIMS OF CRIME FUNDING.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH THE COURT.
YEAH ON THE VICTIMS OF CRIME
FUNDING IS ALSO I THINK --
OVERSUBSCRIBED.
WELL AT THE END AS WE GET TO THE
END OF THE FISCAL YEAR THE END
OF THE FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR
BECAUSE IT'S FEDERAL DOLLARS.
THAT -- THE VICTIMS OF CRIME
FUNDING IS XCELERATED THAT ARE
UP MY OFFICE REPRESENTS VICTIMS
WE GENERATE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES FOR VICTIMS OF
CRIME.
UP BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT THE
WAY THE FORMULA STRUCTURED FOR
NEXT YEAR'S FUNDING IN THE
FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR IS HOW MUCH
WAS SPENT IN THIS YEAR.
AND THEN THEY IDENTIFY AN
ESTIMATE AN INCREASE AND IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS RAISE THE CAP.
OF THE VICTIMS OF CRIME FUNDING
THAT'S AVAILABLE AND THAT HAS
MADE MORE MORE MONEY AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS CHAIR I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION TODAY I THINK WE
ALL AGREE THAT THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL -- IS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT MEDICAL EVIDENCE
YOUR EXAMINATIONS -- I FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED I DO HOPE THAT THE
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL WILL GIVE
MY OFFICE THE COURTESY OF MORE
THAN TWENTY FOUR HOURS HEADS UP.
BEFORE YOU DROP A BILL -- BEFORE
YOU DROP A LETTER THE ON A BILL
THAT YOU SHARE YOUR OPPOSED --
FOR THREE CHAIR WHAT'S THAT.
IT'S A NORMAL PROTOCOL THAT YOU
TALK TO THE CHAIR OF COURSE SEES
ME WAS A CHAIR I DO HOPE THAT
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL WILL
GIVE MY OFFICE THE COURTESY.
OF MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
HEADS UP.
WHEN IT APPARENTLY THIS IS
SOMETHING THEY KNEW THAT THEY
WERE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
WHOLE TIME WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS -- AS
WE MOVE FROM THE POLICY
COMMITTEE WHERE I THINK WE ALL
AGREE ON THE POLICY GOAL IN THE
POLICY NEEDS. TO THE IT TO
HOPEFULLY TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WHERE WE CAN HAVE
DIFFERENT CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
FINDING -- DIFFERENT MODELS FOR
HOW WE FIND THIS CRITICALLY
NEEDED SERVICE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU --
THE CHURCH RECOMMEND I END.
AND I WOULD ASK.
THE OPPONENT. TO TALK WITH --
THE BUDGET CHAIR OF SO FIVE
MAYBE EVEN THE BUDGET CHAIRS OF
BOTH SIDES ON BECAUSE IS A
SERIOUS CONCERN.
THAT THE VICTIMS ASSISTANCE FUND
WILL GO AN INSULT.
SO NO MATTER WHAT.
CALCULATIONS YOU GO ZERO STILL
EQUALS.
ZERO AND SO I THINK PART OF THIS
IS WE DO NEED TO HAVE A ROBUST
COP CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO FUND ITS.
NOT ABOUT WHERE IT SHOULD COME
OUT OF BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S
GETTING CLOSE.
TO ZERO M. AT SOME POINT.
BOB FROM A LEGISLATIVE
STANDPOINT IT WILL BE COMING OUT
A GENERAL FUND DIRECTLY INTO --
WITH DISNEY TO FIGURE IT OUT
WHEN YOU FIGURE OUT FAST IT IS
BECOMING INSOLVENT.
AND SO I I I SHARE -- THE SAME
CONCERN AS STATE IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THAT -- WE NEED A LOT
MORE TIME SO WE COULD ACTUALLY
TRY TO WORK THIS OUT NOW IS IT
IS I'M HOPING THAT HE GETS OUT
IS COMMITTEE -- I WILL TELL YOU
NOW THE THE AUTHOR WILL WORK
WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT. ONE
WE HAVE BEEN GOING FUNDING. FOR
THIS -- AND IN TWO WEEKS WE CAN
DEBATE ALL DAY LONG ABOUT HOW IS
DISPERSED AND THAT DOESN'T OTHER
THING BUT IF THERE'S NO MONEY.
IS NO DISCUSSION SO -- CALL THE
ROLL.
ON AB FIVE THREE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN I'VE
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE HI
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS HI WICKS I THE
MEASURE PASSES.
I'M I'M SO SORRY MR GIPSON MR
HOLDEN SHOWED UP -- ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN AB EIGHT THREE SEVEN
HOLDEN OF BREVITY IS APPRECIATED
AND I HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
THROUGH THIS.
OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN I WILL MOVE
[inaudible]
BRISKLY.
I APPRECIATE -- YOU AND THE
MEMBERS HEARING THIS
PRESENTATIONS THIS MORNING ON
ABA.
THIRTY SEVEN AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEES ASSISTANCE AND
WORKING THROUGH THIS BILL IT'S
BEEN GREATLY.
APPRECIATED.
A WE LIVE IN A DAY WHERE PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FEEL IN BOLD
AND TO ACT UPON THEIR BIASES.
ALTHOUGH OUR STATE HAS TAKEN
GREAT PRIDE IN BEING A HOME TO
ALL REGARDLESS OF THEIR IDENTITY.
THEIR FAITH THE ABILITY OR RACE
WE ARE NOT EXEMPT TO PREJUDICE
FIELD ACTIONS AND WORDS.
THE STATE AUDITOR REPORT
REVEALED THAT THREE OUT OF FOUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
REVIEWED FAILED TO PROPERLY
IDENTIFY HATE CRIMES.
WITHIN THESE FOUR AGENCIES THE
STATE AUDITOR ALSO FOUND THAT
NINETY SEVEN HATE CRIMES ROUGHLY
14% OF ALL HATE CRIMES IN THE
AGENCIES A DENTED DIGNIFIED.
WERE NOT REPORTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT ONE OF THE AGENCIES
REVIEWED COMMITTED THE VAST
MAJORITY OF ERRORS.
CURRENTLY STATE LAW DOES
REFRESHER TRAINING OUTSIDE OF
THE OFFICER TRAINING ACADEMY.
THE SAME REPORT REVEALED THAT
FEW LOCAL AGENCIES PROVIDE A
REFRESHER TRAINING TO POLICE
OFFICERS EVEN WHEN EVEN THEN THE
TRAINING IT WAS OFFERED TO A
MINORITY OF EMPLOYED OFFICERS.
AB EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN ADDRESSES
THIS PERVASIVE ISSUE BY
REQUIRING THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES REQUIRE.
PEACE OFFICERS TO COMPLETE
REFRESHER TRAINING USING THE
MOST RECENT TRAINING MATERIAL
DEVELOP BY THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING POST.
REQUIRED POST ESTABLISH
STANDARDS FOR THE FREQUENCY OF
THAT PERIODIC TRAINING ALONG LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND TO MAKE THEIR
HATE CRIME TRAINING CULTURALLY
RELEVANT TO THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE.
POSTS ALREADY HAS TRAINING
MATERIALS AVAILABLE TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES OF OFFICERS
FREE OF CHARGE.
AB EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN DOES NOT
REQUIRE OPPOSED TO CREATE A NEW
TRAINING THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
CURRENT RESOURCES A BEST UTILIZE
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY MARISSA
GONZALEZ FROM THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS TO
DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
LEGISLATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EUROPE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MY NAME IS MARISSA GONZALEZ AND
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ANY S.
W..
AS SOCIAL WORKERS OUR PRIMARY
GOAL IS TO HELP PEOPLE IN NEED
AND TO ADDRESS SOCIAL PROBLEMS
WITH SPECIFIC ATTENTION TO THE
NEEDS AND EMPOWERMENT OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE VULNERABLE.
OPPRESSED AND LIVING IN POVERTY.
IN A REPORT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IT HAS BEEN FOUND THAT HATE
CRIME EVENTS HAVE INCREASED
SEVENTEEN POINT 4% IN THE PAST
YEAR.
FROM NINE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
INCIDENTS IN 201-621-00090 THREE
IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT FOLLOWS
DOUBLE DIGIT INCREASES IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY SIXTEEN AFTER
SIX YEARS OF STEADY DECLINE.
THE NUMBER OF HATE CRIME
INCIDENTS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
INCREASE IN EVERY MAJOR CATEGORY.
RACE RELIGION AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN GAME AND
WERE MOST LIKELY TO FALL VICTIM
TO HATE CRIMES.
AFRICA LE LATINOS WERE
INCREASINGLY THE SUBJECTS OF
HATE CRIMES WITH A FIFTY ONE
POINT 8% INCREASE FROM.
TWENTY SIXTEEN IT IS OUR JOB TO
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR EQUALITY
IN HUMANE TREATMENT.
OF ALL OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR RACE
RELIGION SEXUALITY OR GENDER.
THE HISTORY OF SYSTEMIC RACISM
IN OUR COUNTRY HAS HAD
WIDESPREAD THIS FAX AND THE
RESULTING GROWTH OF HATE CRIMES
IS A TERRIFYING TRUTH.
THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED LIVING IN
FEAR BECAUSE OF THE POLITICAL
RHETORIC REGARDING YOUR COUNTRY
OF ORIGIN RELIGION OR SEXUALITY.
IS NOT WILL CALIFORNIA STANDS.
FOR WE FIRMLY STAND BEHIND THIS
BILL AND KINDLY ASK THAT YOU DO
THE SAME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH WITNESS.
CHRIS RESPONSIBLE CHIRLA THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ARE PROUD TO BE A SCHOOL
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL LAST YEAR
ARE SINCE THE PRINT TRUMP --
PRESIDENCY -- IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES HAVE EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT HEY INCIDENCES AND
HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF HATE CRIMES --
IT IS ECHOED ON FROM MY
COLLEAGUES I HATE INCIDENT
CRIMES HAVE INCREASED LOS
SIGNIFICANTLY SPECIFICALLY FOR
LATINOS AND ALSO FOR THOSE THAT
ARE.
EXPRESSED IN THE RELIGION ARE
FOR THE BIT BASED ON RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS ARE THEREFORE WE ASK
THAT THERE IS TRAINING
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMITTEES ARE BEST SERVED.
AS IT COMES ARE CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE TO THIS DAY WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THROUGH THE ANDERSON WITH THE
ARE CAN YOU SEE P. CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE INSTALLED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
CHURCH RECOMMEND I CALL THE ROLL.
AB EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
CHEN SIR HI LACKEY.
BAUER-KAHAN HI BAUER-KAHAN I
DEEP.
ARE VOTING.
DEEP NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS HI WICKS I
THAT MEASURE PASSES GRADUATION
[inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] TWENTY
GIPSON.
AB NINE OH ONE GET SEN
[inaudible]
JUVENILES TRUANCY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE ZERO ONE WHICH SEEKS TO
ORANGE ENCOURAGE.
APPROPRIATE INTERVENTION FOR
YOUTH WHO ARE AT RISK OPPOSED --
TO BEING FURTHER CRIMINALIZE.
AND INVOLUNTARY PROBATION
CURRENT LAW GIVES PROBATION
DEPARTMENT THE BROAD AUTHORITY.
TO SUPERVISE AND MIX CASES
INCLUDING AT RISK YOU AS WELL AS
YOU -- WITH MORE FORMAL
PROBATION STATUS THE PROBLEM IS
THAT 80% OF THE U. OR AN
VOLUNTARY PROBATION WERE PLACED
UNDER SUPERVISION BECAUSE OF
POOR ATTENDANCE.
GRADES BEHAVIOR OR OVERALL
PERFORMANCE AT SCHOOL.
THESE YOU ARE SUBJECT TO
VOLUNTEER PROBATION ARE
ESSENTIALLY CRIMINALIZED WITHOUT
HAVING.
EVEN GONE BEFORE A COURT HEARING.
THESE YOUTH -- WHO ARE REQUIRED
TO CHECK IN WITH A PROBATION
OFFICER?
SUBJECT TO RANDOM SEARCH CURFEW.
SURPRISE HOME VISITS AS WELL AS
THE INTERROGATION.
DESPITE THE PROGRAM'S BEING
LABELED VOLUNTARY PARENTS AND
YOU OFTEN FEEL PRESSURED WITH IN
THE PROGRAM AND DO NOT HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF SPEAKING TO AN
ATTORNEY.
MORE OVER.
BLACKS AND LATINOS CHILDREN ARE
CONSISTENTLY OVER IDENTIFIED AS
AT RISK.
OF DELINQUENCIES AND REFERRED --
INFORMAL SUPERVISION A FACT FOUR
POINT 3% OF THEM WERE REFERRED
OF FOR GENERAL LACK OF
MOTIVATION.
AND ONLY TWO POINT 7% WERE
REFERRED AS SUSPECT OF A
SUSPICION OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE ONE
POINT 5%.
OF FOR ANGER ISSUES AND ONE
POINT 5% FOR PARENTAL CONFLICT.
AB NINE A ONE WOULD ENSURE THAT
YOUTH RECEIVING APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTION AND ARE NOT
CRIMINALIZE FOR ACADEMIC REASONS.
FOR TECHNICALLY -- FOR TO FOR
FOR CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS
BEHAVIOR -- BY LIMITING
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS OVER BROAD
DISCRETION AS WELL AS ENSURING
THE TRUANCY OR DISOBEYING A
TEACHER ALONE IS NOT THE REASON
FOR A CHILD TO BE SUBJECTED TO
THE JUVENILE SYSTEM.
EVERY YOU DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO START TO FOR A
BRIDE AS OF GROWING UP -- TO
ADULTHOOD MY BILL INTENDS TO
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD FOR YOU
ENDING UP IN JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEMS THEREFORE REDUCING THE
LIKELIHOOD.
OF THAT THEY WILL BE -- PLACE IN
A JUVENILE FACILITY WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY FOR
A. B. -- NINE OH ONE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FROM A CO
YOU AND ALSO -- FROM THE JUSTICE
FROM THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION
WHO IS SELF INTRODUCED AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I BOTH
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
WHERE WHERE YOU GIVE IT UP GOOD
PLACE THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE?
MY NAME IS ANGELA MCNAIR TURNER
AND I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY AT
PUBLIC COUNCIL ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF AB NINE A ONE PUBLIC
COUNCIL IS THE LARGEST PROBLEM A
LAW FIRM IN THE COUNTRY.
WE PROVIDE REPRESENTATION
SUPPORT ADVOCACY TO THOUSANDS OF
HONORABLE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
I WORK AT PUBLIC COUNCIL FOCUSES
ON EDUCATION EQUITY AND ADVOCACY.
I'M SPEAKING TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINE A ONE WHICH
SEEKS TO INCREASE DIVERSION OF
YOUNG PEOPLE AWAY FROM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
TOWARDS COMMUNITY BASED
INTERVENTIONS.
THIS LEGISLATION IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP TO ENDING THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW PROBATION HAS
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE SERVICES.
TO ANY MINOR IN THE STATE THAT
STATE ASIDE IS AT RISK OF SUNDAY
COMMITTING DELINQUENT BEHAVIOR.
LED TO YOU THING REFER TO
PROBATION FOR MINOR MISBEHAVIOR.
FOR ACADEMIC ATTENDANT ISSUES.
THIS RUNS COUNTER TO NUMEROUS
STUDIES THAT DEMONSTRATE THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT CONTACT WITH USE.
WHO ARE LOW RISK SHOULD BE
MINIMIZED BECAUSE IT IS AN
EFFECTIVE AND INCREASES OUR RISK
FOR COURT INVOLVEMENT IN FUTURE
INCARCERATION?
ADDITIONALLY.
THIS BROAD SUBJECTIVE
DISCUSSIONS LENDS ITSELF TO
IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT BIAS.
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IDENTIFIED AS
AT RISK MY PROBATION. FOR
EXAMPLE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BLACK AND
LATINO STUDENTS WERE OVER 80% OF
THE USE LABELED AT RISK IN
SCHOOL BASS PROBATION
SUPERVISION.
DESPITE BEING ONLY APPROXIMATELY
ABOUT 63% OF THE LA POPULATION.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IMPACT OF
PROBATION PROGRAMS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN COURT ORDERED
SERVICES.
AND WE SUPPORT PROVIDER VERSION.
EIGHTY NINE NO ONE GIVES
CALIFORNIA CHANCE TO LIAM
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO VOTE I
OBISPO.
THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS MORE ABOUT SOMEONE
ELSE I'M A MEMBER OF THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION.
WE'RE HONORED TO BE SPONSORED OF
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE A ONE I WAS
BORN IN LOS ANGELES.
DIRECTLY FROM THE HOSPITAL YOU
MOVE MY MOM.
AND PUT INTO QUE GOT PLASTIC --
INTO CUSTODY OF MY GRANDMOTHER I
GREW UP IN THE I GREW UP WITH MY
GRANDMOTHER TO THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN THAT YEAR MY UNCLE MOVED
INTO MY GRANDMOTHER'S HOUSE.
HE SUFFERS FROM ADDICTION
ISRAELI I WASN'T SAFE AT HOME.
IN MY JUNIOR YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL
I WAS REMOVED MY FAMILY IMPRINT
TO FOSTER HOMES.
AS A TEENAGER AND FOSTER HOPE.
AS A TEENAGER FOSTER CARE I WAS
TRYING TO STAY CLOSE TO MY
SIBLINGS.
I WAS MOVED CONSTANTLY.
BUT IN A DIFFERENT HIGH SCHOOLS
I TO THE DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS IN ONE YEAR.
DESPITE ALL THE MOVES I WAS A
GOOD STUDENT BOTH MY INTENT.
BOTH MY ATTENDANCE.
BOTH MY ATTENDANCE EMIGRATE TO
HIRE.
I RANCHO HIGH I RANCHO HIGH
SCHOOL IN PICO RIVERA.
I WAS CALLED INTO WHAT I THOUGHT
WAS THE COUNTRY'S OFFICE.
THE STAFF MEMBERS SAID I HAD TO
CHECK IN WITH THEM A FEW TIMES A
WEEK.
BECAUSE I HAVE SWITCHED SCHOOLS
TOO OFTEN.
THE FOLLOWING WEEK OTHER
STUDENTS TOLD ME THAT HE WAS A
PROBATION OFFICER.
HE CLAIMED HE CLAIMED THAT IT
WAS HIS JOB TO CHECK TO CHECK ON
ME HE DAN OFFER ANY RESOURCES HE
NEVER TOLD ME HE WAS A PROBATION
OFFICER HE NEVER SHOWED ANY
APPLICATION WHERE INFORMATION
WITH ME OR MY FOSTER FROM THE AT
THE TIME.
NONE OF US EVER GAVE PERMISSION
FOR MY PARTICIPATION. ONE THING
I WAS TALKING TO A PROBATIONER
ONCE I KNEW I WAS TALKING TO A
PROBATION OFFICER.
I FELT UNCOMFORTABLE.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH ME WHY WHY WAS
I FORCED REPORT TO A PROBATION
OFFICER WHEN MY GRADES WERE GOOD
AND I NEVER HAVE.
I'VE NEVER BEEN ARRESTED OR IN
TROUBLE IN MY LIFE.
I NEVER GOT A RESPONSE.
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM BOTH
CHILDREN AND PARENTS ARE
LEGITIMATE FEARS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE ARE WORRIED THAT
ANYTHING.
WE SAY COULD REPLACE A PART OF
MY FAMILY. FOR SIXTEEN YEARS I
HAVE LEARNED TO LIVE IN THE
SHADOWS.
BECAUSE OF THIS EXPERIENCE
.
BECAUSE OF THIS EXPERIENCE I
DECIDED TO LEAVE HIGH SCHOOL
AFTER TWO MONTHS [inaudible]
I WAS.
I WOULD OUT OF SCHOOL FOR SIX
YEARS.
I WENT BACK TO I WENT BACK TO MY
GRANDMOTHER'S HOUSE AFTER YEARS
LATER AND ROLLED IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND ENROLLED.
IN HIGH SCHOOL -- VIEWS JUSTICE
COALITION ONE OF THE THINGS I
HELP ORGANIZE WITHIN AND TO MORE
INTERPRETATION AND LA COUNTY
WHEN WE ENDED IT IN THE SPRING
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE.
THERE WERE OVER TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND YOU I'M GOING TO A
PROBATION.
I AM NOT IN IN COLLEGE AND I
STARTED TO BE A SOCIAL WORK.
SO SHORT [inaudible]
SOCIAL WORKER.
YOU HAVE ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATHY
SURER OF FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR -- THE WE'VE SEEN THE
ISSUES ADDRESSED IN AB -- NINE
OH ONE THROUGH OR WORK IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY -- WHERE
BETWEEN 200-015-2000 FIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT PUT OVER THREE
THOUSAND CHILDREN ON PROBATION
CONTRACTS FOR NORMAL YOUTHFUL
BEHAVIOR NOT CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR --
BASED ON THE BROADER THIRTY
BASED -- GRANTED UNDER WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION -- SIX
FIFTY FOUR YOUTH WERE PLACED ON
PROBATION -- FOR REASONS THAT
WERE CITED AS INCORRIGIBLE EDDIE
OR DEFIANCE AND DESTRUCTIVE
BEHAVIOR CITING TO SECTION SIX
OH ONE IN ONE CASES STUDENT WAS
PLACED ON PROBATION FOR BEHAVIOR
RELATED TO GRIEF FROM THE DEATH
OF A BABY SISTER -- THE YOUTH
AND THEIR PARENTS ARE OFTEN TOLD
IF THEY DON'T AGREE TO PROBATION
THEIR CASES WILL BE REFERRED TO
THE D. A. EVEN WHEN THERE ARE NO
CHARGES THAT.
COULD BE FILED ON THEY AGREED TO
TERMS THAT INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
SEARCHES OF THEIR PERSONS AND
HOMES AS WELL AS RANDOM DRUG
TESTING OFTEN WORSE CONSEQUENCES
THAN THEY WOULD GET IF THEY WERE
BROUGHT TO JUVENILE COURT --
STUDENTS ACCUSED OF SCHOOL
BEHAVE BEARD SCHOOL MISBEHAVIOR
OR LOW LEVEL OFFENSES SHOULD BE
REFERRED TO APPROPRIATE SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND NOT TO PROBATION.
EIGHTY NINE A ONE REFORM
SECTIONS TO THIRTY SIX SIX FIFTY
FOUR AND SIX A ONE TO ENSURE
MORE EFFECTIVE AND SUPPORT OF
OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARINO YOUR ATTENTION CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
CAN WE GO YOU JUST COALITION PRO
COSPONSORS THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LUPITA COULD VIOLATE THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
GOOD DAY DEREK MORGAN FOR THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
BASED ALAMEDA COUNTY HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JULIE MCCORMICK CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CHRIS FOR SIGNS OF THE CHILDREN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KYLE MODEL ASK A STEEL WITH
COMMUNITY WORKS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UP ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
COULD YOU PLEASE MAKE ROOM
[inaudible] FOR ONE TO THREE
FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
BROKE TRICKLE PRINT ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE COALITION PROVISIONAL
REALIZATIONS.
PREVAILED IN OPPOSITION WE
APPRECIATE THE DOCTORS MEETING
WITH US AND DISCUSSING SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES.
I WANT TO JUST START OFF BY
RECOGNIZING THAT THE THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS CLEARLY.
THERE ARE SOME ABUSES IN THE
SYSTEM CLEARLY STUDENTS THAT ARE
ARE.
NEARLY TRUANTS OR HAVE SOME
BEHAVIORAL CHALLENGES SHOULD BE
PUT ON PROBATION.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH THE WAY THE
BILL IS WRITTEN NOW -- DAHLE
NOBLE INTENTION WOULD ADVERSELY
AFFECT THE ABILITY OF PREVENTION
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES OFFICERS TO
ENGAGE IN PREVENTIVE ACTIVITIES.
WITH SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH TAKEN TOGETHER
SECTIONS TWO THIRTY SIX AND SIX
OH ONE WHICH OF AND REFERENCE
BEFORE LAW PROVISIONAL STIRS TO
ENGAGE IN ACTIVITIES.
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO PREVENT
JUVENILES FROM EVER ENTERING THE
DELINQUENCY SYSTEMS.
THESE TWO SECTIONS ARE BEING
USED TODAY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BY PROVISIONAL FARMERS TO COURT
ACTIVITIES AND SERVICES THE
SOCIAL WORKERS. FOR YOU TO
UNDERPINS STATUS AND FOR YOU TO
MAY SIMPLY BE IDENTIFIED AS AT
RISK.
IF ENACTED SUCH COLLABORATIVE
APPROACHES WOULD BE BARRED AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY PREVENTION
FARMS ROLE LONGER BE ALLOWED TO
TAKE PROACTIVE APPROACH IS
WITHOUT RISK USE IN ADDITION AS
WRITTEN A. B. NINE A ONE WHAT
PRIVATE PROBATION OFFICERS TO
OFFER ANY SERVICES OR ACTIVITIES
TRAVIS USE.
UNTIL THEY'RE FORMERLY PLACE IN
THE DELINQUENCY SYSTEM WHICH
MEANS.
WE CAN IN PLACE ALSO NOT BE
ALLOWED TO INTERVENE IN TOLL
CHARGES ARE FORMALLY.
ENTERED AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT THIS
BILL IS A LOSS TO DO THAT.
REGRETTABLY WE OPPOSE THE BILL
IN THE SETTLEMENT THANK YOU
MISTER.
THANK YOU NEXT GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS DANIEL
SANCHEZ WITH THAT SHE PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA -- I DO
WANT TO SAY WE'VE HAD SOME
PRELIMINARY -- AND EARLY
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SPONSOR AND
AND AUTHORS OFFICE ON THIS AND
AND SO WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THEIR DESIRE TO LOOK AT THE
ISSUE OF HOW ARE WE WORKING WITH
YOUTH -- PARTICULARLY IN OUR
SCHOOLS WHATDOES THAT LOOK LIKE
FOR SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
ADDRESSING BEHAVIOR AND SO WE'RE
HAVING SOME OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT I THINK THE
CONCERN IS THAT.
THIS BILL GOES MUCH MUCH FURTHER
TO I TAKE AWAY THE ABILITY OF OF
PROBATION -- TO WORK WITH YOUTH
IN OUR COMMUNITIES BEFORE
THEY'RE IN THE THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT OUR DATA OVER THE
MANY YEARS AND DECADES ACTUALLY
SHOWS THAT WE'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL AND WE HAVE BEEN.
VERY MUCH COMMITTED -- TO SO ALL
INTRODUCED AND AND LET SAID THAT
YOU SPEAK TO THAT WELL WITH ME
TODAY IS A CHEAP STEPHANIE
GENE'S CHEAP PROBATION OFFICER
OF SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY AND ALSO
OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT OF C. PARK.
MORNING MISS LOW CHAIR MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE BEING HERE TO SPEAK
TO THE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE OF
JUVENILE DIVERSION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB NINE A WINE
PROVISIONS BEEN COMMITTED TO
IDENTIFYING DIVERTING YOUTH OUT
OF JUVENILE HALLS AND OUT OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM WHEN
APPROPRIATE AND IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE YOUTH IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS EVIDENCED BY JUVENILE
DETENTION RATES BEING DOWN 60%
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
WHICH ARE STILL CONTINUING TO
DECLINE.
FURTHER OF THE SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND REFERRALS TO PROBATION
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OVER
67% WERE DIVERTED.
OUT WE UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN
FOR NET WHITING BUT OUR DATA
JUSTICE NOT SURE THAT THAT'S
HAPPENING -- PROBATION
APARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
PROVIDE DIVERSION PROGRAMS TO
YOUTH IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
FOCUS ON BUILDING PROSOCIAL
ACTIVITIES THE NETWORKS FAMILY
SUPPORTS AND MANY OTHER PRO.
PROGRAMS TO ASSIST YOUTH AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS OFFER
SERVICES NOT JUST TO THE YOUTH
BUT TO THEIR SIBLINGS AND
PARENTS AS WELL WHO MAY ALSO
BENEFIT FROM THESE PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL WOULD AND OUR ABILITY
TO WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THIS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS
WELL AS GOVERNMENT ENTITIES. TO
DIVERT YOUTH WHO ARE ENGAGING IN
BEHAVIOR THAT PUT THEM AT RISK
OF ENTERING THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
LASTLY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS MADE MEASURE
DOES NOT ALL COUNTY IS DO NOT
HAVE THE SAME RESOURCES WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AS SUCH THIS BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE THE ABILITY A
PROBATION IN THOSE JURISDICTIONS
AS WELL AS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FROM PROVIDING PROGRAMS TO YOUTH
IN THE COMMUNITY WHO CAN BENEFIT
FROM SKILL BASED PROGRAMS
COMMUNITY AND FAMILY SUPPORTS
AND PROGRAMS THAT HELP BUILD PRO
SOCIAL NETWORKS.
IN HAS ACTIVELY LEAD CHANGES TO
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
HAS FOCUSED ON DIVERSION OUT OF
THE SYSTEM AND OUT OF HALLS.
AS WELL AS BUILDING COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS WE DO NOT BELIEVE IT
WOULD BE PRUDENT TO OUR YOUTH OR
COMMUNITIES TO REMOVE PROBATION
FROM WORKING WITH IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. TO REALLY ADDRESS
THE FRONT END OF OUR SYSTEM AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
NINE A ONE THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TWELVE THIRTY
SECONDS [inaudible]
GO.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION THE MAIN
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE WITH THIS
BILL IS THAT IT TAKES AWAY THE
COURT'S JURISDICTION OVER A
MINOR DUE TO HABITUAL TRUANCY.
HAVE VISUAL CURRENCIES
RECOGNIZED AS A RELIABLE
PREDICTOR OF FUTURE CONSOLIDATE
WHAT YOU'VE NO COURT PROCEEDINGS
CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT.
BE VIEWED AS THE ONLY METHOD OF
INTERVENTION IN THESE CASES.
DESTRUCTION SUPERVISION THAT
COULD BE PROVIDED BY THE
JUVENILE COURT IS A VALUABLE
TOOL IN HELPING -- MINERS WHO
MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS TO RESOURCES
ELSEWHERE RESPECTFULLY ASK VIDAK
PUT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT.
CORSO'S ALONG WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
MR SANTIAGO.
BUT THE RESORT RJR WAS FIRST IS
TIME.
GOOD OF ALL RIGHT -- LOOK I'VE
SEEN A LOT OF GREAT WORK DONE BY
ALAMEDA COUNTY PROBATION.
AND I THEREFORE REALLY THINK
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT --
THIS BILL BE NARROWED SO I WILL
NOT SUPPORTED AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
RESPOND.
WHICH IS NOT YET.
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
THINK THE AUTHOR WAS VERY
GENEROUS HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH ME OUTSIDE AND I WANT TO
MAYBE -- MAYBE I DON'T I'M NOT
ASKING FOR A RESPONSE RIGHT NOW
BUT MAYBE TO THE SPONSORS AND
THE AUTHOR.
IF IF IT IS TRUE THAT THIS BILL
DOES PREVENT -- THE ABILITY FROM --
FROM PREVENTING A PERSON FROM
BEING CONVICTED BECAUSE OF THE
ACTIVITIES THAT PROBATION
OFFICERS ARE INCLUDED IN I MEAN
THAT WOULD BE A I WOULD ASSUME
AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WE
WOULD NOT WANT TO FACE BECAUSE
THE WE'RE ALL TRYING TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WE IMPROVE PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
AND I KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT THE
OTHERS TRYING TO DO MAYBE THAT
CAN BE ADDRESSED -- DOWN THE
LINE BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT -- THAT WE VIEW THOSE
POSITIVE THINGS THAT THAT
PROVISIONAL OFFICER LAW
ENFORCEMENT DO TO PREVENT A
PERSON -- FROM GETTING --
GETTING CONVICTED THOSE
ACTIVITIES I WOULD PUBLIC I
WOULD ADVOCATE THAT BE ALLOWED.
TO CONTINUE SO THAT WE DON'T GET
TO THAT POINT -- THAT WOULD BE A
TRAGEDY IN THIS BILL IF THAT WAS
A THAT.
LITTLE PART WAS NOT FIXED.
AT THAT OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- WELL I
CERTAINLY WANT TO KNOW IF CAN
YOU ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE I THINK SOME
OF THEM ARE INCREDIBLY VALID AND
THEN MY SECOND QUESTION IS DOES
THIS AT ALL I DRANK THE CLEARING
OF TRUANCY RECORDS.
PLEASE -- SO REGARDING ON THE
ABILITY OF PROBATION APARTMENT
ACROSS THE STATE TO PARK FILING
DIVERSION WE WANT TO SUPPORT
THAT.
THE BILL DOESN'T PRECLUDE ANY
OTHER ACTIVITIES FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT BRINGS
YOUNG PEOPLE TO THE FRONT DOOR
OF A JUVENILE HALL.
PROBATION WAS STILL HAVE THE
AUTHORITY AND WE WOULD WANT THEM
TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DIVERT
YOUNG PEOPLE AWAY IN A PRE
FILING DIVERSION.
SIMILARLY PROBATION WOULD STILL
BE -- HAVING OPPORTUNITY IN
COURT TO ARGUE FOR DIVERSION
AWAY FROM MORE PUNITIVE SYSTEM
SO -- WHETHER THAT'S A CAMPER
RANCH PROGRAM -- EVEN A LOCKDOWN
PLACEMENT VERSES A COMMUNITY --
DIVERSION PROVISIONS ROLE IN
JUVENILE COURT WOULDN'T CHANGE
IN TERMS OF THEIR ROLE --
DIVERTING IN PEOPLE AWAY FROM
KUWAIT PROBATION VIOLATIONS INTO
CUSTODY AND PROBATION COULD
EITHER FUND OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
THEY THEMSELVES RUN PROGRAMS
AROUND ALTERNATIVES -- TO COURT
ORDER -- CUSTODY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN PROBATION
VIOLATIONS ON FURTHERMORE THERE
THERE WAS A QUESTION FROM I KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY REGARDING --
TRUANCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND THIS
BILL DOESN'T TOUCH THE ABILITY
FOR LOCAL COUNTIES TO HOLD PRESS
PARENTS ARM INVOLVED IN TRUANCY --
EITHER IN COURT TO THE DA'S
OFFICE OR IN AN COMMUNITY MEANS --
IT DOES DECRIMINALIZE TRUANCY
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE THAT SOMETHING IS ALREADY
HAPPENED IN LA COUNTY -- AND TO
GREAT EFFECT FOR EXAMPLE JUST
LOOKING AT ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT
VOTE SECOND LARGEST IN THE
NATION LA UNIFIED.
ON THE DECRIMINALIZATION OF
TRUANCY INTO COMMUNITY BASED ON
SCHOOL BASED PROGRAMS THAT
ADDRESS WHY YOUNG PEOPLE WEREN'T
ATTENDING SCHOOL ACTUALLY
INCREASED IN THIS IS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT GIVING THIS DATA.
INCREASE GRADUATION RATES IN LA
COUNTY FROM 40% TO OVER 60% AND
THE DIVERSION ALL RIGHT AWAY
FROM CRIMINALIZING CHOICE HE WAS
ONE OF THE MAIN THINGS THAT WAS
CITED AS A REASON FOR THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY I I KNOW IT'S MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE QUESTION.
HOPEFULLY YOU BENEFITTED AND I
COULD SEE YOU CAN MISS MCGILL
YOU HAVE YOU CAN READ MISTER.
LACKEYS MIND HE DID ASK THE
QUESTION HERE RIGHT NOW BUT I
WAS PRETTY GOOD.
MISTER BAUER K. IS.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT WE ALL
AGREE WITH.
THE OPPOSITION THAT WE WANT TO
AVOID KIDS GETTING INTO THE
DELINQUENCY SYSTEM THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THAT'S THE GOAL OF
EVERYBODY -- AND THE QUESTIONS
OF THOSE PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE
PROVIDING.
THAT PREVENT THAT ALTHOUGH GOOD
THE QUESTION IS THAT I THINK
POSED BY MR GIVES AND IS.
IS THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THE RIGHT PLACE TO BE PUTTING
THOSE PEOPLE TO GET THE SERVICES
TO PREVENT IT BECAUSE I DO THINK
THERE IS THE QUESTION THAT ONCE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO I'M SURE
ARE MOSTLY BLACK AND BROWN TOUCH
THE COLONEL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO END UP IN
IT IN A DELINQUENCY SETTING.
AND WE WANT TO PREVENT THAT AND
SO I GUESS I WOULD RAISE THE
QUESTION OF NOT.
LET'S NOT GET RID OF THOSE
PROGRAMS BUT WHO IS THE
APPROPRIATE. FORTY TO BE DOING
THOSE THINGS THAT'S GOING TO DO
THOSE THINGS BUT IS A PROBATION
IT SHOULD BE DOING THEM.
AND THEN.
I GUESS ONE OF MY BIGGEST ISSUES
AND I WAS CURIOUS TO KNOW IF MR
QUIRKS.
AMENDMENTS HE WANTS TO SEE
BECAUSE PART OF WHAT BOTHERS ME
SO MUCH ABOUT THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IS THESE ARE JUVENILES WHO HAVE
NOT COMMITTED A CRIME AND
THERE'S NO PARENTAL CONSENT.
AND NOT IS WITHOUT QUESTION AN
ACCEPTABLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
WHAT THAT A QUESTION I JUST
STATEMENT?
MISS POWER QUE.
YOU'RE JUST STATEMENT.
OKAY.
AS A SEE THROUGH THE CHAIR.
WE HAVE TELL YOU IT.
DO IT IN YOUR CLOTHES.
IF YOU NEED HELP FROM ANY OF THE
WITNESSES TAKEN.
COMMENT [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY OKAY. FOR NOW I WAS
GOING TO CLOSE.
FIRST OF ALL THERE IS A I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION I WANT TO MAKE A
POINT THAT WE IN FACT MET WITH
PROBATION AS OF YESTERDAY AND WE
HAVE A MEETING SCHEDULED FOR
FOUR O'CLOCK TOMORROW MY OFFICE.
TO REACH AND TO ADDRESS -- THEIR
CONCERNS AND SO THIS IS ALL
GOING PROCESS WE ARE OPEN -- TO
THEIR SUGGESTS IS TRY TO MAKE
THIS BILL BETTER AGAIN IT GOES
BACK -- TO THE MEMBER A FEW
MOMENTS AGO -- TALKED ABOUT YOU
KNOW CHILDREN BEING IN A
VOLUNTEER SITUATION BEING
TREATED AS IF THEY'RE CRIMINALS
AND THAT'S WE WANTED.
IN FACT TO PREVENT -- 80% OF
THOSE WHO ARE ON VOLUNTARY --
PROBATION ARE BEING TREATED THIS
WAY THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
OR NORT DOES IT STOP THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT OR ANY
OTHER -- GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY FOR
PROVIDING THE KIND OF SERVICES
THAT A FAMILY OR YOUNG PERSON
NEEDS THEY CAN CONTINUE TO DO
THAT.
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT IS THOSE WHO HAVE NOT.
BEEN IN THE COURT SYSTEM IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IT'S OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WOULD NOT EVEN
COMMITTED ANY CRIME -- WHO'VE
BEEN TREATED LIKE THE CRIMINALS
EVEN BEFORE WE HAVE PARENTS WHO
HAVE NOT EVEN HAD OPPORTUNITY TO
EVEN CONSULT ANY KIND OF
ATTORNEY OF THEIR RIGHTS BEEN
FOR THE CHILD'S BEEN FORCED IN
THIS PARTICULAR -- SITUATION AND
THAT'S UNFAIR AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE
BROAD -- AUTHORITY THAT THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT HAS -- WE
WANT TO LIMIT IT BECAUSE THEY
THEY HAVE BROAD DISCRETION AND
WE HAVE KIDS WHO ARE AGAIN
INNOCENT WHO HAVE NOT COMMITTED
ANY CRIME WHO'S BEEN SWEPT UP
AND BEING TREATED UNFAIRLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOAT.
OKAY.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND --
MOVED.
OKAY SO CHAIRS RECOMMEND I BASED
ON WHAT WAS TOLD TO ME BY THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM PROBATION
OFFICERS -- SPECIFICALLY THAT
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ABSOLUTELY TO TRY TO WORK
THROUGH ALL OF THESE ISSUES AND
THAT'S WHY DIDN'T I HAVEN'T
REALLY BEEN INVOLVED BECAUSE IT
SOUNDED LIKE AGAIN FROM THE
PROBATION SIDE.
THAT IT WOULD THEY WERE VERY
ENCOURAGE WITH WORKING WITH YOU
MISTER GIPSON.
OF THIS ALREADY SOME CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE SO THAT.
SO THAT NO ONE FEELS THAT.
WE WE STEIN YOUR WE STOP ANY
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT COULD BE
VERY HELPFUL FOR FOR THE USE.
OF SPECIALLY FROM PROBATION
OFFICERS PROBATION OFFICERS WHAT
I WOULD.
TELL YOU.
THERE WAS A YOUNG WOMAN HERE IN
TEARS.
THAT SHOULD TELL YOU THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG AND DON'T GET
TOO BUREAUCRATIC ABOUT THIS THIS
THIS AND THAT.
BUT REALLY GET INTO THE PAIN OF
THAT YOUNG PERSON WHO SAT HERE
AND BRAVELY TESTIFIED TODAY --
FOR OF ALL THESE PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD THAT.
THERE'S A PROBLEM.
AND BIG OF AN END YOU REALLY
NEED TO ADDRESS IT AND ADDRESS
IT NOW.
AND SO MISTER GIPSON WITH THAT
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU
WILL WORK THROUGH THESE THESE
PROBLEMS ARE ABSOLUTELY --
SPECIAL ANY GETS HOPE YOU IRONED
OUT.
OF IN APPROPRIATIONS GUIDING
DEBTS WERE WE COULD YOU GO NEXT --%
OTHERWISE IT WILL BE DIFFICULT
TO GET THIS OUT AFTER THAT SO I
WOULD I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU.
YOU ARE NOT A LOT OF THESE THESE
ISSUES AND GIVE SOME CERTAINTY
AND SOME CERTAINTY LANGUAGES TO
TO MAKE THIS COMMITTEE FEEL GOOD.
RESEARCHER YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO DOING THAT WE HAVE
A MEDIUM FOUR O'CLOCK ON
TOMORROW AND WE'LL WORK OUT WE
NEED TO BE WORKED OUT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ON EIGHTY NINE A ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. TO
ANSWER I LACKEY.
LACKEYNOPE BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
HI BUT I RESERVE THE RIGHT OF
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE WORKED OUT.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK OF FOLLOW --
CAM LIMIT GOV [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT RESERVE THE RIGHT DEPENDING
ON WHAT HAPPENS.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS HI WICKS I THE
MEASURE PASSES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS MR CHIU HERE.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB SIX EIGHT
EIGHT FIREARMS VEHICLE STORAGE.
YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRS I REMEMBERED
AND THE AB.
SIX EIGHTY EIGHTY PROTECT LAW
ABIDING GUN OWNERS AND KEEP GONE
ALL OF THE WRONG HANDS BY
REQUIRING.
THINGS UNATTENDED FIREARMS TO BE
CHAINED TO THE CAR AT ALL OF
SITE.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE FIVE
STATE WHICH WAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF STOLEN FIREARMS.
DATA SHOWS THAT IN BETWEEN
TWENTY TWELVE AND SEVENTEEN A
CLOSE TO EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND
FIRE ARMS WERE REPORTED STOLEN.
WAS IT WAS IT WAS TO MY DISTRICT
ALAMEDA COUNTY HAVE SEEN ABOVE
AVERAGE IN LOSS AND STOLEN
FIREARMS.
IN AN INDUCED OFTEN END UP.
IS BEING SOLD ILLEGALLY AND YOU
KNOW -- DIED IT WILL END UP IN
THE WRONG HANDS AND FORCE VOTE.
SOMETIMES IT USED TO COMMITTED.
CRIMINAL THE CRIMES.
ALTHOUGH CURRENT LAW REQUIRE
HAND GOING TO BE LOCKED.
IN AND ALL OF SITE IT DOESN'T
APPLY TO ORDER TYPE OF FIREARMS
THAT COULD CALLS EVEN MORE
DAMAGE.
SO SMASH AND GRAB ARE CONSTANTLY
UNDER RIGHTS THROUGH ALL THE
STATE.
AND IT IS TOO EASY TO GRAB A BOX
NOT ATTENDED A NOT ATTACHED TO
THE CAR.
SO IT IS MY DISTRICT -- OURS
SEEN UP TO NINE HISTORY INCREASE
IN SOUTH FROM BILL CALLS SO
CALLED TWENTY A HAS MADE GREAT
PROGRESS TO ENSURE.
THAT GUNS DO NOT END UP IN THE
WRONG HANDS IMPROPER STORAGE
WHEN THE ALIVE AND AND ATTENDED
INTO CARD WILL HELP LUIS WAS
THIS ISSUE.
THE THE CHAIN REQUIRE IN MY BILL
ARE REALLY AN ANNEX NG EXPENSIVE
SOLUTION AND WILL SERVE AS A
DETERRENT AGAINST DOES LOOKING
TO STILL FIREARMS. FOR UNLAWFUL
PURPOSES AND HERE WITH ME TODAY
IS A VERY SPECIAL WERE OF A
WITNESSES ALSO THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL NANCY ALL MOLLY.
IS ONE OF THE THAT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY.
AND WHOSE LOS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
FOR COMING UP HERE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I AS IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
SAID MY OFFICE AND I HAVE DONE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RESEARCH ON
GUN IN GUN VIOLENCE. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PREVENTION WE PUBLISH
REPORT.
EVERY FEW YEARS THAT REALLY
CHRONICLES STOLEN GUNS HOW GUNS
AND UP IN THE WRONG HANDS.
SO I WANT -- TO MAKE THE FIRST
POINT THAT THIS IS NOT A BILL
THAT WOULD TAKE FIREARMS AWAY
FROM LAWFUL OWNERS [inaudible]
USE ME.
THIS IS REALLY A BILL TO KEEP
THOSE LAWFUL GUNS IN THE RIGHT
HANDS.
AND WE HAVE FAR TOO MANY
EXAMPLES OF GUNS BEING STOLEN
OUT OF CARS AND THEN ULTIMATELY
USED IN CRIMES JUST IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THERE ARE
OVER TEN THOUSAND ALMOST ELEVEN
THOUSAND GUN STOLEN IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IN MY COUNTY ALONE THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX STOLEN GUNS A
GOOD PERCENTAGE OF THAT CAME OUT
OF CARS -- WE HAVE AS I SAID TOO
MANY EXAMPLES OF CARS BEING
BROKEN INTO AND FIREARM STOLEN
THAT AREN'T LOCKED UP OR NOT
SECURELY LOCKED UP -- JUST LAST
WEEK IN BERKELEY WE HAD A CAR
GET BROKEN INTO THE FIRE WAS IN
THE CAR IT WAS STOLEN AND THIS
HAPPENS.
FAR TOO OFTEN.
SO THIS THE OTHER POINT TO MAKE
IS THAT THE WHEN THIS BILL A
RICH WHEN THE LOT ORIGINALLY
PASSED. TO REQUIRE FIRES BE
LOCKED UP IT LEFT OUT LONG GUNS.
AND IN MY COUNTY -- THAT OVER
THE FIVE YEAR PERIOD OF OUR
THREE THOUSAND MORE THAN THREE
THOUSAND FIREARMS THAT WERE USED
IN CRIMES.
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE RIFLES. HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
WERE SHOT GUNS AND HUNDRED
FOURTEEN MORE ASSAULT WEAPONS
AND THOSE WERE ALL STOLEN.
SO THIS BILL NOT ONLY DOES IT
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF BEING MORE
SECURELY LOCKED UP SO THAT IF
SOMEONE DOES BREAK INTO A CAR.
IT'S NOT EASY TO GET A GUN OUT
OR FIRE ABOUT BUT SECONDLY IT
JUST EXT EXTENDS THE THE CURRENT
LAW TO INCLUDE THOSE LONG GUNS
THAT ARE.
OFTEN TIMES USING CRIMES
ESPECIALLY ASSAULT WEAPONS.
SO WITH THAT I URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTION MEMBERS COURCELLES
ALONG THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION --
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION
ESPECIALLY MIKE GOOD FRIEND AND
FORMER BOSS AND MENTOR.
I PROMISE TO BE NICE.
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS ABOUT FIREARMS BEING
STOLEN SPECIFICALLY BEING STOLEN
FROM VEHICLES.
WE HAVE TWO MAIN POINTS WE
WANTED TO KNOW TODAY AND WE HAVE
TALKED WITH THE AUTHOR WITH THE
STAFF WITH THE PROPONENTS -- AND
WILL CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT IT
BUT THE THE TWO ISSUES WE WANTED
TO RACE TODAY -- ONE THE THE
ADDITIONAL LOCKING REQUIREMENTS --
AS IT RELATES TO LONG GUNS COULD
IMPACT THE TIME IT TAKES TO
ACCESS THE WEAPON IN AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION SO.
IF IT'S A SITUATION WHERE YOU
HAVE TO GO THROUGH AN ADDITIONAL
LOCKER ANOTHER LATCH OR SOME
SOME FUNCTION IT'S SOMETHING
THAT TAKES A SECOND OR TWO COULD
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE
AND DEATH IN AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION.
I'M NOT TRYING TO RESERVE THE
HYPERBOLE BUT THAT'S THE REALITY
OF OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS TO
ACCESS THEIR TOOLS.
SECOND AS A PRACTICAL MATTER
EQUIPPING VEHICLES OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHETHER
IT'S CABLE LOCK OR SOMETHING
THAT'S PERMANENTLY AFFIXED TO
THE TO THE VEHICLE -- IT IT IT'S
THERE'S A MANDATE THERE'S A COST
THERE IS GONNA BE COST OF THIS
IS NO FUNDING IN THE BILL -- AND
WHEN TO STAND THAT WILL BE
ADDRESSED PRESUABLY IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BUT
JUST WANTED TO RAISE THOSE
THINGS THAT IT'S NOT JUST SO
EASY AS JUST GO DOWN TO THE
STORE GO TO AMAZON AND PICK UP
OF A LOCK IT'S YOU KNOW THERE
ARE OTHER.
CONSIDERATIONS THAT HAVE TO BE
DONE AND THAT HAS TO BE
RECOGNIZED YOU KNOW TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF TIMES.
BECAUSE THERE ARE THAT MANY
POLICE VEHICLES -- PLEASE OFTEN
TRAVEL AWAY FROM THEIR
JURISDICTIONS THEY MAY HAVE
THEIR WEAPONS THEY MAY HAVE A
RENTAL CAR THE RENTAL CAR WOULD
HAVE TO BE SIMILARLY EQUIPPED.
THEY MAY BE IN A SITUATION
SITUATION THEY MAY HAVE A
SPECIAL ASSIGNMENT WHERE PERHAPS
THERE ON A SWAT TEAM THEY TAKE
THEIR WEAPON WITH THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE.
DEPLOYED FROM WHEREVER THEY ARE
AT THE TIME AND THAT WEAPON MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO BE LOCKED IN THE
CENTER -- CENTER REGION OF THE
CAR -- SO THERE ARE SOME VERY
PRACTICAL CONSIDERATIONS AT AT
BAR HERE AND I WILL WE'RE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE DISCUSSING WHAT THE
AUTHOR BUT AT THIS TIME ARE
POSTED ALL THANK YOU.
YES.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND RE
WITH NATURAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
ALSO HERE.
FOR GUN OWNERS THE CALIFORNIA'S
MISTER BROTHERS AS I SAID
EARLIER HAD A FAMILY EMERGENCY.
BUT WERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL -- WE FEEL THAT IT'S OVERLY
BURDENSOME AND IN SOME CASES
UNATTAINABLE -- THE THE BILL
CALLS FOR LOCKING IT TO THE
FRAME OF THE CAR AND WE'VE SEEN
A COUPLE OF THINGS NUMBER ONE WE
SEE IN THE AUTO INDUSTRY GOING
AWAY FROM USING FRAMES AND
AUTOMOBILES AND THEY'RE USING A
UNIBODY CONSTRUCTION.
AND THEN ALSO WITH SOME OF THE
HYBRID SUCH AS TESTS WAS YOU
CAN'T EVEN ACCESS THE FRAME
BECAUSE OF HOW THE BATTERY SETS.
AND SO -- COMPLIANCE WITH THIS
WOULD BE VERY COSTLY -- AND
COULD BE INCREDIBLY PROBLEMATIC --
FOR SOMEONE WHO'S GOING OUT TO
THE FIELD ARE GOING TO THE RANGE --
ALSO OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN
EXPANSION BE ON HAND GUNS TO
LONG GUNS AND THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS.
YOUR LONG GUNS ARE.
LARGER AND AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE
WHEN THEY'RE GOING OUT TO THE
FIELD OR THEY'RE GOING TO THE
RANGE THEY'RE TAKING SEVERAL
FIREARMS AND SO -- IF THEY'RE
GONNA STOP AND HAVE ONE SURE OR
GET GAS OR OR DO SOMETHING TO
DEVIATE FROM THEIR PAST ALL THE
SUDDEN -- THE STORAGE
REQUIREMENTS COME IN AND IT'S
JUST REALLY NOT ATTAINABLE --
ONE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO
BRING UP AS COMMON CARRIERS AND
HOW ARE THE FED EX'S AND YOU PS
IS THE WORLD GOING TO COMPLY
WITH THIS THEY DO SHIP FIREARMS
EVERYDAY TO DEALERS.
THAT'S HOW THEY GO FROM THE
DISTRIBUTORS TO THE DEALERS IN
THE STATE AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS.
TO NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT SO AND
WITH THAT WERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU CHAIR MY NAME'S
MICHAEL FINLEY AND WITH THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION I'D LIKE TO ECHO ON
EVERYTHING THAT DâN WERE READ
SAID IN TERMS OF FFL DEALERS
DâN NAME AN ORGANIZATION --
JUST NAME AN ORGANIZATION BUT AS
WE HI JEFF REVOLVERS CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION AND WILL.
CARRY ON WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL WERE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ROY GRIFFITH
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION WERE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OF ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I JUST [inaudible]
IS THIS.
THIS LAW DOES NOT EXAM PEACE
OFFICERS RIGHT.
WHO -- AND DEFINITELY WILL
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE PEACE
OFFICERS TO SEE WHAT KIND OF
HELP PUT.
THE EXEMPTION BUT I CAN TELL DAY
IN TEN OF THOSE LAWS NOT TRYING
TO MAKE THE PEACE OFFICERS.
MOTIVE DIFFICULT TO PERFORM
THEIR JOB IS REALLY TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- WE DON'T.
EASILY AT THE LEVEL THAT THOSE
GUNS GET ANNA AND UP IN THE
WRONG HANDS.
INTO OURS FROM A CASES SO I
GUESS THE THAT THOSE WEAPONS OR
ARE STOLEN FROM THE PEACE
OFFICERS OF POSSESSION.
SO -- WHAT WE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WAS AT PEACE OFFICERS ON
THIS ISSUE AND HOW DOES THIS
ENCOURAGE SOMEONE TO REPORT THAT
THEIR GUN HAS BEEN STOLEN?
BECAUSE IF IF A GUN IS STOLEN
AND THEY REPORTED THEN YOU KNOW.
THERE IT'S PUNISHABLE AS A CRIME
THEY'RE FINE BUT SO HOW DOES
THIS ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW REPORT A STOLEN GUN.
AGAINST YOUR CONCERN IS THAT
BECAUSE WE REQUIRED THEM TO
CHANGE THAT AND THEY DON'T THEY
DIDN'T CHANGE THE AND THEY GOT
STOLEN -- SO THERE MIGHT BE
HESITANT OF REPORTING TO THE
DISTILLING A SOLUTION TO STOLEN --
GUN I I I I I I I AND I KNOW I
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN WILL YOU
KNOW WOULD BE -- THERE'S REALLY
NEED NOT THE REAL.
TENTATIVE -- MEASURE ON THIS
BILL TO SAY HEY IF YOU LOCK UP
YOUR CONSOLE ALLOW IT TO THROW
YOU IN JAIL SO -- IS NOT A
PUNITIVE [inaudible]
VOTE BLUE [inaudible]
FIND [inaudible]
GETTING INTO.
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW IT ENCOURAGES FOLKS TO DO
THE RIGHT THING -- WHOA WHOA
WILL CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO DO THE RIGHT THING BUT
AGAIN THIS BILL.
A IS FOCUS ON HOW DO YOU PROTECT
THE FOOT FOR THE LEGAL GONE
OWNER TO PROTECT YOUR PROPERTY.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE PROCEDURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OF WOULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOU KNOW
CONTINUE WORKING WAS THE PEACE
OFFICERS.
AND TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE DO YOU SHOULD THE SOME OF
SOMETIME THURSDAY DID THE PEACE
OFFICERS WERE WEAPONS GAR.
ALSO A STOLEN AND I ATE JUST
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THIS BILL
WAS BUILT ADDRESSING THE AN
ATTENDED YOU KNOW SO IF IF YOU
WOULD A GROUP OF PEOPLE GO OUT
HUNTING.
AND THIS ROAD -- GUNS IN THE
BACK OF THEIR PICKUP AND OR
SOMEBODY DARE DOES THAT THIS
DISTRICT JUST LAW DOESN'T REALLY
APPLY. TO TO TO THEM BECAUSE YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY DEAR. TO TO TO
WATCHES AND AND ALSO -- WHO? TO
FRAME OFF THE CAR I THINK WE
MADE TO AMENDMENT TO BE ANY
PERMANENT PART OF THE CAR.
UNDERSTANDING DID TO GO TO THE
IT WAS NOT A WELL DEFINED IN THE
REGIONAL.
OF BILL SO WE WILL HAVE ALREADY
MADE AMENDMENT.
TWO'S TO SAY TO PERMIT ANY
PERMANENT PART OF TWO THE CARD.
WAS SAD I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU NIGHT
AND HOPEFULLY YOU YOU YOU WORK
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT STRIKE.
I WORKED AT A PARMESAN SERVICE I
REMEMBER WORKING ON THE FLEET
SERVICES EARLY PT CARS THERE ARE.
SOME PRECAUTIONS THAT THEY'RE
HAPPIER BUT I ALSO KNOW.
OFFICER HAS A GUN STOLEN IS NOT.
GOING BACK AND TELLING.
YOUR COMMANDING OFFICER IS NOT.
SOMETHING YOU EVER WANT SIDE
WINDOW BUT ALSO TO MAKE SURE
WHEN A ROLL UP. TO AN EMERGENCY.
THEY DON'T LIEU SECONDS.
TRYING TO GO HELP SOMEONE SO UP --
I WOULD TAKE THE CONCERNS OF THE
THAT THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
SERIOUSLY ABOUT WHAT WE WHAT
PRECAUTIONS WE PUT ON THEM --
AND THE MONETARY.
ASPECT OF THAT YOU'LL DEAL WITH
AN APPROPRIATIONS -- AND IS ALSO
WANTED THE ARE A PRODUCT AT HOW
DO YOU SECURE THIS WITHOUT.
IT BECOMING EXTREME COST SO --
YOU HAVE A COUPLE THINGS YOU
NEED TO WORK THROUGH JUST TO GET
OUT OF APPROPRIATIONS MUCH LESS
GETTING IT.
APPROVED ON THE FLOOR CHAU.
HI WITH RESERVATIONS.
ON EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS G. PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER CHEN SIR HI LACKEY.
BAUER-KAHAN I BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP
[inaudible]
WATER DEPTH.
KAMLAGER-DOVE CAN NOT VOTING.
QUIRK OUR QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS HI WICKS I IT'S ON CALL
YOU NEED ONE MORE VOTE WHEN
OTHER MEMBERS COME BACK.
OKAY.
A MISTER [inaudible]
HAM.
AB SIX SIX THREE ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE AND HE'S NOT HERE
[inaudible]
I'VE.
SO MISTER CUNNINGHAM SIDE HERE
SO MISTER BONTA IS NEXT.
AB.
SEVEN THREE TWO AND A. B. NINE
SEVEN TWO ITEM SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY FIVE IT'S NOW 1-225- YOU
BETWEEN US ANDSOMEWHERE ELSE.
UNDERSTOOD MISTER CHAIR AND AND
COLLEAGUES AB OUT CONCERT WITH
A. B. SEVEN THIRTY TWO YES IT
WOULD IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
INCARCERATED PENDING
CALIFORNIANS IN COUNTY JAILS IN
STATE PRISONS MANY OF THE
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS CURRENTLY
EXIST IN.
STATE PRISONS THE STATE
REGULATIONS -- BUT THEY DON'T
EXIST IN COUNTY JAILS THIS WILL
THIS BILL WILL CODIFY THOSE
REGULATIONS SO THAT.
THERE'S A MORE PERMANENT --
APPLICATION OF THOSE RULES AS
THEY PRESENT AND ALSO APPLY
THESE PROTECTIONS.
TO COUNTY JAILS THINGS LIKE
PRENATAL CARE VISITS POST PARTUM
EXAMINATIONS ALSO THINGS LIKE
RESTRICTIONS ON SHACKLING OF
PREGNANT CALIFORNIANS AND
PROHIBITING SOLITARY CONFINEMENT --
THIS HELPS US PROVIDING FIGHTING
COMPASSIONATE HEALTH CARE AND
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS.
WHO ARE PREGNANT AND
INCARCERATED I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY DOCTOR KAREN SCOTT?
REPRESENTING THE WOMEN'S POLICY
INSTITUTE THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND MY AT INGRAM
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
SECOND.
GO AHEAD DOCTOR PASSED YES.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS ACT TO
CARE SCOTT I AM A BOARD
CERTIFIED OB GUARANTEE.
AND WITH SEVENTEEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE SPEAKING IN FAVOR
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO AM ALSO
THE TWENTY NINETEEN WOMEN'S
POLICY IS TO FOLLOW IN THE
ARGENTINE.
THE BILL SPONSOR ACCORDING TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DATA
APPROXIMATELY SIX THOUSAND
FEMALES ARE INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIA AND ABOUT FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED ARE OF CHILDBEARING AGE
THIS PAST SUMMER CAM TO STILL
THOUGHT A LAWSUIT AGAINST
ALAMEDA COUNTY JAIL.
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE AFTER THE
JAIL STAFF DISREGARD A VITAL
INFORMATION AT INTAKE BILL TO
PRIORITIZE A PREGNANCY IS HIGH
RISK AND PROVIDED SUBSTANDARD
CARE AND SUPPORT.
CANDACE UP RESULTS HER
CONFINEMENT WHERE SHE GAVE BIRTH
PREMATURELY TO OUR BABY GIRL
HOPE BANG CARSON PREGNANT PEOPLE
STATE PRISON THE COUNTY JAILS
HAVE NOW BECOME THE DEFAULT
SAFETY NET. FOR PREGNANT PEOPLE
IN NEWBORNS AS YOUR TWO MAIN
POINTS OF TO JUSTIFY THE NEED
FOR A BI SEVEN THIRTY TWO NUMBER
ONE EXISTING LAW DOES NOT
ALIGNED WITH THE STAND AS A
PROFESSIONAL CARE PRACTICE. FOR
THE PROVISION OF A SUCH A
COMPACT OF CARE EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO WILL REQUIRE AN
OBSTETRICIAN OR NURSE TO VERIFY
THE PREGNANCY H..
CONDUCT INITIAL EXAM TO
DETERMINE THE PLAN OF CARE
NECESSARY TEST NUMBER TWO
EXISTING LAW LACKS SPECIFICITY
RESULTING IN VARIATIONS IN THE
QUALITY OF CARE SUCH AS THE MIST
INACCURATE AND OR DELAYED
ASSESSMENTS DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT.
LEADING TO POOR BIRTH OUTCOMES A
LAWSUIT EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO
WILL REQUIRE THE PROVISION OF
TIMELY CONFERENCE OF CARE FOR
HIGH RISK PREGNANCIES CHRONIC
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AND
SUBSTANCE ADDICTIONS IMPACTING
PREGNANCY THE BIRTH THE NEW BORN
IN THE POST PARTUM PERIOD.
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO WILL
REQUIRE CHANGES TO REPORT OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES FOR
INCARCERATED PREGNANT PEOPLE
DOUBLE UP PULL THE DIGNITY AND
HUMANITY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AVOIDING EYE ON EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NECKS I AND GRAHAM
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH THE UNJUST MASS
INCARCERATION SYSTEM SO LONG AS
PEOPLE ARE INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIA HAS A DUTY TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR HEALTH CARE.
WE ISSUED A REPORT ABOUT THE
STATE OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IN
JAILS AND PRISONS AND I WANT TO
SHARE A FEW STORIES FROM THERE.
ONE MISSILE CONSISTENT LACK OF
ADEQUATE AND TIMELY PRETTY KAREN
JAIL.
DESTINY HAD A HIGH RISK
PREGNANCY DUE TO A PREVIOUS
STILLBORN SHE FELT SHARP PAINS
IN HER STOMACH AND PUSHED HER
EMERGENCY BUTTON.
SHE WAS HAD TO WAIT THIRTY
MINUTES BEFORE SHE WAS TAKEN TO
THE CLINIC WHERE THERE WAS NO
DOCTOR OB NURSE ON DUTY SHE WAS
TOLD SHOULD HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
THE NEXT DAY TO SEE A DOCTOR.
WE ALSO SAW INDIVIDUALS PLACED
IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT RIGHT
AFTER GIVING BIRTH.
AFTER BEING SEPARATED FROM HER
BABY FOR TWO DAYS PATH WAS
PLACED IN A TOP BUNK AND A NEW
CELL DESPITE THE FACT SHE WAS
RECOVERING FROM A C. SECTION.
THE DEPUTIES SEARCHED OUR
BELONGINGS FOUND SOMETHING
OBJECT DOUBLE AND SHE WAS
SENTENCED TO SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT FOR TWENTY DAYS SHE
WAS RELEASED AFTER THREE DAYS
ONLY BECAUSE A LAWYER INTERVENED
ON HER BEHALF.
THE LOSSES IN COUNTLESS STORIES
OF RATIONING OF MENSA PRODUCTS
IN JAILS.
THAT BILL HAD A MEDICAL
CONDITION THAT CAUSED HER TO
BLEED HEAVILY DURING HER PERIODS
DESPITE A DOCTOR'SNOTE HER JAIL
ONLY ALLOWED ONE THIN PAD PER
DAY PER PERSON.
SHE REPORTED OTHER PEOPLE
PRESIDING TO MAKING THEIR OWN
PADS AND TAMPONS OUT OF TOILET
PAPER SOCKS AND WATCH CLASS
OTHERS BLOOD THROUGH THEIR
CLOTHES AND HAD TO WAIT DAYS
FRIEND CLEAN CLOTHES.
THIS BILL ALIGNS WITH OTHER
COMMON SENSE REFORMS IN THE
LEGISLATURE SUCH AS SENATOR
MITCHELL'S BILL SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY THREE THAT EXPANDED BIRTH
CONTROL MENTAL PRODUCT ACCESS IN
PRISONS.
AND THE CHAIRS ON BILL LAST YEAR
TO ESTABLISH PUMP AND PICK UP
PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELECTED IN COUNTY JAILS WE ARE
AT YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DEREK MORGAN FOR THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I THINK BUT THE NUMBER A HALF OF
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MR CELLS ELLO SO TOUGH DAYA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
COREY SOCIALISM BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION HERE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL -- WE'RE
NOT AGAINST -- PROVIDING
HEALTHCARE FOR PREGNANT INMATES
WE ARE CONCERNED HOWEVER ABOUT
SETTING THE STANDARDS OF
RIGOROUS TREATMENT WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT.
THE THE MANDATE THAT PRENATAL
AND POST PARTUM CARE BE
DELIVERED BUT THAT.
THE BILL GETS INTO SPECIFIC
LEVELS OF DETAIL OF HOW
FREQUENTLY OF A PREGNANT INMATE
MUST VISIT -- THE DOCTOR -- THE
THE NATURE OF WHICH THE VITAMINS
THAT MUST BE PROVIDED -- IT
EXISTING REGULATIONS GOVERNING
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
INCLUDING JAILS -- THEY HAVE
THEIR REQUIRED TO HAVE WRITTEN
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THAT
PROVIDE FOR SCREENING AND CARE
PREGNANT INMATES.
THIS INCLUDES PRENATAL AND POST
PARTUM INFORMATION AND HEALTH
CARE INCLUDING PRENATAL VITAMINS
INFORMATION ABOUT CHILD BIRTH
EDUCATION -- INFANT CARE --
SITTING THESE PROVISIONS AND
STATURE LIMITS FLEXIBILITY MANY
OF THESE DISCRETE REQUIREMENTS
ARE ALREADY BEING UNDERTAKEN IN
COUNTY JAILS ACROSS THE STATE
NOT NECESSARILY TO THE DEGREE.
AND SCRIPT WHICH THE BILL
MANDATES BUT SOME OF THESE
THINGS ARE ALREADY BEING DONE --
BUT PUTTING THEM IN STATURE IT
MEANS THAT WOULD BEST PRACTICES
CHANGER WHEN THERE'S A DIRECTED
COURSE ARE CHANGING TREATMENT --
WE NOW HAVE TO COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO SAY IT SHOULDN'T
BE THIS MENU ITEMS SHOULD BE
THAT MANY OR SHOULD BE THIS MANY
VISITS A TWENTY SIX WEEKS IT
SHOULD BE THIS MANY VISITS A
TWENTY EIGHT WEEKS -- AND SO
THAT JUST CREATES BUREAUCRATIC
CHALLENGES THAT WE SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO DEAL WITH SO -- DISTRICT
MANDATES ADDITIONAL BE VERY
COSTLY ESPECIALLY IN SMALL
COUNTIES WILL ADDRESS THAT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
FURTHER BUT FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE RESPECT THE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MET.
MR QUIRK -- THE OBJECTIONS OF
THE SHALL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
BUT THE OBJECTION OF HAVING TOO
MUCH SPECIFICITY SOUNDS.
LIKE IT'S A CONCERN AND I HOPE
YOU ADDRESS THAT IT'S BILL GOES
ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE RESPONDED THANK
YOU JUST A QUICK RESPONSE THAT
THE STATE PRISONS ALREADY AT
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION HAD IS OBJECTING TO
SO WE THINK COUNTY JAILS CAN.
TO WE DON'T THINK IT'S OVERLY
SPECIFIC -- WE THINK THAT IT
CREATES A IMPORTANT FLOOR OF
QUALITY FOR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE FOR VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
AND WHO ARE INCARCERATED -- I AM
WILLING TO GO BACK AND LOOK --
CERTAINLY AT THE REQUEST OF
MISTER QUIRK IN AND AND CONSIDER
AREAS THAT THAT -- COULD BE LESS
SPECIFIC BUT WE WE WE THINK
WE'RE PROVIDING A MINIMUM FLOOR
OF QUALITY CARE -- AND IT'S
ALREADY BEEN DONE AT THE STATE
LEVEL SO WE KNOW IT CAN'T BE
DONE -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
Và IN AND I HOPE MEN OF THE
CHAIR SUPPORTING AS A BUT I ALSO
HOPE THAT THIS IS BASED ON WHAT
THE MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
ONE OF I WOULDN'T WANT.
LONG FOR SUIT WHICH IS MOSTLY
MALE.
TELLING A WOMAN WHAT SHE CAN OR
CAN'T.
OR WAS SHE NEEDS ARE NOT NEED --
I READ A HAVE A A PHYSICIAN.
OF WHO HAS THE QUALITY OF CARE
IN A MINE TO TO MAKE A DECISION
ABOUT HOW MANY PILLS I MEAN
VISITS WHAT SO HOPEFULLY WE'RE
COR.
YOU'RE TALKING MORE OF THAT
COORDINATION -- THEN BEING I
GUESS REALLY.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN ONLY DO THIS
MANY AT THAT MANY THAT MANY THAT
IT'S REALLY BASED ON ON A
MEDICAL CONSIDERATION NOT
NECESSARILY -- PROGRAMS OR THE
WAY THAT THE THE OPERATION WORKS
OUT I ALSO WAS TOLD WHEN I DID
THE BREAST FEEDING.
BILL THAT THEY'RE A LOT OF
BREAST FEEDING PROGRAMS ALREADY
IN JAILS AND SO I WAS.
OBVIOUSLY MADE ME FEEL PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT.
PUSHING TO THAT BILL SO
HOPEFULLY AS WE MOVE FOR WITH
THIS -- WAIT WE INCLUDE ABOUT A
PROFESSION.
A CALL FOR THE BOAT.
AN EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER I TO ANSWER I LACKEY.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
WHICH IS WORKING AT TWO YOU MAY
BEGIN MISTER BONTA THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES THIS IS
AB NINE SEVENTY TWO ARE
AUTOMATIC RECORDS MODIFICATIONS.
BILL WHICH CREATES A SIMPLER
MORE EFFICIENT MORE EXPEDITED
PATHWAY FOR THOSE CALIFORNIANS
ELIGIBLE UNDER PROP. FORTY SEVEN
TO MODIFY THEIR CONVICTIONS TO
BECOME MISDEMEANORS RATHER THAN
HAVING TO PETITION -- WELL
RATHER THAN HAVING TO KNOW
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE AND THEN -- GEN
AND AND AND PICASSO PETITIONING
MAYBE EVEN SEEK LEGAL COUNSEL --
WE'RE PROPOSING AN APPROACH THAT
WE USE LAST YEAR FOR PROP SIXTY
FOUR ELIGIBLE -- REDUCTIONS AN
EXPUNGEMENT SWEAR BY THE DOJ
WILL RUN A DATABASE -- IDENTIFY
ELIGIBLE CONVICTIONS DAYS WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO OBJECT
AND THEN -- THE X. THE
MODIFICATIONS WILL OCCUR
AUTOMATICALLY SO WE THINK THIS
IS THAT A NEW APPROACH A BETTER
APPROACH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME I HAVE YVONNE SILVA
WITH CODE FOR AMERICA TO DISCUSS
THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE
PROCESS.
AND ALSO HILARY BLOW OUT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SENTENCE
REVIEW PROJECT [inaudible]
THANK YOU[inaudible]
YES.
HI MY NAME'S YVONNE SILVA SENIOR
PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITH CODE FOR
AMERICA AND I'M HERE TODAY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF GOOD FOR
AMERICA NONPROFIT THAT USES.
THE PRINCIPLES AND PRACTICES OF
THE DIGITAL AGE TO IMPROVE OUR
GOVERNMENT SERVICE THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
I COULD FOR AMERICA WE BELIEVE
THAT GOVERNMENT CAN WORK
DRAMATICALLY BETTER THAN IT DOES
TODAY AND THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS ONE OF THE AREAS WHERE
WERE FAILING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
POST.
CALIFORNIA'S RECORD CLEARANCE
PROCESS WAS NOT DESIGNED FOR THE
DIGITAL AGE THE PETITION BASE
PROCESS DOESN'T WORK IT'S COSTLY
IT'S CUMBERSOME IT'S CONFUSING
IN WAS NOT DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
THE RELIEF.
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IN
AVAILABLE UNDER STATE LAW.
GOOD FOR AMERICA'S BEEN WORKING
TO TRANSFORM THE WAY GOVERNMENT
DELIVER SERVICES TO THOSE
IMPACTED BY THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM ONE OF THE WAYS WE'VE
BEEN DOING THIS IS BY RE
IMAGINING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
RECORD CLEARANCE PROCESS
LEVERAGING.
THE PRINCIPLES OF USER CENTERED
DESIGN.
OUR WORK HAS SHOWN THE
CALIFORNIA CAN'T IMPLEMENT
AUTOMATIC RECORD CLEARANCE AND
MODIFICATION AT SCALE.
AS YOU MAY RECALL A LAW PASSED
LAST SESSION AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
THREE EXPEDITES REVIEW OF
CONVICTIONS ELIGIBLE UNDER PROP.
SIXTY FOUR AND MAKES RELIEF FOR
ELIGIBLE CONVICTIONS AUTOMATIC
WITH NO PETITION REQUIRED -- BY
THE INDIVIDUAL.
WE LAUNCHED A PILOT LAST YEAR TO
PARTNER WITH DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
IN FIVE COUNTIES TO EXPEDITE THE
REVIEW OF CONVICTIONS UNDER PROP.
SIXTY FOUR WITH THE PASSAGE OF
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE THIS
COHORT WILL NOW SET THE STANDARD
FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
AND MAKE REAL THE RELIEF
AVAILABLE TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS UNDER
PROP.
SIXTY FOUR THE SAME IS POSSIBLE
FOR CONVICTIONS UNDER PROP FORTY
SEVEN AS CONTEMPLATED BY.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY TWO WE'VE
BUILT A TOOL THAT WE CALL CLEAR
MY RECORD THAT CAN NOW READ
CRIMINAL HISTORY DATA AND
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY FOR
CONVICTIONS FOR THOUSANDS OF
CONVICTIONS IN JUST A FEW
MINUTES.
AS OPPOSED TO WEEKS MONTHS OR
EVEN YEARS.
THIS SHIFT ELIMINATES THE NEED
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL TO PETITION
FOR THE FOR RELIEF AND FOR DA
STAFF TO GO THROUGH RECORDS ONE
BY. ONE TO OBSTACLES TO RECORD
CLEARANCE.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE OR AN ATTORNEY
IN GENERAL -- ON AVERAGE TAKES
FIFTEEN TO THIRTY MINUTES TO
REVIEW A CRIMINAL RECORD TO
VALUE ELIGIBILITY FOR RECORD
MODIFICATION.
OUR TOOL CAN READ FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND LINES OF CRIMINAL
HISTORY DATA NINETY SECONDS.
THERE'S NO NEED FOR GOVERNMENT
TO MANUALLY SEARCH FOR AN
ANALYZE CRIMINAL RECORDS OR
CRIMINAL HISTORY DATA TO
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY FOR RECORD
MODIFICATION.
STREAMLINING CONVICTION DATA
PROCESSING THROUGH OUR TOOL ALSO
MAKES IT EASIER FOR COURTS TO
UPDATE THEIR RECORDS WHICH HELPS
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE GET THE
RELIEF AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
PUT SIMPLY THERE'S A WAY FOR
PROSECUTORS OFFICES TO REVIEW
AND EVALUATE EDGE ABILITY FOR
RECORD MODIFICATION FOR ALL
CASES WITHIN ITS JURISDICTION AT
AN EXPONENTIALLY FASTER PACE IN
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER COST.
TECHNOLOGY WORKS BEST WHEN IT'S
SIMPLE AND EASY TO USE AND CLEAR
MY RECORD IS A PRIME EXAMPLE.
WE BUILT THIS TOOL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH GOVERNMENT WITH
A THOROUGH UNDERSTANDING OF
POLICY IN GOVERNMENT NEEDS AND
RECOGNIZING THAT THE CURRENT
PETITION BASED PROCESS WAS NOT
DESIGNED TO SERVE ALL WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TODAY.
GOVERNMENT HAS THE ABILITY TO
FILL THE RECORD MODIFICATION
INTENT OF PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN IN A MANNER THAT SIMPLER.
EXPEDITIOUS LESS EXPENSIVE AND
THAT SERVES THE CONSTITUENTS
BETTER. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY TWO
BRINGS AS WELL ALL ONE STEP
CLOSER TO RE IMAGINING EXISTING
GOVERNMENT PROCESSES AND IN TURN
DELIVERING ON THE PROMISE OF
PROP FORTY SEVEN TO REDUCE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS THANK
YOU.
I'M GOOD MORNING -- THANK YOU --
MY NAME IS HILARY BLOWOUT AND I
JUST WANTED.
TO SHARE JUST A COUPLE REAL
WORLD EXAMPLES ABOUT WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED DURING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP.
FORTY SEVEN SO I WAS THE PROP
FORTY SEVEN IMPLEMENTATION
DIRECTOR FOR THE STATE FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND SPENT THREE YEARS
TRYING TO IDENTIFY WAYS TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS AND
IDENTIFY.
THE MILLION PEOPLE -- THAT WE
KNEW THAT STOOD TO BENEFIT FROM
PROP FORTY SEVEN AND I TELL YOU
WE TRIED EVERYTHING -- WE TRIED
TO DO IS STATEWIDE SYSTEM -- BUT
WE HAD DIFFERENT COUNTIES HAVING
DIFFERENT FORMS IN DIFFERENT
PROCESSES WE HAD PEOPLE GOING TO
ONE COUNTY THINKING THAT THEY
CLEARED ALL THEIR CONVICTIONS
GOING TO GET JOBS AND STILL
GETTING DENIED BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T REALIZE THEY HAD A
CONVICTION IN ANOTHER COUNTY.
WE TRY TO WORK WITH THE J. TO
GET STATEWIDE RAPSHEETS SO THAT
WE CAN REALLY GET IN A CLEAR ALL
OF THE RECORDS ON A PERSON'S --
RAP SHEET AND THAT PRESENTED ITS
OWN BERRIER SINCE GETTING THE
RAP SHEET ITSELF COSTS SIXTY
DOLLARS SO THEN WE WHEN WE TRY
TO DO RAP SHEET EVENTS AND
CLINICS AND WE DID.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF INTERVIEWS AND
DISCUSSIONS WITH PEOPLE THAT HAD
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS ON THEIR
RECORD WE BUILT CAPACITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH
COMMUNITY GROUPS GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS LEGAL CLINICS
CHURCHES YOU NAME IT WE BUILT
CAPACITY ACROSS THE STATE IN
THREE YEARS.
AND WITH ALL OF THAT THEY'RE
STILL.
I THINK THE NUMBERS A MILLION
PEOPLE THAT STILL STAND TO
BENEFIT.
SO THE ONLY WAY THAT WE CAN
REALLY MAKE THE PROMISE OF PROP
FORTY SEVEN REAL IS TO HAVE SOME
AUTOMATED MECHANISM OR WE CAN
TARGET THE PEOPLE THAT.
ARE ELIGIBLE AND THEN WE CAN GO
OUT IT FROM THAT DIRECTION I
WANT TO LIFT OF ONE OTHER PIECE
THAT HASN'T BEEN MENTIONED HERE
AND THAT'S THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE SEVERAL NON CITIZENS THAT
ALSO STAND TO BENEFIT FROM PROP.
FORTY SEVEN AND THERE'S THERE
ARE.
MANY OF THEM THAT DO NOT FEEL
COMFORTABLE COMING TO COURT AND
A AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES GIVEN THE FEDERAL
ENFORCEMENT TACTICS ADVICE SO
DOING THIS ALSO ALLOWS US TO GET
AT THAT POPULATION WHO ALSO CAN
BENEFIT.
AND ALSO CAN AVOID MANDATORY
DEPORTATION BY JUST CHANGING A
FELONY TO A MISDEMEANOR THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN.
SUPPORT.
HELLO AGAIN DEREK MORGAN FOR THE
ELEVATORS PERSONS.
FORGIVE ME -- DEREK MORGAN FOR
THE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARGOT GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS HALLS WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
MOLLY BYNUM UT W. ASKED ME LOCAL
THEIR NINE THIRTY IN SUPPORT. TO
THAT CITY BUT THE NUMBER HALF OF
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE ALSO AS A
CO SPONSOR AND INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
DID YOU TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
TYLER MAGANA -- SIXTY WITH
COMMUNITY WORKS IN SUPPORT.
ENGINE MINETTI WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE ALSO
SPONSOR THE BILL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CAN MEMBERS TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THIS BILL IMPOSES NEW AND
POTENTIALLY TIME CONSUMING
LEVELS OF SERVICE ON LOCAL
PROSECUTOR OFFICES WITHOUT
ALLOCATING SPECIFIC FUNDS IN THE
BUDGET FOR THAT INCREASE.
THERE IS A MANDATE BUT IT IS NOT
GUARANTEED.
THERE ARE MANY SITUATIONS WHERE
A FOLLOW MANDATES DO THE WORK
BUT NEVER SEE THE MONEY.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
CREATES A SEPARATION OF POWERS
ISSUE.
BY LEGISLATIVELY REQUIRING
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO PRIORITIZE
OUR RESOURCES TO REVIEW PRIOR
CONVICTIONS.
AND INFORM THE COURTS IN THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S WHICH
CONVICTIONS DO OR DO NOT MEET
THE CRITERIA FOR RE SENTENCING.
IMPEDES ON OUR EXECUTIVE BRANCH
DETERMINATION OF HOW WE ALLOCATE
PROSECUTORIAL RESOURCES.
THIS BILL IS IN ASKING US TO
SIMPLY IDENTIFY WHO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR RELIEF.
WOULD REQUIRE US TO LOOK AT THE
PARTICULARS OF EACH CASE AND
MAKE A FACTUAL DETERMINATION OF
WHETHER THE PERSON IS ELIGIBLE.
NEEDS TO BE A SEPARATION BETWEEN
THE FUNCTIONS OF THE DA AND THE
FUNCTIONS OF THE DEFENSE.
THESE REQUIREMENTS PUSH US INTO
THE REALM OF ADVOCACY IN DEFENSE
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS MORE
APPROPRIATELY HANDLED BY THE
DEFENSE BY RATHER THAN TO THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. FOR THESE
REASONS WE REQUEST ANOTHER.
ARE ANY OF THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE FIRST ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THE
PEOPLE ARE ASKING FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN THEY'VE ASKED FOR IT TO
HAPPEN THEY ASKED BACK IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT THOSE WHO
HAVE THE ELIGIBLE -- FELONY
CONVICTION ON THE RECORD THAT
THEY BE REDUCED TO MISDEMEANORS
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED YET AND SO
WERE WERE PROPOSING A PROCESS.
THAT ALLOWS IT TO HAPPEN THAT
MOVES IT FORWARD EFFICIENTLY AND
ACCURATELY -- THE DA'S WILL HAVE
TWO YEARS AND FOUR MONTHS UNDER
THIS BILL. TO REVIEW I AM THE
DOJ'S LAST AND AND AND TAKE
ACTION ON THEM WE THINK THAT'S
SUFFICIENT WE THINK THAT'S FAIR.
WE ARE ALSO -- WELL AWARE THAT
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO DO THIS
WE'RE SEEKING MONEY THE BUDGET
FOR THAT AS WELL SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT AND WE AGREE.
AND WE'RE FIGHTING FOR THAT
MONEY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MISTER BOB BONTA CHU
IS RECOMMENDING ICE BUT SHE'S
INTERESTING FOR FUNDING.
SO CALLED.
AN EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES -- I LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE CAN
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS I'VE WICKS I
THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF AND
FINALLY A. B. SIX SIX THREE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I JUST SAT FOR
ABOUT THIRTY MINUTES I'M.
I I WILL BE BRIEF IN THE ONGOING
FIGHT AGAINST HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ONE ISSUE THAT -- AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
ADDRESS IS A A FUNDING STREAM
FOR SUPPORT SERVICES FOR THE
VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING.
A WHAT MY BILL SEEKS TO DO IS
PROVIDE THAT FUNDING STREAM AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL SO THAT VICTIMS
OF TRAFFICKING CAN GET SUPPORT
SERVICES SUCH AS COUNSELING
RELOCATION OTHER SERVICES.
AS THE CHAIR KNOWS THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION FUND IS UNDER SOME
STRESS THIS WILL CREATE A
SEPARATE STANDALONE FUNDING
SOURCE.
AND ALLOW -- COUNTIES TO RETAIN
75% OF THE FINE MONEY FOR
SOLICITATION AND DIRECT THAT
INTO HELPING VICTIMS OF
TRAFFICKING -- I DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES TODAY AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS
BILL ACCEPT AMENDMENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT ABOUT.
OKAY WELL I'LL ASK ANYWAY ORDER
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LOOK THEY'RE ASKING RETAIN THE
IMAGE.
NOT THIS YEAR [inaudible]
OKAY.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES NOT POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SORRY FOR
STRETCHING OUT INTO THE LUNCH
HOUR -- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS -- MARCO
GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE'RE
STILL IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
AND BASICALLY WE DON'T THINK IT
MAKES SENSE.
TO FINE PROSTITUTES TO FUND
SERVICES FOR PROSTITUTES AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES -- IN
THE MUNICIPAL COURT WHAT USED TO
BE CALMING TO SUPPORT NOW
SUPERIOR COURT -- IN OAKLAND WE
DO NOT SEE ROGER CRAFT WE DO NOT
SEE HI PRESS PRICE CALL GIRLS.
WE SEE STREET PROSTITUTES.
AND THOSE FOR THE MOST PART
WOMEN SOME MEN.
ARE LUCKY TO MAKE A HUNDRED TO
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A DAY.
AND YES SERVICES ARE NEEDED --
FOR PROSTITUTES BUT BASICALLY
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE FINDS UNFORTUNATELY JUST
BECOME ROUTINE THEY GET STAMPED
INTO THE PROCESS AND FEES AND
ASSESSMENTS GET SENT ON TOP OF
THEM SO NOW THE MINIMUM FINE.
IS FOR MISDEMEANORS A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS PLUS FEES AND
ASSESSMENTS BRINGS IT TO OVER
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IF THIS BILL IS ENACTED THE
MAXIMUM FEES GOING TO BE TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND AS IT SAYS IN THE ANALYSIS
WITH THE FINES AND FEES IT COULD
WELL TOP EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS --
I DON'T THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE
IN OAKLAND ARE GONNA BE FACED
WITH AN EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
FEE BUT I THINK THAT IT WILL
BECOME ROUTINE TO SLAP ANOTHER
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS ON THE TWO
HUNDRED EXISTING FEE.
AND THAT THAT WILL MAKE IT A
CHOICE FOR MY CLIENTS -- TO
EITHER PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE OR
PAY RENT OR PAY THE FINES AND WE
ALREADY KNOW.
FROM THE RESEARCH AND FROM
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND HEAR THE
HARMFUL EFFECTS OF TRYING -- TO
FINANCE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND SERVICES FOR VICTIMS
ON THE BACKS OF THE INDIGENT.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS DOES SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION AND ASK THAT YOU KEEP
THE MONEY AND THE PROSTITUTES
POCKETS THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SORRY TO SAY I AM AT
NO.
THANK YOU.
FOR ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE WAS CUNNINGHAM HAD
ADDRESS THE POINTS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION MY CLOTHES PLEASE.
THERE IS AN EXISTING FINE
ALREADY IN LAW OFFERED FOR THIS
OFFENSE -- SO WE'RE NOT CREATING
A NEW FIND WE'RE CHANGING THE
MAXIMUM CAP ON IT -- AND WERE RE
PURPOSING THE MONEY TO A
SPECIFIC PURPOSE ALONG THE
LOCALS TO USE IT FOR THAT
PURPOSE I TRY TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT SECONDLY.
PRIMARILY WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO
DO IN THIS AND WITH THIS BILL IS
TO GO AFTER JOHN'S AND IF YOU
LOOK AT ALL THE DATA AND
RESEARCH SOCIAL ECONOMICALLY THE
JOHNS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE.
DOING THE SOLICITING ARE ARE
PRETTY SOCIO ECONOMICALLY WELL
OFF PREDOMINATELY AS TO THIS
PURPOSE.
THE AND WE PUT EXPLICITLY IN THE
BILL THAT A JUDGE CAN WAIVE THIS
FINE ENTIRELY.
DOWN TO ZERO BASED ON ABILITY
INABILITY TO PAY THAT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE BILL SO THIS
GIVES US A TOOL TO TAKE MONEY
FROM THE JOHNS.
AND USE IT TO SUPPORT THE PEOPLE
THEY'VE BEEN EXPORTING.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- CHAIRS RECOMMEND
CALL THE ROLL.
ON EIGHTY SIX SIX THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER -- TO ANSWER I LACKEY
YEAH LACKEY AYE.
BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NO QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WICKS.
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PUT PASSES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
YOU'RE NOW GO THROUGH ALL THE
MEASURES SO THAT PEOPLE CAN VOTE.
SO ALL THE ALL THE CALLS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER TWO WAS ON CONSENT.
ADAM OR THREE HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
AT HONOR FIVE IT'S BEEN
AT A NUMBER SIX WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB SIX TWENTY
BY MR COOLEY BARRICADE HAND HI.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SIX
FORTY JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY SIX FORTY FIVE BY SOME
MEMBERS IRWIN BAUER-KAHAN HI
BARRICADE HAD AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
WAS NOT CONSENT.
I THE NUMBER TWELVE WAS JUST
DEFENSELESS.
ITEM THIRTEEN ON CONSENT.
ITEM FOURTEEN ON CONSENT.
ITEM FIFTEEN THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL AB SIX EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU LACKEY.
LACKEY NO DEEP SNOW DEEP NO
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA DEEP.
NUMBER SIXTEEN YOU SEE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO HI [inaudible]
DEEP I ITEM SEVENTEEN ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB EIGHT
THIRTY SEVEN BY HOLDEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY.
LACKEY I ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
THE MEASURE WAS ON CALL AB.
EIGHT NINETY THREE JONES SAWYER.
THE GLOBAL THAT'S NOT.
JONES SAWYER AYE QUIRK.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY WITH
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM TWENTY ONE THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL AB NINE OH SEVEN BY SOME
MEMBER GRAYSON LACKEY
[inaudible]
WHICH ONE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE
AB.
NINE OH SEVEN LACKEY AYE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
RAY S. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN
BARRICADE HAN HI BARRICADE HAD
AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM TWENTY THREE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY NINE BY MELENDEZ JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE QUIRK.
I DON'T TWENTY FIVE WAS
DISPENSED WITH.
I DON'T TWENTY SIX EIGHTY NINE
NINE SEVEN BY A FAMILY MEMBER
LOW DEEP [inaudible]
NO DEEP NO SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I ITEM TWENTY SEVEN WAS
ON CONSENT.
DONE.
TECH INCLUDES THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MEETING